[Music]
hey everyone welcome to this devops
tools full course by simply learn
in this complete course we'll learn
everything that we need regarding
several devops tools
we have matthews and chidanand to guide
us through this journey so let's look at
what's in store for us
we shall begin with having a basic
understanding of devops with a short
animated video
after that we'll dive deeper and
understand the basics of devops like its
relevance in the current scenario and
several devops phases
once we know devops we shall begin with
learning different devops tools in
detail
we shall learn about git followed by
github
and in the process
we shall learn about various git
commands
second we shall see what jenkins is
jenkins pipeline and how we install
jenkins
after that we'll move on to docker and
check out what docker is and docker
container is all about
we'll also learn about the different
processes and how to install docker
moving further we'll understand the
basics of kubernetes the difference
between kubernetes and docker and
kubernetes on aws
the following tool in the list will be
puppet where we shall know what puppet
is and why we use puppet and the process
to install it
moving forward we learn about ansible
and its installation process and what
are the benefits of using ansible
the last tool on our list is selenium
where we shall learn about selenium and
all about its sweet tools followed by
its installation processes
while we're learning all these tools we
shall understand them with the hands-on
demo making the understanding much more
effective and more accessible
finally when we have a piece of
deep knowledge regarding devops and
several devops tools we'll look at some
of the most prominent devops interview
questions that will help you excel in
your forthcoming devops interviews
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure you hit the subscribe button and
the bell icon to never miss an update
so without further ado let's begin
right from the start software
development comprise two different
departments the development team that
develops the plan designs and builds the
system from scratch and the operation
team for testing and implementation of
whatever is developed the operations
team gave the development team feedback
on any bugs that needed fixing and any
rework required invariably the
development team would be idle awaiting
feedback from the operations team
this undoubtedly extended timelines and
delayed the entire software development
cycle
there would be instances where the
development team moves on to the next
project while the operations team
continues to provide feedback for the
previous code
this meant weeks or even months for the
project to be closed and final code to
be developed now what if the two
departments came together and worked in
collaboration with each other what if
the wall of confusion was broken
and this is called the devops approach
the devops symbol resembles an infinity
sign suggesting that it is a continuous
process of improving efficiency and
constant activity the devops approach
makes companies adapt faster to updates
and development changes the teams can
now deliver quickly and the deployments
are more consistent and smooth though
there may be communication challenges
devops manages a streamlined flow
between the teams and makes the software
development process successful
the devops culture is implemented in
several phases with the help of several
tools let's have a look at these phases
the first phase is the planning phase
where the development team puts down a
plan keeping in mind the application
objectives that are to be delivered to
the customer
once the plan is made the coding begins
the development team works on the same
code and different versions of the code
are stored into a repository with the
help of tools like get and merged when
required this process is called version
control the code is then made executable
with tools like maven and gradle in the
build stage
after the code is successfully built it
is then tested for any bugs or errors
the most popular tool for automation
testing is selenium
once the code has passed several manual
and automated tests we can say that it
is ready for deployment and is sent to
the operations team
the operations team now deploys the code
to the working environment the most
prominent tools used to automate these
phases are ansible docker and kubernetes
after the deployment the product is
continuously monitored and nagios is one
of the top tools used to automate this
phase
the feedback received after this phase
is sent back to the planning phase
and this is what forms the core of the
devops life cycle that is the
integration phase
jenkins is the tool that sends the code
for building and testing if the code
passes the test it is sent for
deployment and this is referred to as
continuous integration
there are many tech giants and
organizations that have opted for the
devops approach for example amazon
netflix walmart facebook and adobe
netflix introduced its online streaming
service in 2007.
in 2014 it was estimated that a down
time for about an hour would cost
netflix 200 000
however now netflix can cope with such
issues
they opted for devops in the most
fantastic way
netflix developed a tool called the
simeon army that continuously created
bugs in the environment without
affecting the users
this chaos motivated the developers to
build a system that does not fall apart
when any such thing happens
so on this note here is a quiz for you
match the devops tool with the phase it
is used in
a
b
c
[Music]
d
none of the above
today more and more companies lean
towards automation with the aim of
reducing its delivery time and the gap
between its development and operations
teams to attain all of these there's
just one gateway
devops
and if you're also looking forward to
doing the same and excel in devops check
out simply learn's postgraduate program
in devops design and collaboration with
caltech ctme the program can help you
master several in-demand devops skills
and tools like continuous integration
and delivery devops on cloud kubernetes
docker and much more hello this is
matthew with simply learn and today
we're going to go through and introduce
you to devops we're going to go through
a number of key elements today the first
two will be reviewing models that you're
already probably using for delivering
solutions into your company and the most
popular one is waterfall followed by
agile then we'll look at devops and how
devops differs from the two models and
how it also borrows and leverages the
best of those models we'll go through
each of the phases that are used in
typical devops delivery and then the
tools used within those phases to really
improve the efficiencies within devops
finally we'll summarize the advantages
that devops brings to you and your teams
so let's go through waterfall so
waterfall is a traditional delivery
model that's been used for many decades
for delivering solutions not just i.t
solutions and digital solutions but even
way before that it has its history that
goes back to world war ii so waterfall
is a model that is used to capture
requirements and then cascade each key
deliverable through a series of
different stage gates that is used for
building out the solution so let's take
you through each of those stage gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand specifically what they
actually do and what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that requirements
analysis you'll build out a project
planning so you have an understanding of
what the level of work is needed to be
able to be successful in delivering the
solution after that you've got your plan
then you start doing the development and
that means that the programmers start
coding out their solution they build out
their applications to build out the
websites and this can take weeks or even
months to actually do all the work when
you've done your coding and development
then you send it to another group that
does testing and they'll do full
regression testing of your application
against the systems and databases that
integrate with your application you'll
test it against the actual code you'll
do manual testing you do ui testing and
then after you've delivered the solution
you go into maintenance mode which is
just kind of making sure that the
application keeps working there's any
security risks that you address those
security risks the problem you have
though is that there are some challenges
however that you have with the waterfall
model the cascading deliveries and those
complete and separated stage gates means
that it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and if the project has
been running for six months and they've
gone hey we need to change something
that means that we have to almost
restart the whole project it's very
expensive and it's very time consuming
also if you spend weeks and months away
from your clients and you deliver a
solution that they are only just going
to see after you spend a lot of time
working on it they could be pointing out
things that are in the actual final
application that they don't want or are
not implemented correctly or lead to
just general unhappiness the challenge
you then have is if you want to add back
in the client's feedback to restart the
whole waterfall cycle again so the
client will come back to you with a list
of changes and then you go back and you
have to start your programming and you
have to then start your testing process
again and just you're really adding in
lots of additional time into the project
so using watford model companies have
soon come to realize that you know the
clients just aren't able to get their
feedback in quickly effectively it's
very expensive to make changes once the
teams have started working and the
requirements in today's digital world is
that solutions simply must be delivered
faster and this has led for a specific
change in agile and we start
implementing the agile model so the
agile model allows programmers to create
prototypes and get those prototypes to
the client with the requirements faster
and the client is able to then send the
requirements back to the programmer with
feedback this allows us to create what
we call a feedback loop where we're able
to get information to the client and the
client can get back to the development
team much faster typically when we're
actually going through this process
we're looking at the engagement cycle
being about two weeks and so it's much
faster than the traditional waterfall
approach and so we can look at each
feedback loop as comprising of four key
elements we have the planning where we
actually sit down with the client to
understand what they're looking for we
then have coding and testing that is
building out the code and the solution
that is needed for the client and then
we review with the client the changes
that have happened but we do all this in
a much tighter cycle that we call a
sprint and that typically a sprint will
last for about two weeks some companies
run sprints every week some run every
four weeks it's up to you as a team to
decide how long you want to actually run
a sprint but typically it's two weeks
and so every two weeks the client is
able to provide feedback into that loop
and so you were able to move quickly
through iterations and so if we get to
the end of sprint two and the client
says hey you know what we need to make a
change you can make those changes
quickly and effectively for sprint three
what we have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call a product backlog and this will
be just a whole bunch of different
features and they may be small features
or bug fixes all the way up to large
features that may actually span over
multiple sprints but when you go through
the sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually implement successfully into
their sprint plan and then once you
actually start running your sprint again
it's a two-week activity you meet every
single day to with the actual sprint
team to ensure that everybody is staying
on track and if there's any blockers
that those blockers are being addressed
effectively and immediately the goal at
the end of the two weeks is to have a
deliverable product that you can put in
front of the customer and the customer
can then do a review the key advantages
you have of running a sprint with agile
is that the client requirements are
better understood because the client is
really integrated into the scrum team
they're there all the time and the
product is delivered much faster than
with a traditional waterfall model
you're delivering features at the end of
each sprint versus waiting weeks months
or in some cases years for a waterfall
project to be completed however there
are also some distinct disadvantages the
product itself really doesn't get tested
in a production environment it's only
been tested on the developer computers
and it's really hard when you're
actually running agile for the sprint
team to actually build out a solution
easily and effectively on their
computers to mimic the production
environment and the developers and the
operations team are running in separate
silos so you have your development team
running their sprint and actually
working to build out the features but
then when they're done at the end of
their sprint and they want to do a
release they kind of fling it over the
wall at the operations team and then
it's the operations team job to actually
install the software and make sure that
the environment is running in a stable
fashion that is really difficult to do
when you have the two teams really not
working together so here we have is a
breakdown of that process with the
developers submitting their work to the
operations team for deployment and then
the operations team may submit their
work to the production service but what
if there is an error what if there was a
setup configuration error with the
developers test environment that doesn't
match the production environment there
may be a dependency that isn't there
there may be a link to an api that
doesn't exist in production and so you
have these challenges that the
operations team are constantly faced
with and their challenge is that they
don't know how the code works
so this is where devops really comes in
and let's dig into how devops which is
developers and operators working
together is the key for successful
continuous delivery so devops is as an
evolution of the agile model the agile
model really is great for gathering
requirements and for developing and
testing out your solutions and what we
want to be able to do is kind of address
that challenge and that gap between the
ops team and the dev team and so with
devops what we're doing is bringing
together the operations team and the
development team into a single team and
they are able to then work more
seamlessly together because they are
integrated to be able to build out
solutions that are being tested in a
production-like environment so that when
we actually deploy we know that the code
itself will work the operations team is
then able to focus on what they're
really good at which is analyzing the
production environment and being able to
provide feedback to the developers on
what is being successful so we're able
to make adjustments in our code that
it's based on data so let's step through
the different phases of a devops team so
typically you'll see that the devops
team will actually have eight phases now
this is somewhat similar to agile and
what i'd like to point out at time is
that again agile and devops are very
closely related that agile and devops
are closely related delivery models that
you can use with devops it's really just
extending that model with the key phases
that we have here so let's step through
each of these key phases so the first
phase is planning and this is where we
actually sit down with a business team
and we go through and understand what
their goals are the second stage is as
you can imagine and this is where it's
all very similar to agile is that the
coders actually start coding but they
typically they'll start using tools such
as git which is a distributed version
control software it makes it easier for
developers to all be working on the same
code base rather than bits of the code
that is rather than them working on bits
of the code that they are responsible
for so the goal with using tools such as
git is that each developer always has
the current and latest version of the
code you then use tools such as maven
and gradle as a way to consistently
build out your environment and then we
also use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and junit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get environment we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another pointer
here is that the tools that we're
listing here these are all open source
tools these are tools that any team can
start using we want to have tools that
control and manage the deployment of
code into the production environments
and then finally tools such as ansible
and chef will actually operate and
manage those production environments so
that when code comes to them that that
code is compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can
actually zero in on spikes and issues
that are relevant to either the code or
changing consumer habits on the site so
let's step through some of those tools
that we have in the devops environment
so here we have is a breakdown of the
devops tools that we have and again one
of the things i want to point out is
that these tools are open source tools
there are also many other tools this is
just really a selection of some of the
more popular tools that are being used
but it's quite likely that you're
already using some of these tools today
you may already be using jenkins you may
already be using git but some of the
other tools really help you create a
fully scriptable environment so that you
can actually start scripting out your
entire devops toolset this really helps
when it comes to speeding up your
delivery because the more you can
actually script out of the work that
you're doing the more effective you can
be at running automation against those
scripts and the more effective you can
be at having a consistent experience
so let's step through this devops
process so we go through and we have a
continuous delivery which is our plan
code build and test environment so what
happens if you want to make a release
well the first thing you want to do is
send out your files to the build
environment and you want to be able to
test the code that you've been created
because we're scripting everything in
our code from the actual unit testing
being done to the all the way through to
the production environment because we're
testing all of that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can send that code right back
to the developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix that with information that is
real on the either the code or the
production environment if however your
code passes the scripting test it can
then be deployed and once it's out to
deployment you can then start monitoring
that environment what this provides you
is the opportunity to speed up your
delivery so you go from the waterfall
model which is weeks months or even
years between releases to agile which is
two weeks or four weeks depending on
your sprint cadence to where you are
today with devops where you can actually
be doing multiple releases every single
day so there are some significant
advantages and there are companies out
there that are really zeroing in on
those advantages if we take any one of
these companies such as google google
any given day will actually process 50
to 100 new releases on their website
through their devops teams in fact they
have some great videos on youtube that
you can find out on how their devops
teams work netflix is also a similar
environment now what's interesting with
netflix is that netflix have really
fully embraced devops within their
development team and so they have a
devops team and netflix is a completely
digital company so they have software on
phones on smart tvs on computers and on
websites interestingly though the devops
team for netflix is only 70 people and
when you consider that a third of all
internet traffic on any given day is
from netflix it's really a reflection on
how effective devops can be when you can
actually manage that entire business
with just 70 people so there are some
key advantages that devops has it's the
actual time to create and deliver
software is dramatically reduced
particularly compared to waterfall
complexity and maintenance is also
reduced because you're automating and
scripting out your entire environment
and you're improving the communication
between all your teams so teams don't
feel like they're in separate silos but
that are actually working cohesively
together and that there is continuous
integration and continuous delivery so
that your consumer your customer is
constantly being delighted a very warm
welcome to all our viewers i'm anjali
from simply learn and today i'll be
showing you the installation for git on
windows so we'll start by downloading
and installing git on our system we'll
then have a look at the git bash
interface we'll type in some basic git
commands next we'll create a local
repository that is we'll create a
repository on a local machine we'll then
connect to a remote repository and
finally we'll push the file onto github
first things first we need to download
and install git so download git for
windows and i'll select the second link
so
2.19.1 which is the most latest version
of kit that's the one we want for
windows system choose your version so
mine is a 64-bit system and it's
downloading so this will take a while
so git is
on our system
click here
run
so go to next we don't have to change
this path
just so just click on in quick launch
and on desktop
next
next again next nothing to change here
either
and install so now git is getting
installed on our system
so we don't need to view the release
notes we just want to launch the git
bash
so let's just tick that and then click
on finish
and your git bash interface appears here
so we are on the master branch the first
thing we do is we'll check the version
for our git so the command is git dash
dash version
and as you can see version
2.19.1 on our windows system which is
exactly what we just downloaded we'll
now explore the help command so let's
just type git help config so config is
another command and as i hit enter the
manual page for the second command
opened up which is config so what help
command does is that it provides the
manual or the help page for the command
just following it
so in case you have any doubts regarding
how a command is used what a command is
used for or the various syntax of the
command you can always use the help
command now there's another syntax for
using the help command itself which is
git config dash dash help enter this
does the exact same thing as you can see
now that we looked at the help command
let's begin by creating a local
directory so mkdir
test
now test is my new directory i'll move
into this directory so cd test
great so now that we are inside our test
directory let's initialize this
directory so git
init is the command for initializing the
directory and as you can see as you can
see the path here this is the local path
where a directory is created so i'll
just show you the directory test and
it's completely empty
what we do now is we'll create a text
file within this new directory that we
created so new text document and i'll
just name this demo i'll open this and
just put in some dummy content
so hello simply done
save this file and go back to your bash
interface let's just check the status
now so git status and as you can see
our file has appeared it's visible but
nothing is committed yet so this means
that we have not made any change to a
file through the git tool itself so the
next thing that we are going to do is we
will be adding demo to our current
directory the next command that we will
be applying is the commit command and
when you add certain files to the
current directory the comment command is
applied on all the above directories so
git commit minus m and a message that
will appear once the file is committed
so as you can see one file is changed
and one insertion
just clear the screen next thing we need
to do is we need to link our git to a
github account so the command for doing
that is git config
global user dot username
and this will be followed by our
username so let me just show you my
github account
so this is my github profile and my
username is
simplylearn.github so guys before you
begin this procedure just make a github
account type in my username here simply
learn github and enter and there you go
a git is successfully linked with github
next thing we do is we'll just open our
github
and we'll create a new repository give a
repository name so i'll name it test
underscore demo and create repository
great so our repository is created this
is our remote repository what we do next
is just copy the link and then go back
to your bash interface
now we need to link our remote and our
local repository
so get remote origin and then paste
the http link and now that our local
repository and our remote repository are
linked we can push our local file onto
our remote repository so the command for
doing that is git
push origin master as we are on the
master branch
and that's done so now let's move back
to github i'll just click on test demo
and as you can see here our local file
has been pushed to our remote repository
with that we have successfully completed
our demo thanks anjali now matthew and
chadanan will take you through the
remaining part of the course hello this
is matthew from simply learn and today
we're going to go through and explain
how you can use git for your software
development so what are we going to
cover today so we're going to introduce
the concept of version control that you
will use within your devops environment
then we'll talk about the different
tools are available in a distributed
version control system will highlight a
product called git which is typically
used for version control today and
you'll also go through what are the
differences between get and github you
may have used github in the past or
other products like get lab and we'll
explain what are the differences between
git and git and services such as github
and git lab will break out the
architecture of what a get process looks
like and how do you go through and
create forks and clones how do you have
collaborators being added into your
projects how do you go through the
process of branching merging and
rebasing your project and what are the
list of commands that are available to
you in get finally i'll take you through
a demo on how you can actually run git
yourself and in this instance use the
software of git against a public service
such as github all right let's talk a
little bit about version control systems
so you may have already been using a
virtual control system within your
environment today you may have used
tools such as microsoft's team
foundation services but essentially the
use of a version control system allows
people to be able to have files that are
all stored in a single repository so if
you're working on developing a new
program that such as a website or an
application you would store all of your
version control software in a single
repository now what happens is that if
somebody wants to make changes to the
code they would check out all of the
code in the repository to make the
changes and then there would be an
addendum added to that so um there will
be the version one changes that you had
then the person would then uh later on
check out that code and then be a
version two and add it to that code and
so you keep adding on versions of that
code the bottom line is that eventually
you'll have people being able to use
your code and that your code will be
stored in a centralized location however
the challenge you're running is that
it's very difficult for large groups to
work simultaneously within a project the
benefits of a vcs system a version
control system
demonstrates that you're able to store
multiple versions of a solution in a
single repository now let's take a step
at some of the challenges that you have
with traditional version control systems
and see how they can be addressed with
distributed version control so in a
distributed version control environment
what we're looking at is being able to
have the code shared across a team of
developers so if there are two or more
people working on a software package
they need to be able to effectively
share that code amongst themselves so
that they constantly are working on the
latest piece of code so a key part of a
distributed version control system
that's different to just a traditional
version control system is that all
developers have the entire code on their
local systems and they try and keep it
updated all the time it is the role of
the distributed vcs server to ensure
that each client and we have a developer
here and developer here and developer
here and each of those our clients have
the latest version of the software and
then that each person can then share the
software in a peer-to-peer like approach
so that as changes are being made into
the server of changes to the code then
those changes are then being
redistributed to all of the development
team the tool to be able to do an
effective distributed vcs environment is
get now you may remember that we
actually covered git in a previous video
and we'll reference that video for you
so we start off with our remote git
repository and people are making updates
to the copy of their code into a local
environment that local environment can
be updated manually and then
periodically pushed out to the git
repository so you're always pushing out
the latest code that you've code changes
you made into the repository and then
from the repository you're able to pull
back the latest updates and so your git
repository becomes the kind of the
center of the universe for you and then
updates are able to be pushed up and
pulled back from there what this allows
you to be able to accomplish is that
each person will always have the latest
version of the code so what is get git
is a distributed version control tool
used for source code management so
github is the remote server for that
source code management and your
development team can connect their get
client to that
remote hub server git is used to track
the changes of the source code and
allows large teams to work
simultaneously with each other it
supports a non-linear development
because of thousands of parallel
branches and has the ability to handle
large projects efficiently so let's talk
a little bit about git versus github so
get is a software tool whereas github is
a service and i'll show you how those
two look in the moment you install the
software tool for git locally on your
system whereas github because it is a
service is actually hosted on a website
get is actually the software that used
to manage different versions of source
code whereas github is used to have a
copy of the local repository stored on
the service on the website itself get
provides command line tools that allow
you to interact with your files whereas
git help has a graphical interface that
allows you to check in and check out
files so let me just show you the two
tools here so here i am at the git
website and this is the website you
would go to to download the latest
version of git and again git is a
software package that you install on
your computer that allows you to be able
to do version control in a peer-to-peer
environment for that peer-to-peer
environment to be successful however you
need to be able to store your files in a
server somewhere and typically a lot of
companies will use a service such as git
hub as a way to be able to store your
files so git can communicate effectively
with github there are actually many
different companies that provide similar
service to github git lab is another
popular service but you also find that
development tools such as microsoft
visual studio are also incorporating git
commands into their tools so the latest
version of visual studio team services
also provides this same ability but
github it has to be remembered is a
place where we actually store our files
and can very easily create public and
shareable is a place where we can store
our files and create public shareable
projects you can come to github and you
can do a search on projects you can see
at the moment i'm doing a lot of work on
blockchain but you can actually search
on the many hundreds of projects here in
fact i think there's something like over
a hundred thousand projects being
managed on github at the moment that
number's probably actually much larger
than that and so if you are working on a
project i would certainly encourage you
to start at github to see if somebody's
already maybe done a prototype that
they're sharing or they have an open
source project that they want to share
that's already available and in github
certainly if you're doing anything with
them azure you'll find that there are
thousands 45 000 azure projects
currently being worked on interestingly
enough github was recently acquired by
microsoft and microsoft is fully
embracing open source technologies so
that's essentially the difference
between git and github one is a piece of
software and that's git and one is a
service that supports the ability of
using the software and that's github so
let's dig deeper into the actual git
architecture itself so the working
directory is the folder where you are
currently working on your git project
and we'll do a demo later on where you
can actually see how we can actually
simulate each of these steps so you
start off with your working directory
where you store your files and then you
add your files to a staging area where
you are getting ready to commit your
files back to the main branch on your
git project you will want to push out
all your changes to a local repository
after you've made your changes and these
will commit those files and get them
ready for synchronization with the
service and will then push your services
out to the remote repository an example
of a remote repository would be github
later when you want to update your code
before you write any more code you would
pull the latest changes from the remote
repository so that your copy of your
local software is always the latest
version of the software that the rest of
the team is working on one of the things
that you can do is as you're working on
new features within your project you can
create branches you can merge your
branches with the mainline code you can
do lots of really creative things that
ensure that that a the code remains at
very high quality and b that you're able
to seamlessly add in new features
without breaking the core code so let's
step through some of the concepts that
we have available and get so let's talk
about forking and cloning in kit so both
of these terms are quite old terms when
it comes to development but forking is
certainly a term that goes way way way
back um long before we had distributed
cvs systems such as the ones that we're
using with git to fork a piece of
software is a particular open source
project you would take the project and
create a copy of that project and but
then you would then associate a new team
and new people around that project so it
becomes a separate project in entirety a
clone and this is important when it
comes to working with git a clone is
identical with the same teams and same
structuring as the main project itself
so when you download the code you're
downloading exact copy of that code with
all the same security and access rights
as the main code and then you can then
check that code back in and potentially
your code because it is identical could
potentially become the main line code in
the future now that typically doesn't
happen your changes are the ones that
merge into the main branch but also but
you do have that potential where your
code could become the main code with git
you can also add collaborators that can
work on the project which is essential
for projects where particularly you have
large teams this works really well when
you have product teams where the teams
themselves are self-empowered you can do
a concept what's called branching and
get and so say for instance you are
working on a new feature that new
feature and the main version of the
project have to still work
simultaneously so what you can do is you
can create a branch of your code so you
can actually work on the new feature
whereas the rest of the team continue to
work on the main branch of the the
project itself and then later you can
merge the two together pull from remote
is the concept of being able to pull in
services software the team is working on
from a remote server and get rebase is
the concept of being able to take a
project and re-establish a new start
from the project so you may be working a
project where there have been many
branches and the team has been working
for quite some time on different areas
and maybe you kind of losing control of
what the true main branch is you may
choose to rebase your project and what
that means though is that anybody that's
working on a separate branch will not be
able to branch their code back into the
mainline branch so going through the
process of a get rebase essentially
allows you to create a new start for
where you're working on your project so
let's go through forks and clones so you
want to go through the process so you
want to go ahead and fork the code that
you're working on so let's use this
scenario that one of your team wants to
go ahead and add a new change to the
project the team member may say yeah go
ahead and you know create a separate
fork of the actual project so what does
that look like so when you actually go
ahead and create a fork of the
repository you actually go and you can
take the version of the mainline branch
but then you take it completely offline
into a local repository for you to be
able to work from and you can take the
mainline code and you can then work on a
local version of the code separate from
the mainland branch it's now a separate
fork collaborators is the ability to
have team members working on a project
together so if you know someone is
working on a piece of code and they see
some errors in the code that you've
created none of us are perfect at
writing code i know i've certainly made
errors in my code it's great to have
other team members that have your back
and can come in and check and see what
they can do to improve the code so to do
that you have to then add them as a
collaborator now you do that in github
you can give them permission within
github itself that's really easy to do
super visual interface that allows you
to do the work quickly and easily and
depending on the type of permissions you
want to give them sometimes it can be
very limited permissions it may be just
to be able to read the files sometimes
it's being able to go in and make all
the changes you can go through all the
different permission settings on github
to actually see what you can do but
you'll be able to make changes so that
people can actually have access to your
repository and then you as a team can
then start working together on the same
code let's step through branching in git
so suppose you're working on an
application but you want to add in a new
feature and this is very typical within
a devops environment so to do that you
can create a new branch and build a new
feature on that branch so here you have
your main application on what's known as
the master branch and then you can then
create a sub branch that runs in
parallel which has your feature you can
then develop your feature and then merge
it back into the master branch at a
later point in time now the benefit you
have here is that by default we're all
working on the master branch so we
always have the latest code the circles
that we have here on the screen show
various different commits that have been
made so we can keep track of the master
branch and then the branches that have
come off which have the new features and
they can be many branches and get so get
keeps you the new features you're
working on in separate branches until
you're ready to merge them back in with
the main branch so let's talk a little
bit about that merge process
so you're starting with the master
branch which is the blue line here and
then here we have a separate parallel
branch which has the new features so if
we're to look at this process the base
commit of feature b is the branch f is
what's going to merge back into the
master branch and it has to be said
there can be so many divergent branches
but eventually you want to have
everything merged back into the master
branch let's step through get rebase so
again we have a similar situation where
we have a branch that's being worked in
parallel to the master branch and we
want to do a get rebase so we're at
stage c and what we've decided is that
we want to reset the project so that
everything from here on out with along
the master branch is the standard
product however this means that any work
that's been done in parallel as a
separate branch will be adding in new
features along this new rebased
environment now the benefit you have by
going through the rebase process
is that you're reducing the amount of
storage space that's required for when
you have so many branches it's a great
way to just reduce your total footprint
for your entire project so get rebase is
the process of combining a sequence of
commits to form a new base commit and
the prime reason for rebasing is to
maintain a linear project history when
you rebase you unplug a branch and
re-plug it in on the tip of another
branch and usually you do that on the
master branch and that will then become
the new master branch the goal of
rebasing is to take all the commits from
a feature branch and put it together in
a single master branch it makes it the
project itself much easier to manage
let's talk a little bit about pull from
remote suppose there are two developers
working together on an application the
concept of having a remote repository
allows the code to the two developers
will be actually then checking in their
code into a remote repository that
becomes a centralized location for them
to be able to store their code it
enables them to stay updated on the
recent changes to the repository because
they'll be able to pull the latest
changes from that remote repository so
that they are ensuring that as
developers are always working
on the latest code so you can pull any
changes that you have made to your
forked remote repository to your local
repository the command to be able to do
that is written here and we'll go
through a demo of how to actually do
that command in a little bit good news
is if there are no changes you'll get a
notification saying that you're already
up to date and if there is a change it
will merge those changes to your local
repository and you get a list of the
changes that have been made remotely so
let's step through some of the commands
that we have in git so git and it
initializes a local git repository on
your hard drive git add adds one or more
files to your staging area get commit
dash m commit message is a commit
changes the get command commits changes
to head up so the git command commits
changes to your local staging area get
status checks the status of your current
repository and lists the files you have
changed get locked provides a list of
all the commits made on your current
branch get diff use the changes that
you've made to the file so you can
actually have files next to each other
you can actually see
the differences between the two files a
git push origin branch name so the name
of your branch command will push the
branch to the remote repository so that
others can use it and this is what you
do at the end of your project git config
global username will tell get who you
are by configuring the author name and
we'll go through that in a moment get
config global user email we'll tell get
the author of by the email id get cloned
creates a get repository copy from a
remote source
git remote add origin server connects
the local repository to the remote
server and adds the server to be able to
push to it get branch and then the
branch name will create a new branch for
you to create a new feature that you may
be working on git check out and then the
branch name will allow you to switch
from one branch to another branch git
merge branch name will merge a branch
into the active branch so if you're
working on a new feature you're going to
merge that into the main branch a get
rebase will reapply commits on top of
another base tip and get rebase or
reapply commits on top of another base
tip and these are just some of the
popular get commands there are some more
but you can certainly dig into those as
you're working through using get so
let's go ahead and run a demo using get
so now we are going to do a demo using
get on our local machine and github as
the remote repository for this to work
i'm going to be using a couple of tools
first i'll have the deck open as we've
been using up to this point now the
second is i'm going to have my terminal
window also available and let me bring
that over so you can actually see this
and the terminal window is actually
running get bash as the software in the
background which you'll need to download
and install you can also run git batch
locally on your windows computer as well
and in addition i'll also have the
github repository that we're using for
simply learn
already set up and ready to go all right
so let's get started so the first thing
we want to do is create a local
repository so let's go ahead and do
exactly that so the local repository is
going to reside in my development folder
that i have on my local computer and for
me to be able to do that i need to
create a drive in that folder so i'm
going to go ahead and change the
directory so i'm actually going to be in
that folder before i actually create and
make the new folder so i'm going to go
ahead and change directory
and now i'm in the development directory
i'm going to go ahead and create a new
folder
and that's gone ahead and created a new
folder called hello world
i'm going to move my cursor so that i'm
actually in the hello world folder
and now that i'm in the hello world
folder i can now initialize this folder
as a get repository
so i'm going to use the git command init
to initialize and let's go ahead and
initialize that folder so let's see
what's happened so here i have my hello
world folder that i've created and
you'll now see that we have a hidden
folder in there which is called dot get
and we expand that we can actually see
all of the different subfolders that git
repository will create so let's just
move that over a little bit so we can
see the rest of the work
and now if we check on our folder here
we actually see this is users matthew
development hello world dot get and that
matches up with hidden folder here
so we're going to go ahead and create a
file called readme.txt
in our folder so here is our hello world
folder and i'm going to go ahead and
using my text editor which happens to be
sublime
i'm going to create a file and it's
going to have in there text hello world
and i'm going to call this one
readme.txt
if i go to my hello world folder you'll
see that we have the readme.txt
file actually in the folder what's
interesting is if i select the getstatus
command what it'll actually show me is
that this file has not yet been added to
the commits yet for this project so even
though the file is actually in the
folder it doesn't mean that it's
actually part of the project for us to
do that we actually have to go and
select
for us to actually commit the file we
have to go into our terminal window and
we can use the git status to actually
read the files that we have there so
let's go ahead and use the get status
command and it's going to tell us that
this file has not been committed
you can use this with any folder to see
which files and subfolders have been
committed and what we can now do is we
can
go and actually add the readme file so
let's go ahead i'm just going to say at
git
add so the git command is add readme dot
txt so that then adds that file into our
main
project and we want to then commit those
files into the main repositories history
and so to that do that we'll hit the the
get command commit and we'll do a
message
in that commit and this one will be
first commit
and it has committed that project what's
interesting is we can now go back into
readme file and i can change this so we
can go
hello get
git is a very popular
version control
solution
and we'll
we'll save that
now what we can do is we can actually go
and see if we have made differences to
the readme text so to do that we'll use
the diff command for get so we do get
deaf
and it gives us two
releases the first is what the original
text was which is hello world and then
what we have afterwards is what is now
the new text in green which has replaced
the original text
so what we're going to do now is you
want to go ahead and create an account
on github we already have one
so what we're going to do is we're going
to match the account from github with
our local account so to do that we're
going to go ahead and say get config
and we're going to do dash and it's
going to be a global user dot name and
we put in our username that we use for
github in this instance we're using the
simply learn
dash
github account name
and under the github account you can go
ahead and create a new repository name
in this instance we call the repository
hello dash world
and what we want to do is connect the
local github account with the remote
helloworld.getaccount
and we do that by using this command
from get which is our remote connection
and so let's go ahead and type that in
open this up so we can see the whole
thing so we can type in get
remote
add
origin
https
backslash
github
dot com
slash
simply learn
dash github and you have to get this
typed in correctly when you're typing in
the location hello
dash world dot get
that creates the connection to your
hello world account
and now we want to do is we want to push
the files to the remote location using
the get push command commit get push
origin
master
so we're going to go ahead and connect
to our local remote github
so i'm just going to bring up my
terminal window again and so let's
select git remote add origin
and we'll connect to the remote location
github.com
simply
learn dash
github
slash
hello dash world dot get
oh we actually have already connected so
we're connected to that successfully and
now we're going to push the master
gish so git
push
origin
master
and everything is connected and
successful
and if we go out to github now
we can actually see that our file was
updated just a few minutes ago
so what we can actually do now is we can
go and fork a project from github and
clone it locally so we're going to use
the
fork tool that's actually available on
github let me show you where that is
located
and
here is our branching tool it's actually
changed more recently with a new ui
interface
and once complete we'll be able to then
pull a copy of that to our account using
the forks new http url address
so let's go ahead and do that
so we're going to go ahead and create a
fork of our project now to do that you
would normally go in when you go into
your project you'll see that there are
fork options in the top right hand
corner of the screen now right now i'm
actually logged in with the default
primary account for this project so i
can't actually for project as i'm
working on the main branch however if i
come in with a separate id and here i am
i have a different id and so i'm
actually pretending i'm somebody else i
can actually come in and select the fork
option and create a fork of this project
and this will take just a few seconds to
actually create the fork
and there we are we have gone ahead and
created the fork
so you want to set clone or download
with this and so this is the
i select
i'll actually give me the web address i
can actually show you what that looks
like i'll open up my text editor
which doesn't correct
i guess that is correct
so i'm going to copy that
and
i can fork the project locally and clone
it locally i can change the directory so
i can create a new directory that i'm
going to put my files in and then post
in that content into that file that so i
can now actually have multiple versions
of the same code running on my computer
i can then go into the fault content
and use the patchwork command
to achieve
so i can create a copy of
that code that we've just created and we
call it that's a clone and we can create
a new folder that we're actually putting
the work in and we could for whatever
reason we wanted to we could call this
folder patchwork and that would be maybe
a new feature and then we can then paste
in the url of the new uh directory that
has the forked work in it and now at
this point we've now pulled in and
created a clone of the original content
and so this allows us to go ahead and
fork out all of the work for our project
onto our computer so we can then develop
our work separately
so now what we can actually do is we can
actually create a branch of the fork
that we've actually pulled in onto our
computer so we can actually then create
our own code that runs in
that separate branch and so we want to
check out um the the branch and then
push the origin branch
down to our computer
this will give us the opportunity to
then add our collaborators so we can
actually then go over to
github and we can actually come in and
add in our collaborators
and we'll do that under settings and
select collaborators and here we can
actually see we have different
collaborators that have been added into
the project and you can actually then
request people to be added via their
github name or by email address
or by their full name
one of the things that you want to be
able to do is ensure that you're always
keeping the code that you're working on
fully up to date by pulling in all the
changes from your collaborators
you can create a new branch and then
make changes emerged into the master
branch now to do that you would create a
folder and then that folder in this
instance would be called test we would
then move our cursor into the folder
called test and then initialize that
folder so let's go ahead and do that so
let's call create a new folder and we're
going to first of all change our root
folder and we're going to go to
development
and we're going to create a new folder
we call it test and we're going to move
into the test folder and we will
initialize
that folder
and we're going to move some files into
that test folder
call this one test one
and then we're gonna do file save as and
this one's gonna be test
two and now we're going to commit those
files
okay add
that kit add and then we'll use the
dot to pull in all files
and then git
commit
dash m
files
committed
make sure i'm in the right folder here i
don't think i was
and now that i'm in the correct folder
let's go ahead and
and hit
commit
and it's gone ahead and edit those files
and so we can see the two files that
were created have been added into the
master
and we can now go ahead and create a new
branch
and call this one git
test underscore
branch
and let's go ahead and create a third
file to go into that folder
this is
file
three
let's do file save as i'll call this one
test3.txt
and we'll go ahead and add
that file and to get
add
test3.txt
and
we're going to move from the master
branch to the test branch
git
check
out test underscore
branch
i switched to the test branch
and we'll be able to list out all of the
files that are in the tech in that
branch now
and we want to go through and merge the
files into one area so let's go ahead
and we'll do git
merge test underscore
branch
as well we've already updated everything
so that's good so otherwise it would
tell us what we would be merging
and now all the files are merged
successfully into the master branch
there we go all merged together
fantastic
and so what we're going to do now is
move from master branch to test branch
so get
check out
test underscore
branch
and we can modify
the files the test3 file that we took
out
and
pull that file up
and we can
now
modify
and we can then
commit
that file
back
in
and we've actually been able to then
commit the file with one changes and now
we've seen it's text free change that
was made
now we can now go through the process of
checking the file back in switching back
to the master branch and ensuring that
everything is in sync correctly
we may at one point want to rebase all
the work is kind of a hard thing you
want to do but it will allow you to
allow for managing for changes in the
future so let's switch to it back to our
test branch
which i think we're actually on we're
going to create two more files
let's go to our folder here and let's go
copy those
and that's created
we'll rename those tests
for
and
five
and so we now have additional files
and we're gonna add those into
our branch that we're working on
so we're going to go and select
get add
dash a
and we're going to commit those files
get
commit
dash
a
dash m
adding
two new
files
and it's added in the two new files
so we have all of our files now we can
actually list them out and we have all
the files that are in the branch
and we'll switch them to our master
branch
we want to rebase the master
so we do get rebase
master
and that will then give us the command
that everything is now completely up to
date
we can go
get
checkout
master to switch to the master account
this will allow us to then
continue through and rebase the test
branch and then list all the files that
are all in the same area
so let's go
get rebase
test underscore
branch
and now we can list and there we have
all of our files listed incorrectly
hello and welcome to git commands my
name is chidanand and i am with the
simply learn team today i am going to
cover few essential git commands and
walk you through a demonstration for
most of it i begin by installing a git
bash or the git client and configuring
it for its first time usage once i'm
done with configuring the git client i'm
going to spin up few repositories
locally and work on these repositories
using git commands once i'm happy with
my local changes i'm going to commit few
of them and then push these changes to a
git server of my choice for today's
demonstration i plan to use github.com
which is a cloud hosted free service and
it provides free account registrations
for anyone eventually i will cover few
topics regarding git branching and
merging because these two in my opinion
are the killer features of the git
distributed version control tool kit is
one of the most popular distributed
version control tools of recent times
and like any other distributed version
control tool it allows us to perform
various version control tasks without
really needing a network connection
before i jump into my demonstration let
me spend some time explaining to you the
git client server working model what
does it take for a couple of users to
collaborate and start working with git
the bare minimal thing that any user
would need in order to start working
with kit is something called as git bash
or the git client this comes as an
installer for all popular operating
systems like windows all flavors of
windows linux mac os and other operating
systems so once you install git bash you
get a command line utility using which
you can fire up your git commands and
ensure that you can bring up
repositories you can work with these
repositories by adding files to it
committing changes to it and all those
git commands would work perfectly well
so you can bring up a small repository
and you can work with your repository
using this git bash but what does it
take for you to share this repository
with another user who has also got git
bash installed on his system this is
where you would need something called as
a gig server
so for user one or one user to share his
repository with another user he would
need to collaborate using something
called as a git server so in the present
market there are a bunch of git servers
which are popularly available some of
them are free some of them come with
cost because they are licensed a bunch
of these servers that i can think of are
github which is one of the most popular
kit servers that is around in the market
for a long time now it comes with two
variants one is the cloud hosted one
which is the github.com and then the
other one is an enterprise server which
comes as a black box that can be
installed into your data centers so
typically organizations who don't want
their source code to be put up on the
cloud but go for this github enterprise
servers wherein they buy this servers
and these servers are hosted on their
data centers other popular variant of
the git server is bitbucket this is from
the famous atlassian products and it
integrates very well with all other
atlassian products like jira in recent
times there's one other variant of the
git server called gitlab which is
getting very very popular these days
because gitlab not just provides a git
server it also provides something called
as a runner this is a part of the
continuous integration strategy where as
soon as you have a source code check-in
that is going in you have this runner
that kicks up and builds your particular
project so all these are bundled
together in a git lab and git lab also
provides you with a community edition
which is almost free of cost having said
that there are a bunch of these tools
available for my demonstration what i'm
going to do is i've already registered
myself on the github.com by providing my
username and my password and i'm going
to use a free account so whatever
repositories that i'm going to put up on
this server is all public by default so
i want to register myself by using my
username or my email id and my password
so this set of authentication is also
referred to as https authentication
so in order for me to share my
repository with say user 2 the first
thing that i got to do was have an
access to a git server where both user 1
and user 2 are set up so once i have
that i can push my repository onto this
server and provide right kind of access
so that user 2 or the other developer
who wishes to collaborate with me on
this repository can use his credentials
as long as he's registered properly on
the git server he can use his
credentials and pull down this
repository and work with this repository
so this is the https way of
authenticating and sharing repositories
another popular way of sharing
repositories or working with each other
is called as ssh authentication as many
of you would know ssh means nothing but
creation of a private and a public key a
bunch of keys public and private are
created on the client machine while i
create a keys i will be asked for a
passphrase i need to type in a
passphrase and remember my passphrase
and then i take this public key and kind
of post it on to my account within my
git server so that whenever i'm going to
connect next time using my command
prompt or any of the tools it's going to
challenge me for my passphrase as long
as i remember my phrase correctly i can
authenticate myself and get into the
server so both https and ssh are popular
ways of communicating with the git
server having said this let me just get
started by installing the git bash on my
local system and then fire up some of
these git commands and build up some
repositories make some changes in my
repository commit these changes and
later use my github credential to
connect to my github server and push my
repositories out there
let me now go ahead and find my git bash
for my windows so that i can go ahead
and install it so i just type in get
client for windows open up a browser and
type in for this the first one that i
find as a gui tool i don't need this gui
client i need this one so this is the
git client or the git bash that i was
referring to it's about 40 megs and let
me just download this pause this video
for some time so that the download
happens and come back to you once i have
the download the download seems to be
complete when i'm recording this video
the version that i have the latest
version that is there is 2.19.0
and this is a 64-bit version for windows
so i've got that downloaded let me go
ahead and find it and install this exe
all right i go ahead choosing all the
default options i want it to be
installed in c colon program files under
the git folder
everything looks good for me i'm not
going to make any changes here
get bash from windows yes i may want to
use git from windows command prompt that
sounds good for me open ssh that's fine
looks good looks good
now i don't want any of these new
features
so what i'm doing is installing the git
bash or the git client so that i can
start using my git commands
the version that i'm using is 2.19.0
which as i record this video this
happens to be the latest version
all right so looks good i don't want to
see the release notes i'll say launch
git bash
so what i get is this window so this is
the git command prompt so let me check
if everything is looking good say gate
version it sounds good say get
help all right a lot of git help
commands
everything looks good so i ended up
installing the git bash i can go ahead
with all other commands
now that i have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before i do
anything i just need to configure it for
the first time stating what would be the
user name and the email id with which i
want the git bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config
hyphen iphone global which means that
this setting that i'm going to set would
be a global setting user dot name and
this the name of the user would need to
be specified within a double quote in my
case i am using the simplylearn account
which is the official account and this
is the particular username of this
account the other setting is nothing but
git config hyphen f1 global this is also
a global setting
and this would be the email id
the email id need not contain a double
quote
so in my case this is the email id that
i would be setting up get to work with
all right let me check if the
configurations were set correctly or not
all right if you see this the username
and the email id has been picked up the
way i wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
git prompt you're placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where i'm going to create all my
multiple git repositories so i will
create a folder called let's say git
underscore demo
all right
there's already a folder called git demo
so let me just delete that in the first
place and let me create this git demo
again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
is my git demo
so this would be a folder so i would use
this folder as a base folder for
creating all other repositories as a
part of this demo so let me create my
first repository a repository is nothing
but a folder so let me create my first
folder called first
repo
and let me
get into this repo all right as of now
this is just an empty folder
if at all i navigate to this you could
see that this folder is empty there's
nothing much in this folder at all at
this moment
okay so let me create a repository out
of this how do i create a repository of
this it's pretty simple i just run and
get init command
when i say git init it means it's going
to initialize a repository as of now
the folder contained nothing on it was
an empty repository so it initialized an
empty repository in this particular
folder if at all i look at my content
you'd see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since i've
configured my explorer to view all
hidden folders i see it otherwise you
wouldn't see it so a folder by name dot
get is created within this first repo
and this was created because we ran the
command git init
if i get into this folder i see a bunch
of directories and other configurations
if you see there's something called as a
hooks directory a couple of
configuration files that are here in
this directory all these relate to one
or the other type of a client hook that
can be enabled and there's info there's
objects
there's references a bunch of stuff that
is there
so what is this folder this is a magical
git folder and this is created whenever
a repository is initialized so by
default if at all you get into any git
folder or any git repository you would
see this dot get folder a word of
caution do not get into this folder and
try to modify anything because if you
fiddle around with this and corrupt this
particular folder your whole repository
will go for a toss so let me come out of
this
and let me show you another thing
now if you notice here
when i was in the folder the repository
did not have anything after this now
when i say get in it there is something
called as a master that shows up so
typically what happens is whenever a git
repository is created for the first time
it creates a default branch the name of
the branch is called master and that is
why you would see master within braces
this doesn't mean anything else other
than we have a repository out in this
particular folder and by default there
is a branch called master and we are
currently on that branch if at all i
create multiple branches in this folder
whenever i navigate to different
branches the branch name within this
brackets would change
all right so far so good so we created a
folder we made it a git repository by
initializing that with the git in it and
then i'm not put anything yet in the
repository so let me try to do that let
me create a few files within this
particular repository so i use a touch
command
touch is a linux command it kind of
creates this particular folder if not
you're not comfortable with the file
creation by this way you can always use
a file explorer and create some files in
this so i create a file called
touchmaster.txt i'll open up in the
notepad
okay so this is my first file that's
what i'm going to write inside this
i save this and i come out of this all
right now let me do a git status command
so what does this
tell you there's no commit set you're on
the master branch there is an untracked
file and this shows up in red it also
gives you all the commands that is
supposed to be run so if at all you want
to add this file you would say git add
and the name of the file and then you're
going to commit it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository now that a git notices
that there is a new file in this
repository called master.txt if at all
you want you want us to let git know
that you want to track this file we need
to add this to the repository so command
to add that is called git add i can
specify either the name of the file or i
can give a while character saying git
add dot now if i run the git status
command again
it says there's no commits yet added a
file and the file which was earlier in
red now shows up in green and it says
it's a new file master dot text
all right it also gives you something
called git remove command if at all you
want to unstage or undo your changes so
what has happened is the file which was
earlier untracked is been added into the
git index or it is ready for staging or
it's in a staged state now i can go
ahead and commit this file if at all
that's what i want to do so let me do
that
i'll do a kit commit minus m and i give
a message that i want i would say this
is my
first get
commit
all right i run the git status command
again
and see it says on the branch master
nothing to commit it's all nice and
clean so typically what happened was i
created an empty directory made it into
a git folder by doing a git init i put a
file into it i made some changes to the
file i added that file into the
repository and i committed to the
repository if it error i run the git log
command
it says this was the commit id or the
commit
number or the commit hashtag and this is
the author if you notice this is the
email id and the username that we set
earlier this was done on this date and
this is the
commit message that is there all of it
looks so good let me do one more commit
into this repository so i will touch
master one dot text i'll put in another
file
i'll open up this particular file
write something into this
all right i save this change
let me also open up the older
file make some more change into this
all right so what i did i modified the
older file that existed i also added a
new file to my repository now if i run
the git status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which is an untracked file
all right now let me add both these
files because these are the changes that
i want to
incorporate i would say git add dot i
run the git status command again
and it says now this is a modified file
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and commit this so git
commit with the message that says this
is my second commit
all right
if i do a git log now it shows both the
comments the first comment is the one
that that shows up at the bottom and the
topmost one is the latest comment that
is there so far so good if at all you
notice
i'm doing all these git commands without
really connecting it to any git server i
don't need any network connection for
doing any of these things i can keep on
doing more and more git commands and run
git commands the way i want to
without really having any connections to
the git server
now that i have my changes the way i
wanted and i've checked in all the code
changes into my local repository i may
want to share my repository with
somebody else
and work in a collaborative way so the
way to do that is as i mentioned earlier
to host this repository or to push this
repository onto a kit server i already
have a github account wherein i've
registered myself using my username and
password so i log into my github account
using my username and credentials and
let me go ahead and create a new
repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what i essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that i can link them together and
push the content from my local
repository to the server
if you notice the name of my repository
is this first repo
so let me copy this i would create a
folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name so that
when i pushed my repository from my
local box it will go ahead and get
created in the server
so the repository name should be the
same as what i created on my local box
description i would say this is my first
git
hub
repository
on the server
this is just an optional description
that will show up
and if you notice
i can't have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that i'm going to
create here would be a public repository
so i choose public and i don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because i already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that i need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server
so with this option with just the name
and with an optional description and the
repository being public i go ahead and
click on the create repository button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that i would need to run in
order to create a repository and pushed
onto the server
and also important point it shows me two
urls one is the https url and the other
one is the ssh url as of now we do not
have any ssh keys that is set up so let
me use this https url to connect my
local repository with the repository on
the server
so i've done all these things i already
have the repository set up all that i
need is a placeholder for me to connect
my local repository with the server url
so this would be the command that i need
to copy
which essentially links or adds an
origin with the url of the git server i
just copy this command
and run it here
git remote add the name of the remote is
called origin and it points to an https
url which is nothing but the placeholder
that i've created on the server
all right so let me check if it's added
correctly
okay the url looks good i'm all set i've
got two comments in my repository i'm
done with all the changes so let me try
to push my repository onto the server
the command for doing it for the first
time is git push hyphen u this is for
linking the upstream
origin
master
so git push hyphen u upstream linking
origin master link the master
branch of my local repository with the
master branch on the server repository
and where is it going to push it is
going to push by default to an origin
and the origin points to this url
all right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up an url asking
me the credentials with which i need to
log into my github server so let me just
copy and paste
the username
and the password with which i have
registered
i would say login
okay success
so i'm able to create a repository on
the server and the content seems to be
pushed and it created a new branch
called master it has linked the master
branch from the local repository with
the master branch on the server
so let me go back to my server and
refresh this page
and see if all my commits have come in
master master one dot text if at all i
see the commits there seem to be two
comments this is my first comment this
is my second comment and if at all you
notice each of this commit comes with a
hash key or a hash id which contains the
details of my commits in this commit the
files were added this was a line that
was added if you look at the second
commit
i added these lines
i made this you know one line chain that
was there i also added this new file
which was not existing these are the two
commits that existed
and if you see
the timestamp of the commit
this is the commit which was committed
for 15 minutes ago so what does this
mean is that the commit is the timestamp
when we actually commented the code in
the client the pushing is just after we
have committed the change we have pushed
it so there's no time stamp of the push
that happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial wherein i create a repository
on the client and then i pushed it to
the server after creating a repository
skeleton on the server
now let me demonstrate to you the ssh
configuration that is required for
creating a pair of ssh keys and ensuring
that i connect to the github server
using the ssh mechanism so for doing
that i need to first create a pair of
private and public key the command to do
that is ssh kijan
hyphen t i will use the rsa mechanism
for creating my keys capital c and i
need to specify the email id using which
i'm going to connect to or i need to
create the keys for
all right so generating a private and
public key pair it says let me know what
folder should i create the keys in so by
default the keys are created in the user
home directory under a dot ssh folder so
this is pretty good for me so let me go
ahead and say that that's fine enter a
passphrase
so let me enter some passphrase
keep in mind that i would need to
remember my passphrase because when i'm
going to authenticate myself using ssh
mechanism it will challenge me for this
particular passphrase i need to enter
the right passphrase so that i get
authenticated
so the key is generated and by default
it is created in this particular folder
so let me go over to that particular
folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with
a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file now i would need to stick it in
on the server so that i can get myself
authenticated using ssh keys so i have
logged in to github using my credentials
and go to my
settings
and you would see an ssh and gpg keys
let me click on that as of now there are
no ssh key or gpg keys so i will click
on new ssh key and let me paste my
public key that i've copied
and i would say add a ssh key
it prompts me for my password just to
make sure that
i've got the right kind of
authentication to be adding a new key so
this one looks good that means the keys
were added successfully let me check if
my ssh keys are working well
so i do ssh hyphen capital t
i would say get
at
github.com
this is just to double check if my ssh
keys
are authenticated correctly are you sure
you want the connection yes you want to
continue yes
all right now
a check for my passphrase let me enter
my passphrase
i hope i remember it correctly
all right
pretty good i have been successfully
authenticated so that means now my ssh
keys are good and just by using my
passphrase i can connect to my github
server using ssh all right so for the
second use case what i would do is
create a repository on the server with
some content in it and then clone that
repository cloning is nothing but making
a copy of that repository linking the
origin so that i create an exact replica
of the repository which is there on the
server on my local drive so let me first
create a repository on the server i will
create a new repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file i would call this my second
repo
give some description
this is my
second repo
that is created
straight
on the git server on the github server
to be precise
it's a public repository this time i am
going to choose this option the reason
being that i don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now i want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then i want a repository to be
created on the server
all right i say create a repository
so
a random readme file with some content
in it gets created and
i can see there are two urls to this
repository https and ssh so this time
let me copy the ssh url so that i will
use this url to clone this repository on
the server
rather from the server to my local box
all right so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that i created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository the second repo that i
created on the server the command to do
that is get clone the url of the
repository that i want to clone
oops
looks like i didn't copy the url
correctly let me copy that again
copy this url
all right so if you notice there's no
https to it i'm just cloning the url
that is ssh url of the repository
it asks for my passphrase again
okay
so i just had first repository earlier
now i have something called a second
repo this is an exact replica of
whatever was the repository content that
was created on the server so if i get
into
the repository there's just a simple
readme file that is there let me try to
add a new file out here i would say
notepad
second.txt
some text file i'm going to put in here
yes definitely you will not find that
file there
this is my second
file that
i will push onto the server
i'm going to put in some content out
there
i'm going to save this
and if i do get status
it says this this is a new untracked
file do you want to add this file onto
the repository you want to track this
file yes i definitely want to track this
file let me also commit my change to the
file
with the message
this is my first
commit for the second repo
i'm giving some particular message
and this time around since i cloned my
repository from a server
the origin is already set for me i don't
really need to
add the origin and all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that i was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
another server which is why i had to set
up the upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case i have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when i clone i get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
i don't need to do anything more other
than push the content i'll just say git
push to be on the safer side i would say
origin and master
ask me for the passphrase
okay it pushed the content onto the
server let me see if the contents have
come in here
okay wonderful i had only one comment
now i see my second comment so what was
added as a part of the second comment it
says a new file was added all this line
that never existed got added this is the
second file the content exactly what i
pushed onto the server
now this completes the tutorial when i
create a repository on the server cloned
it made some changes to the repository
and pushed it to the server using ssh
a quick recap of all the git commands
that we ran till now git init is used to
initialize the repository so if at all
you are creating a local repository you
can get into any of the folder which is
not a git repository and run this
command whenever you run this command a
magical folder by name dot kit gets
created in the folder and from that time
onwards git will start tracking any
changes that happen to that particular
folder it also creates a new repository
and a branch by default the branch that
is created is called the master branch
git add dot is a wildcard character for
adding any number of new files into your
git repository if you have a bunch of
files one file two file ten files a
folder containing multiple files in it
all of them could be added into the
repository using this command so once
you add any number of files into the
repository you can keep on adding more
and more files into the repository once
you're done with that you want to commit
the changes that has happened in the
repository you use the git commit
command git commit hyphen m with a
meaningful message
this will commit all the work items that
you have done in terms of the files that
got changed the files that got added all
this with one particular message get
status will give you the status of all
the files and folders any file that got
added any file that got created any file
that was deleted all the status of the
files will be obtained using the git
status command git log will show you all
the commit history with the latest
history or the latest commit showing up
on top git add remote origin this
command is used whenever you want to
link any local repository to a server
and this is when you want to really push
a repository from the local to the
server for the first time git push
hyphen u origin and master this is the
command that you would use whenever you
want to push contents from the local
repository to the server git clone and
the url of the server this is the
command that you would run whenever you
have an existing repository on the
server and you want to make a fresh
clone or a fresh copy of that particular
repository onto your local box
more than often many developers or git
users find themselves in situations
where they would want to go back in
history and modify
or change some of the files that they
recently committed or checked into the
repository now from a perspective of git
this is a very very simple activity
however from a perspective version
control tool you will have to be really
cautious about the change that you're
gonna do in case the changes are pretty
local none of the developers or none of
the other users who are collaborating
with you would be affected by this
change you're good to go ahead and make
this change however if your repository
has been pushed to the server and you're
trying to modify something from history
this would have a very bad or adverse
effect on all the other users who will
be using it you need to be really
cautious while running these commands in
case your repository contents are local
you have not pushed your changes to your
repository and if at all you made some
changes to the repository maybe to fix a
defect or to include a new feature and
you missed few things you can go ahead
and modify this with some of these
commands let's see i have this simple
repository called undo undo repo and if
at all i look at the logs of these i
have the commit histories which are like
this
i have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in c1 i've added a
file in c2 i've added another file in c3
i've also added some file in c4 i made
some changes to m1 and m3 and in c5 i've
added another file called m4 now this is
my commit history now let's say i made
these two commits but possibly i want to
club them together along with some other
changes because whatever changes i did
did not really fix things the way i
expected it to fix so there is a git
command called git reset this would
allow me to go back in history to go
back to any of the snapshot get rid of
all this commit history on the coming
messages but retain the changes that
were made as a part of these comments so
if at all i need to go back in history
and go back to this particular commit
and however i just want to get rid of
these commits that are there in terms of
the commit messages but i want the
changes that were there as a part of
these commits to still exist i would do
command called get reset
hyphen iphone soft
now this would go back or unwind my
changes back to this particular snapshot
getting rid of all the commit messages
that were there as a part of these two
comments but a soft would ensure that
the file changes that were done as a
part of these two comments would still
exist a full remain so the command for
that is git reset hyphen f and soft
which is the snapshot that i want to get
back to if this is the commit that i
want to get back to i just copy this
and paste this
all right it doesn't give me any message
but if at all i do a good log pretty one
line
what it says is c1 c2 now the head which
is nothing but the current pointer which
is earlier pointing to c5 it's gone back
to c3 now what happened to the changes
that were there as a part of c4 and c5
if at all you do a git status if you see
the changes that were part of c4 were
some changes to m1 and m2 and c5 a new
file got m4 got added if i do a git
status
you would see those changes still exist
however from the git history or the git
commit history c3 is the topmost commit
that exists as of now c4 and c5 have
been gotten rid of but the changes that
were there still exist
all right now i can make some more
changes that i want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and commit
this whole thing as a new commit
altogether maybe
i'll open up a notepad and possibly
create a new file called m6.txt
and say
one
new file
that was missed out
i make this change
i go to a get status
all these files are still there i would
say get add dot
also get
commit hyphen m
c4
rewriting history
and i do a get
log
pretty
there you go
so c1 c2 c3 still existed and whatever
was the part of c4 and c5 the older ones
i've gotten rid of this along with those
old changes i also added a new file i
made some changes and it was able to
commit it now if you look at my gate
history it's all nice and clean however
do this activity only when you don't
push your git repository to the server
one other most powerful and useful
command while undoing or resetting the
history is something called as revert
this is a safe way of undoing some
things remember what i talked about when
exactly you can do a reset it's only
when your changes are local and is not
being pushed to the repository take this
scenario wherein let's say i have a git
server
and i have the changes
which are c1
c2
c3
and possibly c4
all right so this is a bunch of comments
that has happened this was the oldest
comment and this is the newest comment
and if at all developer one is the one
who's responsible for pushing these
contents
in the first place so he has got c1 to
c4 on his history
i'm going to jump all these c2 and c3
and get into c4 and he's pushed all
these contents out here
and there are a bunch of people from the
server who has pulled this repository
and all of them are at the same level
now imagine a use case where developer 1
then figures out that by mistake he put
in the c3 which was the wrong thing to
do and possibly you know he could have
done a better job of fixing this in a
different way so he wants to get rid of
the c3 or c4 or any one of these
comments
if he's going to do that and push to the
server first of all the git server would
not allow him to go back in history but
assuming that he forcibly pushed
something
what would happen to all these people
who are looking to work ahead from c4
all of them would be affected in adverse
way so
in short never go back in history if at
all you need to undo something go ahead
and put in a new commit to undo
something
let's take this example maybe if at all
a developer one wants to get rid of c3
better way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead
say let's say c5 and what does this
commit do
this commit possibly gets rid of c3
instead of going back in history it
actually is taking your git history
ahead but as a part of this commit
you're undoing some part of the work
that was done as a part of c3
in short you're removing a commit but to
remove a commit you're adding a new
commit and this is why you're doing it
because there are a bunch of other
people who are
you're using this repository
collaboratively and what planning to get
ahead in terms of history they cannot
afford to go back in history and modify
something in history all right the
command to do this is called the git
revert command
so let me take up this repository which
has got a bunch of commits in it and if
at all i do a git
log pretty one line
i have these bunch of comments
and c1 i've added a file in c2 hour
another file in c3 i've added one more
file
and in c4 i made some changes and this
is the latest commit and this is the
oldest comment so if at all i see the
contents of the git
folder it contains m1 m2 m3 and m4
and
let's say looking at the previous use
case that i mentioned i may want to get
rid of this particular commit
i want to get rid of the c3 which is
nothing but i've added a file called
m3.txt but i added it by mistake
i need a better way of fixing it
possibly i look at it later on but for
now i don't want this particular commit
and the changes that were made as a part
of that commit to exist so the better
way to do that is using the git revert
command so git revert and the commit id
whatever i want to revert so if i want
to revert this
i copy this particular commit id and
bear in mind that considering a reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
i can do
one commit revert at a time i can club
bunch of them together and do one commit
but otherwise the revert always works on
one commit at a time so get revert
paste this
essentially what i'm trying to do i'm
trying to undo this particular commit
while i'm undoing this commit what does
git do it safely adds a new commit and a
part of this new commit it unders
whatever changes that were done as a
part of this command so if i say git
revert this
all right i forgot to mention the
message which is why this window is
showing up but that message is good for
me i say write and quit
all right and if i do a git log
all right if you see this c1 still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from c5 i see another commit
but what was it as a part of this commit
actually is getting rid of this commit
c3 so if at all i see my files here
there's only m1 m2 and m4
m3 was added as a part of c3 now i've
gotten rid of m3
by getting rid of the revert command for
c3 so this is a better way of undoing
things
now that we have acquainted ourselves
with few of those basic git commands let
me get into a very very interesting
topic regarding get which is about
branching the topic is interesting
because kit deals with branches in a
completely different way
compared to any other version control
tool
in most of the version control tools
whenever you create a new branch a
complete copy or a subset of the whole
repository is created which in my
opinion is very very cost inefficient
because it is a very very expensive
operation both in times of time and the
disk space
however in git you just create a very
very lightweight mobile pointer whenever
you create a branch there is no folder
or no copy of the repository that is
created in short the branches are very
very inexpensive and great so go ahead
and create any number of branches that
you need however once you create your
branches do all the work relating to
that branch in that specific branch and
once you've completed your task go ahead
and merge your branches back into your
base branch and then delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that
so let me go back to my base directory
which is git demo and then i'm going to
create a new folder here
i'll create a folder called org details
all right this is my folder here
all right i navigate into this folder
and let me create a repository here
i initialize a repository and dot git
folder is created without any
files in it so let me create a few files
on it
say notepad name dot text
organization name
i create a name.text within this maybe
i'll create one more file in this
notepad
employees.txt
simply learn
has
over
3k employees
i just put in some content in this save
this content
all right
so if i try to look at status i just
see two files in it so let me go ahead
and
add these two files and let me commit my
changes so get
commit iphone am or iphone m
first comment
so if i do a gig log
i see only one comment and there are two
files you can see those two files that
is here
all right so at this stage let me go
ahead and create a new branch
and the command for creating new branch
is get
branch name of the branch
so let me name my branch as bangalore
branch blr branch
and this created a branch
but i don't see any changes in the
folder structure or in the file that
exists here
i've just created this branch so if i
thought i do a git
branch
i see these two branches
and whatever star means i'm currently in
this master branch so let me go ahead
and get into the blr branch at this
moment the number of files that exist in
this repository is same there's
absolutely no change in any of the
branches both master and blur branch
point to the same snapshot
so let me get into
the other branch and the command to do
that is get checkout
plr branch
i've actually switched into bangalore
branch if you see the content of the
files there's exactly two files the way
it was earlier because i've created a
branch from my base branch which is a
master branch and when i created a
branch there were two files existing
here if you see the content of these
files they would all be the same
all right so let me create a
file that is specific to panel branch
so i would just say notepad
maybe i want to put down the address of
this organization specific to bangalore
in this address dot text so i say
notepad address.txt
also simply learn
bangalore office
say located in
[Music]
some arteries
i would say
bangalore
that is the content of this file
and i'm creating all this new file in
this blr branch so i would say git add
dot
and i would say git
commit hyphen m
bangalore
branch
commit
all right if you see this now i have an
address.txt which is there only in the
bangalore branch that i'm presently on
now let me switch back to my master
branch the command to do that is git
check out
master branch
if you remember when i forked out or
when i created a new branch from the
master branch i didn't have this address
or text in it so let me go back to get
get checkout master branch
and keep noticing this particular
what happened to the address.text
it kind of disappeared
how did that happen it's all because of
this magical git folder so what happened
is now git knows that when you're in the
master branch
the
file that was there in the bangalore
branch which was called the address.txt
didn't exist
so
git is playing around with the file
system snapshot so if i come back let's
say i come back to git check out
bangalore branch
if you see this the address.txt file
appears
so this particular file is only present
in the branch and git is playing around
with the file system snapshot by moving
the pointers across and ensuring that
whenever i am switching to bangalore
branch i see this address dot text when
i go back to my master branch i don't
see this bangalore branch
contents which is the address dot text
all right now that i created this branch
maybe i may need to push this onto the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in our
previous exercise
so
the name of the folder needs to be
exactly this one so let me copy this
and let me create a repository very
quickly
go here and say new repository
all right this
is the name of the repository
get branch demo this is what i'm going
to put in as a description i would say
public i don't want any readme files in
it because i already have a repository i
will just say create a repository
all right
let me use
the ssh url yeah this is the ssh url
this is good for me so let me copy this
url
let me add it here
i'm linking my local repository with the
server
and i would let me come back to my
master branch
let me first push my master branch so i
would say git
push
hyphen u origin
master
it asks for my passphrase
all right
i pushed my master branch it looks good
it says new branch master is created so
if i go back to my server and i do a
refresh
if you see it says only one branch
and it says what is the name of the
branch master
if you see the contents there is
employees.text and name.txt
now
let's try to push the other branch that
is there the command to do that is a
little different compared to
the way we created it on the client
because on the client we created the
branch with a git branch command now
this branch doesn't exist on the server
and i need to push this new branch onto
the server so the command would be
gate
push
hyphen u
origin
and the name of the brand that i want to
specifically push
all right now it created a branch out
here
let me do a refresh of this
all right it says two branches
if i get into this bankrupt branch i
would see the address dot text if at all
i go back into master branch i would not
see this address.txt
wonderful
now let me do one thing let me try to
get the changes from the branch that i
created back into the master branch that
is what i would mean by
merging i would want the changes that is
there as a part of the bangalore branch
to come back into my master branch so if
i go to click checkout
bankrupt branch i see this address tag
this is there only as a part of
bangalore branch now assuming that i am
done with the changes from the bandwidth
branch i want to get those changes back
into my master so let me come back
to my master branch
and the way to merge in the changes is
get merge
so what is that you want to merge i want
to merge the bangalore branch changes
and where will it merge it'll merge it
into the current branch that i'm on
presently i'm in the master branch so
this command would merge the changes
from the bangalore branch into your
master branch so with this if you'll
keep looking here the content that was
there that was added as a part of
bangalore branch which is nothing but
the address dot text this file should
appear as soon as we do a merge
all right so it happened
quickly and you would see this address
dot text that is here so if you see
let's check the contents in terms of the
git log
all right so there was only one branch
that we had earlier which had only one
commit right now we are at this
bangalore branch commit which was there
as a part of the bangalore branch
committee
so with this change let me push this
change onto the server as well gate push
origin
master
okay those changes were pushed to the
server and now
if at all i do a refresh out here
okay i mean two branches
the francis master even if i'm in master
brands i should see this address dot
text that is there even if i'm in the
bangalore branch the content is all same
because we have these two branches
now that i've merged this branch i don't
need this branch anymore so i would go
ahead and delete this locally as well as
push it onto the server so that it gets
deleted from the server as well so
delete branch locally the command is get
branch hyphen d and the name of the
branch
only thing you need to ensure is that
you should not be currently on that
branch which you're trying to delete so
i would say get branch
and i'm presently in the master branch
so i can go ahead and delete the other
branch so get branch hyphen d bangle
branch
all right this got rid of our bandwidth
branch locally
if at all i don't get branch hyphen way
it shows there's only one branch as of
now however this branch would still
exist on the server because server
doesn't know anything about the changes
that we have done
we need to specifically push our changes
onto the server
okay there are two branches still here
so let me go ahead and push this changes
so that the branch gets deleted from the
server as well the command to do that is
get
push
origin
hyphen iphone delete
and the name of the branch
all right
so this went ahead and deleted the
branch
from the server let's check that
okay if you see now there's only one
branch
these are the basic steps that you would
need to know before you work with any of
the branches within git and as i said
before the branches are very very
inexpensive and good go ahead and create
any number of branches that you want but
just ensure that once you create your
branch finish of your task and once you
finish off your task go ahead and delete
the branch and before you delete the
brands please ensure that you merge in
the branches so that you get in or take
in the work that was done as a part of
that particular branch
to summarize the git branching commands
are as follows to create a new branch
you issue a command git branch the name
of the branch and this would
automatically spin off or create a new
branch from the existing branch from
where you issue this command if you are
on the master branch and if you execute
this command get branch new underscored
branch it creates a new underscore
branch from the master branch once you
create a new branch in order to get into
this branch you type in git check out
the name of the branch this would
automatically switch the file system
snapshot between different branches now
the branches that are created are by
default created on the local repository
in case you want to push any specific
branch onto the server you would have to
issue a command git push hyphen u origin
and the name of the branch so this will
ensure that the contents of the new
branch are pushed onto the server at any
time if you want to list out all
existing branches on your local
repositories the command would be git
branch hyphen av assuming that you did
all your work in a new branch and you're
happy with the changes you would want to
bring back those changes into the master
branch the command to merge the contents
of any new branch into a master branch
would be git merge and the name of the
branch this would automatically merge
the branch contents that you specified
into the branch on which you currently
reside if at all you're on the master
branch and if you issue a command git
merge new underscore branch this would
merge the contents of the new branch
onto the master branch so once you merge
the contents of any branch you would
possibly want to go ahead and delete
this branch so the command to delete
those branch locally is get branch
hyphen capital d and the name of the
branch this again would delete the
branch locally in order to make this
change on the server which is in order
to remove this branch from the server
the command to do that is get push
origin hyphen iphone delete and the name
of the branch this would also delete the
branch that you created on the server
hello this is matthew from simply learn
and today we're going to deep dive into
what jenkins is and how it improves your
devops continuous integration
environments
so this is what we're going to be
covering in this session we're going to
cover what life is like before using
jenkins and the issues that jenkins
specifically addresses then we'll get
into what jenkins is about and how it
applies to continuous integration and
the other continuous integration tools
that you need in your devops team then
specifically we'll deep dive into
features of jenkins and the jenkins
architecture and we'll give you a case
study of a company that's using jenkins
today to actually transform how their
i.t organization is operating so let's
talk a little bit about life before
jenkins
let's see this scenario i think it's
something that maybe all of you can
relate to as developers we all write
code and we all submit that code into a
code repository and we all keep working
away writing our unit tests and
hopefully we're running our unit tests
but the problem is that the actual
commits that actually gets sent to the
code repository aren't consistent you as
a developer may be based in india you
may have another developer that's based
in the philippines and you may have
another team lead that's based in the uk
and another development team that's
based in north america so you're all
working at different times and you have
different amounts of code going into the
code repository there's issues with the
integration and you're kind of running
into a situation that we like to call
development hell where things just
aren't working out and there's just lots
of delays being added into the project
and the bugs just keep mounting up the
bottom line is the project is delayed
and in the past what we would have to do
is we'd have to wait until the entire
software code was built and tested
before we could even begin checking for
errors and this just really kind of
increased the amount of problems that
you'd have in your project
the actual process of delivering
software was slow there was no way that
you could actually iterate on your
software and you just ended up with just
a big headache with teams pointing
fingers at each other and blaming each
other
so let's jump into jenkins and see what
jenkins is and how it can address these
problems
so jenkins is a product that comes out
of the concept of continuous integration
that you may have heard of as power
developers where you'd have two
developers sitting next to each other
coding against the same piece of
information what they were able to do is
to continuously develop their code and
test their code and move on to new
sections of code jenkins is a product
that allows you to expand on that
capacity to your entire team so you're
able to submit your codes consistently
into a source code environment
so there are two ways in which you can
do continuous delivery one is through 90
builds and one is through continuous
so the approach that you can look at
continuous delivery is modifying the
legacy approach to building out
solutions so what we used to do is we
would wait for nightly builds and the
way that our nightly builds would work
and operate is that as co-developers we
would all run and have a cut-off time at
the end of the day and that was
consistent around the world that we
would put our codes into a single
repository and at night all of that code
would be run and operated and tested to
see if there were any changes and a new
build would be created that would be
referred to as the nightly build with
continuous integration we're able to go
one step further we're able to not only
commit our changes into our source code
but we can actually do this continuously
there's no need to race and have a team
get all of their code in an arbitrary
time you can actually do a continuous
release because what you're doing is
you're putting your tests and your
verification services into the build
environment so you're always running
cycles to test against your code this is
the power that jenkins provides in
continuous integration so let's dig
deeper into continuous integration so
the concept of continuous integration is
that as a developer you're able to pull
from a repository the code that you're
working on and then you'll be able to
then at any time submit the code that
you're working on into a continuous
integration server and the goal of that
continuous integration server is that it
actually goes ahead and validates and
passes any tests that a tester may have
created
now if on the continuous integration
server a test isn't passed then that
code gets sent back to the developer and
the developer can then make the changes
it allows the developer to actually do a
couple of things it allows the developer
not to break the build and we all don't
want to break the builds that are being
created but it also allows the developer
not to actually have to run all the
tests locally on their computer write
tests particularly if you have a large
number of tests can take up a lot of
time so if you can push that service up
to another environment like a continuous
integration server it really improves
the productivity of your developer
what's also good is that if there are
any code errors that have come up that
may be beyond just the standard ci test
so maybe there's a code the way that you
write your code isn't consistent those
errors can then be passed on easily from
the tester back to the developer too the
goal from doing all this testing is that
you're able to release and deploy and
your customer is able to get new code
faster and when they get that code it
simply just works
so let's talk a little bit about some of
the tools that you may have in your
continuous integration environment so
the cool thing with working with
continuous integration tools is that
they are all open source at least the
ones that we have listed here are open
source there are some that are private
but typically you'll get started with
open source tools and it gives you the
opportunity to understand how you can
accelerate your environment quickly
so bamboo is a continuous integration
tool that specifically runs multiple
builds in parallel for faster
compilation so if you have multiple
versions of your software that runs on
multiple platforms this is a tool that
really allows you to get that up and
running super fast so that your teams
can actually test how those different
builds would work for different
environments and this has integration
with and maven and other similar tools
so one of the tools you're going to need
is a tool that allows you to automate
the software build test and release
process and buildbot is that open source
product for you again it's an open
source tool so there's no license
associated with this so you can actually
go in and you can actually get the
environment up and running and you can
then test for and build your environment
and create your releases very quickly so
buildbots also written in python and it
does support parallel execution jobs
across multiple platforms if you're
working specifically on java projects
that need to be built and test then
apache gump is the tool for you it makes
all of those projects really easy it
makes all the java projects easier for
you to be able to test with api level
and functionality level testing so one
of the popular places to actually store
code and create a versioning of your
code is github and it's a service that's
available on the web just recently
acquired by microsoft if you are storing
your projects in github then you'll be
able to use travis continuous
integration or travis ci and it's a tool
designed specifically for hosted github
projects and so finally we're covering
jenkins and jenkins is a central tool
for automation for all of your projects
now when you're working with jenkins
sometimes you'll find there's
documentation that refers to a product
called hudson hudson is actually the
original version of the product that
finally became jenkins and it was
acquired by oracle when that acquisition
happened the team behind um hudson was a
little concerned about the direction
that oracle may potentially go with
hudson and so they created a hard fork
of hudson that they renamed jenkins and
jenkins has now become that open source
project it is one of the most popular
and continuously contributed projects
that's available as open source so
you're always getting new features being
added to it it's a tool that really
becomes the center for your ci
environment
so let's jump into some of those really
great features are available in jenkins
so jenkins itself is really comprised of
five key areas around easy installation
easy configuration plugins extensibility
and distribution so as i mentioned for
the easy installation jenkins is a
self-contained java program and that
allows it to run on most popular
operating systems including windows mac
os and unix you even run it on linux
it really isn't too bad to set up it
used to be much harder than it is today
the setup process has really improved
the web interface makes it really easy
for you to check for any errors in
addition you have great built-in help
one of the things that makes tools like
jenkins really powerful for developers
and continuous integration teams and
your devops teams as a whole when you
have plug-ins that you can then add in
to extend the base functionality of the
product jenkins has hundreds of plugins
and you can go and visit the update
center and see which other plugins that
would be good for your devops
environment certainly check it out
there's just lots of stuff out there
in addition to the plug-in architecture
jenkins is also extremely extensible the
opportunity for you to be able to
configure jenkins to fit in your
environment is almost endless now it's
really important to remember that you
are extending jenkins not creating a
custom version of jenkins and that's a
great differentiation because the core
foundation remains as the core jenkins
product the extensibility can then be
continued with newer releases of jenkins
so you're always having the latest
version of jenkins and your extensions
mature with those core foundation the
distribution and the nature of jenkins
makes it really easy for you to be able
to have it available across your entire
network it really will become the center
of your ci environment and it's
certainly one of the easier tools and
more effective tools for devops
so let's jump into the standard jenkins
pipeline so when you're doing
development you start off and you're
coding away on your computer the first
thing you have to do when you're working
in the jenkins pipeline is to actually
commit your code now as a developer this
is something that you're already doing
or at least you should be doing you're
committing your code to a git server um
or to an svn server or a similar type of
service so in this instance you'll be
using jenkins as the place for you to
commit your code jenkins will then
create a build of your code and part of
that build process is actually going
through and running through tests and
again as a developer you're already
comfortable with running unit tests and
writing those tests to validate your
code but there may be additional tests
that jenkins is running so for instance
as a team you may have a standard set of
tests for how you actually write out
your code so that each team member can
understand the code that's been written
and those tests can also be included in
the testing process within the jenkins
environment assuming everything past the
the tests you can then get everything
placed in a stage and release ready
environment within jenkins and finally
again ready to deploy or deliver your
code to a production environment jenkins
is going to be the tool that helps you
with your server environment to be able
to deploy your code to the production
environment and the result is that
you're able to move from a developer to
production code really quickly this
whole process can be automated rather
than having to wait for people to
actually test your codes or go through a
nightly build you're looking at being
able to commit your code and go through
this testing process and release process
continuously as an example companies
etsy will release up to 50 different
versions of their website every single
day so let's talk about the architecture
within jenkins that allows you to be so
effective at applying a continuous
delivery devops environment so the
server architecture really is broken up
into two sections on the left hand side
of the section you have the code the
developers are doing and submitting that
code to a source code repository and
then from then jenkins is your
continuous integration server and it
will then pull any code that's been sent
to the source code repository and will
run tests against it it will use a build
server such as maven to actually then
build the code and every single stage
that we have that jenkins manages there
are constant tests so for instance if a
build fails that feedback is sent right
back to the developers so that they can
then change their code so that the build
environment can run effectively
the final stage is to actually execute
specific test scripts and these test
groups can be written in selenium so
it's probably good to mention here that
both mavin and selenium are plugins that
run in the jenkins environment so before
we were talking about how jenkins can be
extended with plugins mavin and selenium
are just two very popular examples of
how you can extend the jenkins
environment the goal to go through this
whole process again is an automated
process is to get your code from the
developer to the production server as
quickly as possible have it fully tested
and have no errors so it's probably
important at this point to mention uh
one piece of information around the
jenkins environment that if you have
different code builds that need to be
managed and distributed this will
require that you need to have multiple
builds being managed jenkins itself
doesn't allow for multiple files and
builds to be executed on a single server
you need to have a multiple server
environment with running different
versions of jenkins for that to be able
to happen so let's talk a little bit
about the master slave architecture
within jenkins so what we have here is
an overview of the master slave
architecture within jenkins on the left
hand side is the remote source code
repository and that remote source code
repository could be github or it could
be
team foundation services or the new
azure devops code repository or it could
be your own git repository the jenkins
server acts as the master environment on
the left hand side and that master
environment can then push out to
multiple other jenkins slave
environments to distribute the workload
so it allows you to run multiple builds
and tests and production environments
simultaneously across your entire
architecture so jenkins slaves can be
running the different build versions of
the code for different operating systems
and the server master is controlling how
each of those builds operate so let's
step into a quick story of a company
that has used jenkins very successfully
so here's a use case scenario over the
last 10 or 15 years there has been a
significant shift within the automotive
industry where manufacturers have
shifted from creating complex hardware
to actually creating software we've seen
that with companies such as tesla
where they are creating software to
manage their cars we see the same thing
with companies such as general motors
with their onstar program and ford just
recently have rebranded themselves as a
technology company rather than just a
automotive company what this means
though is that the software within these
cars is becoming more complex and
requires more testing to allow more
capabilities enhancements to be added to
the core software so bosch is a company
that specifically ran into this problem
and their challenge was that they wanted
to be able to streamline the
increasingly complex automotive software
by adopting continuous integration and
continuous delivery best practices with
the goal of being able to delight and
exceed the customer expectations of the
end user so bosch has actually used
cloudbees which is the enterprise
jenkins environment so to be able to
reduce the number of manual steps such
as building deploying and testing bosch
has introduced the use of cloud bs from
jenkins and this is part of the
enterprise jenkins platform it has
significantly helped improve the
efficiencies throughout the whole
software development cycle from
automation
stability and transparency because
jenkins becomes a self-auditing
environment now the results have been
tangible previously it took three days
before a build process could be done and
now it's taken that same three-day
process and reduced it to less than
three hours that is significant
large-scale deployments are now kept on
track and have expert support and there
is clear visibility and transparency
across the whole operations through
using the jenkins tools
hello and welcome to continuous
integration tutorial using jenkins my
name is chidanand and i am with the
simply learn team today let's get
started with jenkins jenkins in my
opinion is one of the most popular
continuous integration servers of recent
times what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for sun microsystems
way back in early or mid-2000s has
gradually and eventually evolved into
very very powerful and robust automation
servers it has a wide adoption since it
is released under mit license and is
almost free to use
jenkins has a vast developer community
that supports it by writing all kinds of
plugins plugins is the heart and soul of
jenkins because using plugins one can
connect jenkins to anything and
everything under the sun
with that introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial i will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing jenkins post which i will go
ahead and install jenkins on a windows
box there are few first time
configuration that needs to be done and
i will be covering those as well so once
i have jenkins installed and configured
properly i will get into the user
administrative part i create few users
and i will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users i will also put in some
freestyle jobs freestyle job is nothing
but a very very simple job and i will
also show you the powerfulness of
jenkins by scheduling this particular
job to run based upon time schedule i
will also connect jenkins with github
github is our source code where source
code repository where i've got some
repositories put up there so using
jenkins i will connect to github pull up
a repository that is existing on github
onto the jenkins box and run few
commands to build this particular
repository that is pulled from github
sending out emails is a very very
important configurations of jenkins or
any other continuous integration server
for that matter whenever there is any
notifications that has to be sent out as
a part of either a build going bad or
built being good or built being
propagated to some environment and all
these scenarios you would need the
contains integration servers to be
sending out notifications so i will get
into a little bit details of how to
configure jenkins for sending out emails
i will also get into a scenario where i
will have a web application a maven
based java web application which will be
pulled from a github repository and i
will deploy it onto a tomcat server the
tomcat server will be locally running on
my system eventually i will get into one
other very very important topic which is
the master slave configuration it's a
very very important and pretty
interesting topic where distributed
builds is achieved using a master slave
configuration so i will bring up a slave
i will connect the slave with the master
and i will also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally i will let
you know how to use some plugins to
backup your jenkins so jenkins has got a
lot of useful information set up on it
in terms of the build environments in
terms of workspace all this can be very
very easily backed up using a plugin so
this is what i'm going to be covering as
a part of this tutorial jenkins is a web
application that is written in java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install jenkins i have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
jenkins is usually installed on any
system the topmost one is as a windows
or linux based services so if at all you
have windows like the way i have and i'm
going to use this mechanism for this
demo so i would download a msi installer
that is specific to jenkins and install
this service so whenever i installed as
a service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
jenkins and i have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of linux as well one other
way of running jenkins is downloading
this generic war file and as long as you
have jdk installed you can launch this
war file by the command opening up a
command prompt or shell prompt referral
layer on linux box specifying java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a
control c and then bring down this
prompt and your jenkins server would be
down other older versions of jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
administration is all taken care of by
the apache or the tomcat server or the
web server on which jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you're going to bring up
your jenkins instance the way we're
going to operate jenkins is all going to
be very very same or similar one with
the subtle changes in terms of user
administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
administration otherwise all the
commands or all the configuration all
the way in which i'm going to run this
demo it is going to be same across any
of these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running jenkins as i
mentioned earlier jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is written
in java so all that it needs is java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2gb ram is the
recommended ram for running jenkins and
also like any other open source tool
sets when you install jdk ensure that
you set in the environment variable java
home to point to the right directory
this is something very specific to jdk
but for any other open source tools that
you've installed there's always a
preferred environment variable that
you've got to set in which is specific
to that particular tool that you're
going to use this is a generic thing
that is there for you know for any other
open source projects because the way
open source projects discover themselves
is using this environment variables so
as a general practice or a good practice
always set these environment variables
accordingly so i already have jdk 1.8
installed on my system but in case you
do not what i would recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the oracle
home page and just type in or search for
install
jdk 1.8
and navigate to the oracle home page
you will have to
accept the license agreement and there
are a bunch of installers that is okay
that you can pick up based upon the
operating system on which you're running
so
i have this windows 64 installer that is
already installed and running on my
system so i will not get into the
details of downloading this or
installing it let me show you once i
install this what i've done with regard
to my path
so
if you get into this environment
variables
all right so i've just set in a java
home variable
if you see this colon program files java
jdk 1.8 this is where my my java is
located c program files
c program files java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what i've been i've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run java
or java c from a command prompt ensure
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere i will see yes there you go c
colon program files java jdk 1.8 pin so
with these two i'll ensure that my java
installation is nice and you know good
enough so to check that to double check
that or to verify that let me just open
up a simple command prompt
and if i type in java iphone version
all right
and java c
iphone version
so the compiler is on the path java is
on the path and if at all i do this
even the environment variable specific
to my java is
installed correctly so i'm good to go
ahead with my jenkins installation
now that i have my prerequisites
all set for installing jenkins let me
just go ahead and download jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
jenkins
all right lts is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies i would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that um long term
support is good enough and as i
mentioned there are so many flavors of
jenkins that is available for download
you also have a docker container wherein
you know you can launch jenkins as a
container but i'll not get into details
of that in this tutorial
all right so what i want is
yes this is the war file was a generic
war file that i was talking to you
earlier and this is the windows msi
installer so go ahead and download this
msi installer i already have that
downloaded so let me just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
jenkins instance
or rather installer this is a pretty
maybe a few months old but this is good
enough for me
before you start jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called jenkins home this is
where jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an msi
installer all your installation gets
into c colon program files 86 and
jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user id with
which you're running your war file the
jenkins folder there's a dot jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
jenkins or you want jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
i don't need to do any of these things
so i've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation
all right so this is my jenkins msi
installer i would just i don't want to
make any changes into the jenkins
configuration c colon program files is
good for me yeah this is where all my
destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes i'm
happy with this i don't want to change
this
i would just say go ahead and click
installation
okay so what typically happens once the
jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default jenkins launches on
the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein i need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets
stored out here so i'll have to just
copy this path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a jenkins station
so as a part of the installation it just
asks you to do this
so if that is not great it will
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation
so you would need to install some
recommended plugins
what happens is the plugins are all
related to each other so it's like the
typical rpm kind of a problem where you
try to install some plugin and it's got
a dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that
install recommended plugin so if you see
there is
a whole lot of plugins which are bare
essential plugins that is required for
jenkins in order to run properly so
jenkins as a part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you
this is a good combination to kind of
begin with and mind you at this moment
jenkins needs
lots of bandwidth in terms of network so
in case your you know your network is
not so good few of these plugins would
kind of fail
and these plugins are all you know on
available on openly
or mirrored sites and sometimes some of
them may be down so do not worry in case
some of these plugins kind of fail to
install you'll get an option to kind of
retry installing them but just ensure
that you know at least most or 90 95 of
all these plugins are installed without
any problems let me pause the video here
for a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed
my plugin installation is all good there
was no failures in any of my plugins so
after that i get to create this first
admin user again this is one important
point that you got to remember
keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it alright so i'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that i can remember
i will
that's my name and um an email id is
kind of optional but it doesn't allow me
to go ahead in case i don't so i just
given an admin and i got a password i've
got i remember my password this is my
full name
all right i say save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that i have my jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configuration
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
ui is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys
but if at all you're a java guy you know
how painful it is to write ui in java
you will kind of appreciate you know all
the effort that has gone into the ui
bottom line you are a little hard to you
know wrap your head around it but once
you start using it possibly you'll start
liking it
all right so let me get into something
called as manage jenkins
this can be viewed like a
main menu for all jenkins configuration
so i'll get into some of those important
ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete jenkins instance
few things to kind of look out for this
is a home directory this is a java home
where all the configurations all the
workspace anything and everything
regarding jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's probably show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets jenkin know
at any point in time how many jobs or
how many threads can be run you can kind
of visualize it like a thread that can
be run on this particular instance as a
thumb rule if at all you're on a single
core system number of executors two
should be good enough
in case at any point in time there are
multiple jobs that kind of get triggered
the same time in case the number of
executors are less compared to the
number of jobs that have that to woken
up no need to panic because they will
all get queued up and eventually jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the cpu usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors two for my system is kind of
good label for my jenkins i don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your jenkins this is good
for me because i only have a primary
server that is running so i want to use
this node as much as possible quite
pretty each of these options have got
some pair minimal
help kind of a thing that is that is out
here by clicking on these question marks
you will get to know as to what are
these particular configurations
all right so this all look good what i
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin svn
email notifications
i don't want that what i want the yes i
want this smtp server configuration
remember i mentioned earlier that i
would want jenkins to be sending out
some emails and what i've done here is
i've just configured
the smtp details of my personal email id
in case you're in a in organization you
would have some sort of an email ids
that is set up for a jenkins server so
you can specify the smtp server details
of your company so that you know you can
authorize jenkins to kind of send out
emails
but in case you want to try it out like
me i have configured my personal email
id which is on my gmail for sending out
notifications so the smtp server would
be
smtp.gmail.com i'm using the smtp
authentication i have provided my email
id and my password i'm using the smtp
port which is 465 and i'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine i can
just send out an email
and see if at all this configuration
works again gmail would not allow you to
allow anybody to send out notifications
on your behalf so you'll have to lower
the security level of your gmail id so
that you can allow a programmatically
somebody to send out email notifications
on your behalf so i've done already that
i'm just trying to see if i can send a
test email with the configuration that
i've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your
you know your gmail account in case you
want to do that if not put in your
organization smtp server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that i'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so i come back to managing
ken's okay one other thing that i want
to kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario look at it this
way jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required for building
the appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
you an example in case your source code
is a java source code and assuming that
you know because in this demo this is my
laptop and i've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because i'm a developer i'm
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case i want
jenkins to you know run a java code i
would need to install jdk on it i need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since i already have the jdk
installed and i've already put in the
java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly i don't
need to do it git if at all i want the
jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command bash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
gradle and maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system
which is your continuous integration
server you will have to come in here and
configure something
in case you don't configure it when
jenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it'll crib about it
that's good i don't want to save
anything
manage jenkins let me see what else is
required yes configure global security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the user
names which hashes up these user names
and kind of stores them
so as of now it jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your jenkins repository rather
jenkins tool
so you would specify your ldap server
details the root dn
password or the manager dn and the
manager password and all these details
in case you want to connect your jenkins
instance with your
ldap or ad or any of the authentication
servers that you have in your
organization
but for now since i don't have any of
these things i'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so i will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once i put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so i'm going to save
all this stuff
that's good for me so enough of all
these configurations let me put in a
very very simple job
all right so job new item you know a
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so i'll
just say you know first job this is good
for me i just give a name for my job i
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me i don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not become active so choose
the freestyle project and say okay
at a very high level you would see
general source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am i doing at the
moment i'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so i don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo let me just put in a very very
simple job i'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first
jenkins job
all right i don't want to choose any of
these again there are some helps
available here
i don't want to choose any of this i
don't want to connect it to any source
code for now
i don't want any triggers for now i'll
come back to this in a while build the
environment i don't want any build
environment as a part of this build step
you know i just want to you know run few
things so that i kind of complete this
particular job so since i'm on a windows
box i would say execute windows batch
command all right so what do you want to
do i would let me just echo something
echo
uh hello
this is my first jenkins job
and possibly i would want the date and
the time stamp
pertaining to the job i mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right i don't want to do anything
else i want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me
save this job
all right so once i save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then i need to build this job and you
would see some build straight out here
nothing is there as of now because i've
just put in a job i have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a time stamp so if i click on
this you would see a console output
if i go here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into if
you see this
if i navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
i was mentioning earlier regarding
jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here
all right so the workspace is where all
the jobs that i've created whichever i'm
running would you know there will be
individual folders specific to the jobs
that has been put up here all right so
one job one quick run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
i would say second job
i would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
i just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what i said earlier about
jenkins because at the core of jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server
all right so what i'm going to do i will
just keep everything else the same i'm
going to put in the build script pretty
much similar to
second job
that
gets triggered
automatically
every
minute all right let me do that
percentage date
and i'll put in the time
all right so i just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what i was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time i'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger
so a build can be triggered using
various triggers that is there so we'll
get into this github
triggering or hook or a web hook kind of
a triggering later on but for now what i
want to do i want to ensure that this
job that i'm going to put in would be
automatically triggered on its own let's
say every minute i want this job to be
run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of help
that is available for me so for those of
you who have written cron jobs on linux
boxes you'll find it very very simple
but for others don't panic let me just
put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's
one
two three four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that i'm
going to put in and jenkins got a little
worried and is asking me do you really
mean every minute oh yeah i want to do
this every minute let me save this and
how do i check whether it gets triggered
every minute or not i just don't do
anything i'll just wait for a minute
and if at all everything goes well
jenkins would automatically trigger my
second job in a minutes time from now
this time around i'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see
it's automatically got trigger
if i go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42
1642 which is 442 my time that looks
good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this jog would be
automatically triggered
now that i have
my jenkins up and running a few jobs
that has been put up here on my jenkins
instance i would need a way of
controlling access to my jenkins server
this is wherein i would use a plugin
called role based access plugin and
create few rules the rules are something
like a global role and a project rule
project specific growth i can have
different roles and i can have users who
have signed up or the users whom might
create kind of assigned to these roles
so that each of these users fall into
some category this is my way of kind of
controlling access to my jenkins
instance and
ensuring that people don't do something
unwarranted all right so first things
first let me go ahead and install a
plugin
for doing that so i get into manage
jenkins and manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed and advanced as of now we
don't have the role based plugin so let
me go to available it will take some
time for it to get refreshed all right
now these are the available plugins
these are the install plugins
all right so let me come back to
available and i would want to search for
my role based access plugin so i would
just search for role and hit enter
okay role based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a role
based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or nodes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that i want
i would want to install it without a
restart
all right looks good so far yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember jenkins is running on a java
using a java instance so typically many
things would work the same way unless
and until you want to restart jenkins
once in a while but as a good practice
whenever you do some sort of a big
installations or big patches on your
jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restart it otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your jenkins instance but for
now i don't need that it looks good i've
installed the plugin so where do i see
my plugin i installed the plugin that is
specific to the
user control or the access control so
let me go into
yes global security
and i would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role based plugin so
this is what i would want to enable
because i already have my own database
setup and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what i'm going
to install i mean i've already installed
a role-based strategy
plugin and i'm going to enable that
strategy all right i would say save okay
now i've installed the role based access
plugin i would need to just set it up
and check that you know i would go ahead
and create some roles and ensure that i
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to manage jenkins
configure
all right let me see where is this
configure configure global security is
that where i create my roles
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now i've just enabled the plugin i
have enabled role based access control
and i would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular jenkins
instance so i would say first
manage rules
i would need to create some roles here
and the roles are at a very high level
these are global rules and there are
some project rules and there are some
slave rules i'll not get into details of
all of this at a very very high level
which is a global role let me just
create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group
so i would create a role called
developer typically the jenkins instance
or the ca instance are kind of owned up
or controlled by qa guys so qr guys
would need to provide some sort of uh
you know limited access to developers so
that's why i'm creating a role called
developer
and i'm adding this role at a global
role level so i would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
if you hover over it you would see some
sort of a
help on what what are these uh you know
permissions specific to so what i want
is like you know it sounds a little
different but i would want to give very
very little permissions for the
developer so from an administration
perspective i would just want him to
have a read
kind of a role credentials again i would
just want to view kind of a rule i don't
want him to create any agents and all
that stuff that's looks good for me
for a job i would want him to just
possibly
read i don't want him to build i don't
want him to cancel any jobs i don't want
him to configure any job i don't even
want him to create any job i would just
want him to read few things i would not
give him possibly a role to the
workspace as well i mean i don't want
him to have access to the workspace i
would just want him to
read a job
or check you know have read only access
to the job run
um no i don't want him to give him any
any particular access which will allow
him to run any jobs view configure
yeah possibly create yeah
delete i don't want to read yes
definitely and this is the specific role
so what i'm doing i'm just creating a
global role called developer and i'm
giving him very very limited roles in
the sense that i don't want this
developer to be able to run any agents
nor create jobs or build jobs or cancel
jobs or configure jobs at the max i just
want him to read a job that is already
put up there
okay
so i would save
now i created a role i still don't have
any users that is there on the system so
let me go ahead and create some user on
the system
that's not here how sick configure
manage and cans manage users okay let me
create a new user
i would call this user as yeah developer
one sounds good
some password
some password that i can remember
okay his name is developer1
d at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which i kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer1 is a user that
i have configured so still have not set
any rules for this particular user yet
so i would go to manage and gains
i would say
manage and assign roles i would say
assign rules
okay so if you see what i'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular i will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that i have already
configured
the role shows up here i would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that i created was
developer1 i would add this particular
user and now this particular user what
kind of a role i want him to have
because this is the global rule that had
created so developer i would assign this
developer 1 to this particular global
rule
and i would go ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges
so
there you go i have jenkins but i don't
see a new item i can't trigger a new job
i can't do anything i see these jobs
however i don't think so i'll be able to
start this job i don't have the
permission set for that the maximum i
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and i added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role so that the
developers don't get to configure any of
the jobs because the jenkins instance is
owned by a qr person he doesn't want to
give developer any administrative rights
so the rights that he set out by
creating a developer role and anybody
who is tagged any user who's tagged as a
part of this developer role would get
the same kind of permissions and this
permissions can be you know fine grain
it can be a project specific permissions
as well but for now i just demonstrated
the high level permission that i had set
in let me quickly log out of this user
and get back
as the admin user because i need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created i have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
jenkins being so popular as i mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect jenkins to an aws instance or
you want to connect jenkins to a docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if i want to connect jenkins
to bitbucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers
there's so many plugins that is
available okay so
bottom line jenkins without plugins is
nothing so plugins is the heart of
jenkins for you to connect or for in
order to connect jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got java and maven
you would need to install maven and jdk
on your jenkins instance if at all
you're looking for a net build or a
microsoft build you would need to have
ms build installed on your on your
jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server side web hooks
from github you will need github
specific plugins if you want to connect
jenkins to aws you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the url which is
publicly reachable you just have a
docker plug-in that is installed on your
jenkins instance sonarcube is one of the
popular static code analyzers so you can
connect a jenkins build you can build a
job on jenkins and push it to sonar cube
and get sonar cube to run analysis on
that and get back the results in jenkins
all of these works very well because of
the plugins now with that let me connect
our jenkins instance to github i already
have very very simple java repository up
on my github instance so let me connect
jenkins to this particular github
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple
you know repository that is there called
hello java and this is what is there in
the repo there is a hello hello.java
application that is here or a simple
class file that is there it's got just
one line of system dot out so this is
already present on github.com at this
place and this would be the url for this
repository
if i pick up the https url this is my
cps url so what i would do is i would
connect my jenkins instance to go to
github provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloudhostedgithub.com
and get it to my jenkins instance and
then build this particular java file i'm
keeping the source code very very simple
it's just a java file how do i build my
java file how do i compile my java file
i just say java c and the name of my
class file which is hello java and how
do i run my java file i would say java
and hello
okay so remember i don't need to install
any plugins now because uh what it needs
is a git plugin so if you remember when
we were doing the installation there was
a bunch of recommended plugins so git is
already installed on my system so i
don't need to install it again so let me
put up a new job here it says git job
let it be a freestyle project that's
good for me i would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some echo kind of uh
jobs we did not need any integration
with any of the source code systems so
now let me connect this so i'm going to
put up a source code and git would show
up because the plugin is already there
svn perforce any of those additional
source code management tools if at all
you would need just install those
plugins and jenkins connects wonderfully
well to all these particular source
control tools okay so i would copy the
https url from here i would say this is
the url that i'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so i'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so i would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password i just save this and say add
and then i would say you know use this
credentials to go to github and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
jenkins not able to find git or the git
dot exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me i'm going to grab this
url what am i going to do
this step would pull the source code
from the github
and then what would be there as a part
of my build step
because this repository just has a java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this i would just say
execute windows batch command and i
would say java c
hello dot
java that is the way i would build my
java code and if i have to run it i
would just say java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from github
so java c java that sounds good i would
say save this
and let me try to run this
okay if you see
there's a lot of you know it executes
git on your behalf it goes out here it
provides my credentials and says you
know it pulls all my repository and by
default it will pull up the master
branch that is there on my repository
and it kind of builds this whole thing
java c hello java and it runs this
project java hello and there you see
this is the output that is there and if
at all you want to look at the contents
of the repository if you can go here
this is my
workspace
of my system hang on this is not right
okay good job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my github repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the github repository all right so
this was the same program that was here
and jenkins on our behalf went over all
the way to github pulled this repository
from there and then you know it brought
it down to my local system on my jenkins
instance it compiled it and it ran this
particular application
okay now that i've integrated jenkins
successfully with github for a simple
java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what i will do is i
have a maven based web application that
is up there as a repository in my github
so this is the repository that i'm
talking about it's called amv and web
app it's got it's a maven based uh
repository as you would know maven is a
very very simple java based uh build
tool that will allow you to run various
targets and it will compile it will
based upon the goals that you specify it
can compile it can run some tests and it
can you can build a war file and even
deploy it into some other server for now
what we're going to use maven is just
for building and creating a package out
of this particular web application it
contains a bunch of things and what is
important is just the index.jsp it just
contains an html file that is there as a
part of this web application so from a
perspective of requirements now since
i'm going to connect jenkins with this
particular repository git we already
have that set we only need two other
things one is maven because jenkins will
use maven so in order to use maven
jenkins would have to have a maven
installation that is there on the
jenkins box and in this case the jenkins
box is this laptop
and after i have my maven installed i
also need a tomcat server tomcat is a
very very simple web server that you can
freely download i'll let you know how to
quickly uh download and install the
tomcat all right so download maven first
the various ways in which you can kind
of download this maven there is zip
files
binary zip files and archive files so
what i've done is i've just already
downloaded maven and if you see i've
unzipped it here so this is the folder
with which i have unzipped my maven
so as you know maven again is is one
open source build tool so you'll have to
set in a few configurations and set up
the path so mvn iphone iphone version if
i specify this after i set in my path my
one should work and if at all i echo
empty home which is nothing but the
variable environment variable specific
to my onenote it is already set here
so once you unzip my one just set this
m2 home variable to the directory where
you unzip your mi1 also just set the
path to this particular directory slash
bin because that is where your maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with maven and you
know since i've set the path and the
environment variable maven is running
perfectly fine on my system i just
verified it okay next one is the tomcat
server
download apache tomcat
server 8.5 is what i have on my system
so i'm just going to show you where to
download this from
this is where you download tomcat server
and
i already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
i just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration i have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080. since we
already have our jenkins server running
on port 8080 we cannot let tomcat run on
the same port there will be a port clash
so what i've done i have configured
tomcat to use a different port so if i
go to this configuration file here there
is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 8080 i've just
modified it to 8081. so i've changed the
port on which my tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by tomcat so for that i need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my jenkins
instance
so i would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
i've already created
a username called deployer and the
password is deployer and i've added a
role called manager hyphen script
manager hyphen script will allow
programmatic access to the tomcat server
so this is the role that is there so
using this credentials i will enable or
i'll empower jenkins to get into my
tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required
let me just start my tomcat server first
so i get into my bin folder i open a
command prompt here and there's a
startup startup.bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes there you go tomcat server
is up and running now this is running on
port 8081 so let me just check if that
looks good
so localhost
8081.
okay my tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what i'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
i'm good to use maven as a part of my
jenkins so i will put up a simple job
now
i will say job
mbn
web app i call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the url of my git repository is
this guy
https url
okay
that's this url i will use the
credentials the old credentials that i
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that i'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after i get this since i said this
is a simple maven repository i will have
some maven targets to run
so the simple target first is
let me run maven package this creates a
war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever i
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see
if it connects well if there's any
problem with my war file or the war file
gets created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a war file and if
you see it all shows you what is the
location where this war file was
generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this war file was successfully
built now i need to grab this particular
war file and then i would need to deploy
it into tomcat server
again i would need a small plugin to do
this because i need to connect tomcat
with my jenkins server
let me go ahead and
install the plugin for the container
deployment so i will go to manage
plugins
available
type in container
container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that i would need i will
install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the target folder
i would see this web application war
file that is already built
so i would need to configure this plugin
to pull up this war file and deploy it
onto the tomcat server for deploying
onto the tomcat server i will use the
credentials of the user that i've
created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good i'm gonna just
create a package that's all fine
now
add a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
directive let me use this
deployment to container now this will
show up after you install the plugin so
deploy this one to the container
now what is that you're supposed to
specify you're supposed to specify
the what is the location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot war that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the tomcat server
i will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now i need
to specify what kind of a container that
i'm talking about
all right so the deployment would be for
this tomcat 8.5 is what i need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that i have so this
would be the url so the credentials yes
i need to add a credential for this
particular server so if you remember i
had created a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential
i would say i would say add a new
credential jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
deployer
so i would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the url of my
tomcat instance
so this is the url of my tomcat instance
so take the war file that is find found
in this particular
folder
and then you know context path is main
web use the deployer deployment
credentials and get into this localhost
which is there
8081 this is the tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
i would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
uh looks like the deployment went ahead
perfectly well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if i
type in this
all right if at all i go ahead into my
tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder
you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server it was built locally
on the jenkins test and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo i'm running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
ip address all that you've got to go and
change is the url of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that you know if you
have a tomcat which is running on some
other machine that's all fine with a
different ipa that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using jenkins and
maven the four components are as follows
the docker client and server which we've
already done a deeper dive on docker
images docker containers and the docker
registry so if we look at the structure
that we have here on the left hand side
you see the relationship between the
docker client and the docker server and
then we have the rest api in between now
if we start digging into that rest api
particularly the relationship with the
docker daemon on the server we actually
have our other elements that form the
different components of the docker
ecosystem so the docker client is
accessed from your terminal window so if
you are using windows this can be
powershell on mac it's going to be your
terminal window and it allows you to run
the docker daemon and the registry
service when you have your terminal
window open so you can actually use your
terminal window to create instructions
on how to build and run your docker
images and containers if we look at the
images part of our registry here we
actually see that the image is really
just a template with the instructions
used for creating the containers which
you use within docker the docker image
is built using a file called the docker
file and then once you've created that
docker file you'll store that image in
the docker hub or registry and that
allows other people to be able to access
the same structure of a docker
environment that you've created the
syntax of creating the image is fairly
simple it's something that you'll be
able to get your arms around very
quickly and essentially what you're
doing is you're creating the option of a
new container you're identifying what
the image will look like what are the
commands that are needed and the
arguments for within those commands and
once you've done that you have a
definition for what your image will look
like so if we look here at what the
container itself looks like is that the
container is a standalone executable
package which includes applications and
their dependencies it's the instructions
for what your environment will look like
so you can be consistent in how that
environment is shared between multiple
developers testing units and other
people within your devops team now the
thing that's great about working with
docker is that it's so lightweight that
you can actually run multiple docker
containers in the same infrastructure
and share the same operating system this
is its strength it allows you to be able
to create those multiple environments
that you need for multiple projects that
you're working on interestingly though
within each container that container
creates an isolated area for the
applications to run so while you can run
multiple containers in an infrastructure
each of those containers are completely
isolated they're protected so that you
can actually control how your solutions
work there now as a team you may start
off with one or two developers on your
team but when a project starts becoming
more important and you start adding in
more people to your team you may have 15
people that are offshore you may have 10
people that are local you may have 15
consultants that are working on your
project you have a need for each of
those developers or each person on your
team to have access to that docker image
and to get access to that image we use
the docker registry which is an open
source server-side service for hosting
and distributing the images that you
have defined you can also use docker
itself as its own default registry and
docker hub now something it has to be
very mine though is that for publicly
shared images you may want to have your
own private images in which case you
would do that through your own registry
so once again public repositories can be
used to host the docker images which can
be accessed by anyone and i really
encourage you to go out to docker and
see the other docket images that have
been created because there may be tools
there that you can use to speed up your
own development environments now you
will also get to a point where you start
creating environments that are very
specific to the solutions that you are
building and when you get to that point
you'll likely want to create a private
repository so you're not sharing that
knowledge with the world in general now
the way in which you connect with the
docker registry is through simple pull
and push commands that you run through
terminal window to be able to get the
latest information so if you want to be
able to build your own container what
you'll start doing is using the pull
commands to actually pull the image from
the docker repository and the command
line for that is fairly simple in
terminal window you would write docker
pull and then you put in the image name
and any tags associated with that image
and use the command pulls so in your
terminal window you would actually use a
simple line of command once you've
actually connected to your docker
environment and that command will be
docker pull with the image name and any
associated tags around that image what
that will then do is pull the image from
the docker repository whether that's a
public repository or a private one now
in reverse if you want to be able to
update the docker image with a new
information you do a push command where
you would take the script that you've
written about the docker container that
you defined and push it to the
repository and as you can imagine the
commands for that are also fairly simple
in terminal window you would write
docker push the image name any
associated tags and then that would then
push that image to the docker repository
again either a public or a private
repository so if we recap the docker
file creates a docker image that's using
the build commands a docker image then
contains all the information necessary
for you to be able to execute the
project using the docker image any user
can run the code in order to create a
docker container and once a docker image
is built it's uploaded to a registry or
to a docker hub where it can be shared
across your entire team and from the
docker hub users can get access to the
docker image and build their own new
containers welcome to all our viewers
i'm anjali from simply learn and today
i'll be taking you through the
installation process for docker so
before we begin let me give you an intro
to docker so what is docker docker is a
tool which is used to automate the
deployment of applications in
lightweight containers so when i say
containers i mean a software package
that consists of all the dependencies
required to run the particular
application and when you deploy
containers you're basically providing
the capability for the application to
run in any kind of environment so
dockers have multiple features some of
which are that multiple containers can
run on the same hardware it has very
high productivity when compared to
virtual machines it maintains isolated
applications and has a very quick and
easy configuration process so now let's
begin with the demo we'll be installing
docker on an ubuntu system so this is my
system i just opened the terminal so the
first thing you can start with is
removing any docker installation that
you probably already have present in
your system if you want to start from
scratch so this is the command to do so
sudo apt get remove
docker
docker engine docker dot io enter your
password
and docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install docker
once again
before that i'll just clear my screen
okay so before i install docker let me
just ensure that all these softwares on
my system currently is in its latest
state
so sudo apt get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment of
the machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type docker install
and that by itself will give you the
command you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install
docker dot io is a command that we will
need to execute to install docker
and after that we will execute the suros
snap install docker so sudo apt install
docker dot io first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have
sudo snap install docker so snap install
docker installs a newly created snap
package
there are basically some other
dependencies for docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire docker i o
it will take some time
great so our docker is installed the
next thing we do as i mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages
so the command for that is
sudo snap install docker
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is docker
version
and as you can see docker version
17.12.1
ce has been installed
next thing we do is we pull
an image from the docker hub
so docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a docker image which
is present on the docker hub docker hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker image hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now
the command to check this
is sudo docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository
this is present on our system currently
so the image has been successfully
pulled onto the system
and this means that our docker is
working
now we'll try out another command
sudo docker ps minus a
this displays all the containers that
you have pulled so far so as you can see
here there are three hello world images
displayed and all of them are in exited
state so i did this demo previously too
which is why the two hello worlds which
is created two minutes ago is also
displayed here and the first hello world
which has been created a minute ago is
the one we just did for this demo now as
you have probably noticed that all the
hello world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for docker ps
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running state you can
simply execute sudo docker ps
suro
docker yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running state and with that we come to
an end of our docker installation
welcome everyone to our one another demo
on which we are going to see that how
exactly we can do the installation of
docker on the windows platform
specifically on windows 10. now docker
is something which is available for most
of the operating systems different
different platforms so it supports both
the unix and the windows platform as
such so
linux through various commands we can do
the installation but in the case of
windows you have to download the exe
file and a particular installer from the
docker hub websites you can simply
google it and you will get a kind of a
link from where you will be able to
download the package so let's go to the
chrome and try to search on for the
windows string uh particular installer
you will get a link from docker hub you
download it you get the stable version
you get the edge version whichever
version you want you wish to download
you can download it so let's go back to
the chrome so here you have the docker
desktop for windows so you can go for
this table or you can go for the edge
right so you also have the comparison
that what is the difference between
these two versions right
so um the particular edge version is
something which is getting releases
every month and uh the
stable version is getting the releases
every quarter so they are not doing much
of the changes to the stable version as
compared to the edge there so you just
have to double click on the installer
and that will help you to do the
installation of the process so let's get
started so you just click on the get
instable version so when you do that the
uh particular installer is going to
install now it's going to take like
around 300 mb there so that's the kind
of installed which is available
so uh once the installer is downloaded
so what you can do is that you can
actually go ahead and you can uh proceed
with the doing the double click on this
installer when you double click on that
you have to proceed with some of the
steps like you know from the gui itself
you are going to proceed with these
steps so we'll wait for 10 to 20 seconds
more and then the installer will be done
and then we can do the double click and
the installation will proceed
so another thing is that uh there is a
huge difference between the installer
like for example in case of unix the
installer is a little bit less but in
case of windows it's a gui is also
involved and there are a lot of binders
which is available there so that's the
reason why you know the huge size is
there now it's available for free that's
for sure and it also requires the
windows 10 professional or enterprise
64-bit there so um if you are working on
some previous version of operating
systems like windows 7 and all you have
the older version called docker toolbox
so they used to call it as like docker
toolbox earlier but now they are calling
it as a docker desktop with the new
docker windows 10 support as such here
so another couple of seconds and then
the installer will be done and then we
will be able to proceed with the
installation
so let's see that how much progress is
there to the download so we'll click on
the downloads and here still we have
some particular installations or some
download going on so we'll wait for some
time and once the installation is done
then we'll go back and we'll proceed
with installation
so couple of seconds
so it's almost done so i'll just click
on this one you can go to the directory
to the downloads and you can double
click on that also but if you want to do
the installation you can click on this
one also and it will ask for the
approval yes or no you have to provide
now once that is done so um a desktop a
kind of a gui component will open there
so it will start proceeding with
installation so it's asking whether you
want to add a desktop the shortcut to
desktop so you can say okay i'm going to
click on ok so it will unpack the files
all the files which is required for
docker to successfully install that is
getting unpacked over here so it will
take some time to do the installation
because it's doing a lot of work here so
you can just wait for till the execution
of the installer to be completed and
once the installer is done you can open
your command line and start working on
the docker
so taking some time to extract the files
now it's asking us to you know do the
close and do the restart so once that is
done you will be able to proceed further
and you can just you know run the
command line and any docker command if
you can run so that will give you the
response whether the docker is installed
or not so you can see here the docker is
you know something which is installed so
you can run like docker version you will
be able to get a version
of the client when you do the restart of
the machine then at that moment of time
the docker server will also be started
and then this particular error message
will go off right now the docker demand
is not up and running because the
installation requires a restart and when
you close on this one and go for the
restart the machine will be restarted
here so this is the way that how exactly
we can go for a docker installation and
we can go on that part welcome everyone
to this topic on docker tutorial for the
beginners here now in this one we are
going to talk about the various
components for example what is the
devops here why the devops is important
what is docker the advantages of docker
installation of docker
architecture of docker components of
docker game
so these are the different things which
we are going to talk about over here now
let's start with what exactly isn't
devops all about here now devops is
nothing but a collaboration between the
development and the operations teams
over here which enables continuous
delivery of the applications and
services to the end user so it's a
combination or collaboration between the
two teams development and operations
which helps us to go for a further
implementation of various processes like
continuous integration continuous
deployment continuous delivery all these
things are possible with this
collaboration over here now why exactly
docker is important for us as such
in a city far away from this one so
a developer decided to develop a tons of
software on a single vm now he can put
up applications he is having a big
server and he wants to host the the
multiple application on a single machine
but for him these virtual machine got a
crash because definitely if you are
putting up more uh different different
applications as such on the on a single
vm
it's not able to take up that much kind
of load over there so in order to avoid
this situation how exactly he can do the
various options or what he can
implement to have this
issue resolved
so ultimately docker is something which
is the solution of him so if he really
wants to host multiple applications uh
on a single virtual machine or he want
to have different different applications
then docker is the ultimate solution for
him to do that and by doing so uh there
will be no issues as such when we talk
about that uh the errors or the
uh virtual machines cannot be crashed
and but there will be no impact on the
virtual machine as such so why exactly
docker is important so let's talk about
the comparison between the docker and
virtual machine there are very few
reasons why exactly uh the docker is
being chosen open a virtual machine
because virtual machine is a
full-fledged component which can take up
any kind of load but some of the reasons
are still that in which case we will be
preferring the docker instead of the
virtual machine here the very first one
is the memory users so docker is having
a very less memory uses because there is
no concept of guest operating system
whereas on the other hand the virtual
machines are going to take a huge amount
of ram
resources in order to keep that
particular operating system up and
running second one performance because
if definitely if you have less
utilization and the users is less the
performance will be better but for some
reason if you are taking up more
resources and you will not be able to
deliver that amount of performance as
such over there and then again we have
portability so portability is also quite
easy when we talk about the virtual
machines in case of docker it it's quite
portable as compared to the virtual
machine and then the last time is that
the boot up time so virtual machine boot
up time is probably in minutes but uh in
case of docker it's in seconds so if we
summarize it on this one so the memory
utilization the boot up time the
performance everything is better in case
of docker as compared to the virtual
machines
right for a classic example let's say
that what about the memory user 9gb of
memory uh you know is something if you
can see that one f2 and app3 is there so
green and red color represents the
occupied memory and the wasted memory
now
there is a particular utilization of
let's say that um you know a server
which is available there and uh you know
3 gb of
ram is something which is wasted and 4
gb of ram is something which is being
occupied there so app 2 is using like 2
gb and then you can see that the
specific 2gb of ram is occupied and 3gb
is occupied and the wasted one is 1gb so
vm can see over there that uh you know
9gb of ram is used and the remaining 6
gb of
unused ram cannot be reused because if
for example i allocate like 4 gb of ram
to the virtual machine it's there itself
it it gets locked on so
it's not like okay uh i'm using only 4gb
ram out of this
9gb of ram then the next
5gb of ram will be totally wasted so you
cannot reuse it for any purpose
so this is a problem with the virtual
machine that if you allocate some memory
to the uh specific virtual machine if
you are not using that much uh resources
or that much memory the remaining memory
will be simply wasted because this is
hardcorely allocated to virtual machine
and you cannot utilize this unused
memory as such over there so this is the
limitation from the memory perspective
but in case of docker definitely if uh
you know out of the 9gb of ram if we are
using uh only 3gb of ram
so whatever the unused memory is there
so we can actually use it to for the new
containers so it's not dedicatedly
allocated to the virtual machines if you
are using
out of 9gb if you are using 1gb 2gb 3gb
or 4gb whatever the remaining
memory is available that you can simply
use it for the other containers also
this ensures that you always go for an
optimal utilization of your resources
and unnecessarily there is no wastage of
the different different resources or the
different components over here in this
one so that's the reason why the docker
containers are quite uh efficient in
terms of memory when we compare it with
the virtual machine next one is the
performance now um in a virtual machine
we know that you know on the
infrastructure on the physical
infrastructure on top of that you put up
a kind of operating system a base
operating system is there and then on
top of that you have the hypervisor and
this hypervisor then is used to create
the virtual machines which is having a
kind of guest operating system inside it
now the issue over here is that you have
two operating systems over here so the
guest operating system is also going to
take some particular resources and uh
for example memory or a space a
processor so in every terms in every
resource terms it is going to
go ahead and say that okay i'm going to
use the
particular some of the resources now
problem is
that if you're hosting a very small
application you will end up in having a
more consumption because of this guest
operating system will take more more of
the resources and then you are just
using some small very small resources
for your application in an uh real world
so docker container on the other hand
does not have a concept of the guest
operating system and that's where
what happens that the docker engine is
more than sufficient to handle the
docker containers and inside the docker
containers there is the application
which is being hosted over there now
with this one definitely the performance
is quite better as compared to any
virtual machine because of the terms
that there is no unnecessary wasted of
the resources because in the previous
case virtual machines a full-fledged
guest operating system is up and running
you need some resources to be allocated
to that but in case of containers you
don't need to have that particular
functionality implemented then
portability so um you know having a
portability or moving an application
which works on a system a does not means
that it will work on the system b also
this is a similar problem which we face
that you know the usually the
application works perfectly fine in a
lower environment and when it goes to
the production environment it sometimes
fails and it does not comes up properly
so this isn't portability issue which we
have when we talk about the virtual
machines but when in case of containers
when we got a container up and running
in a lower environment and once the
container is prepared you don't have to
do the changes on modification to that
depending on the environment the same
container can be deployed in production
environment and it's very easy so
whatever container prepared in the lower
environment in a dev environment the
same will work in production environment
without any issues because it contains
all the dependencies and executables
everything inside it so you don't have
to do any kind of modifications or
changes to these containers as such over
here and the last one is the boot up
time so
the boot up time of the virtual machines
is in minutes and whereas the boot up
time of uh the
docker containers is in seconds or
probably in milliseconds so these are
the reason why we consider the virtual
machine as an uh resources
based uh environment but on the other
hand docker is something which is quite
light and fast as compared to virtual
machines so let's see that what exactly
is in docker all about here so in this
one you can see uh we have the physical
infrastructure on which we have
the host operating system now we don't
have the hypervisor and the guest
operating system instead of that we have
the docker engine which is taking care
of managing the docker containers and
inside these docker containers you have
the applications and all the required
binaries and the libraries here so there
is no concept of the gift operating
system these docker engine is the uh
person or is the process which is taking
care of all the requests which is going
on and if this docker engine is up and
running then all the containers will
also be accessible and will be available
now docker is nothing but a os level
virtualization
software platform that enables
developers and id administrators to
create deploy and run applications in a
docker container with all its
dependencies so docker is a very
important tool nowadays if you want to
look forward to the host your
application because of its portability
uh benefit that you don't require much
of the changes uh depending on the
platform or depending on the environment
so whatever the developers are able to
build up the same thing will go till the
production environment now let's talk
about what exactly is in docker
container here now docker container is a
lightweight software package that uh
includes all the dependencies whether
it's a
base operating system uh some framework
some libraries it's it's something which
is a part of this one so that if you
will be
if you want to host your application you
will be able to do that so it's a
complete package so both the source code
and the dependencies is what you put up
inside the docker containers
now
within this docker containers you can
have multiple applications there
multiple programming languages multiple
frameworks can be hosted there in fact
the databases also can be hosted within
these docker containers you can host
them as such over there now one of the
different advantages of docker let's
talk about that now the first one is the
rapid deployment so rapid deployment is
the very first
advantages which we are getting over
here second
quick and easy configuration
better efficiency
portability
scalability and security over here now
there are different ways in which we can
understand the uh benefits or we can
have the understanding about the
docker here so uh these are some couple
of
benefits now let's take up uh take them
one by one the for the first one is the
deployment part so
it's it supports the rapid deployment
now
just like a web application for instance
i want to deploy to websites so there
are some couple of steps which
needs to be done across different
different environments like for example
if i have five environments i have to do
the deployment the same steps in all the
five environments at the different
period of time now when we talk about
docker containers we don't have to run
those steps multiple times because once
those steps are executed in one docker
container the same docker container goes
till the production environment so you
don't have to actually do a rebuild of
the docker containers and you can simply
say that okay i have got the docker
container here so you can just run one
or two couple of commands and that will
help you to host your docker containers
so you don't have to redo or rework on
any kind of the deployment work into the
production environment or into the
higher environments and then we goes for
the
quick and easy configurations so the
configurations of docker containers is
quite easy you can have your own custom
docker images built out the docker files
so uh these processes can be integrated
within the jenkins also so cicd is quite
possible with the help of docker if you
want to really do that and
then we have better efficiency yes they
have a better efficiency and their
resources management as compared to the
virtual machines portability uh we have
already thought about that that it's
easy to move from one environment from
one system to another in fact it's easy
from the developer also so from one
machine from one developer to another
developer it's very easy to move these
uh different docker containers then we
have scalability
scalability is also possible with this
docker containers just like multiple
virtual machines you can also create
multiple containers and you can share
the traffic out of that so but that
scalability and all is possible with the
orchestration tools uh then security is
there so
you can have your best practices of the
security implemented because um it's
just a kind of a virtualization just
like a virtual machine so you have all
the uh different uh possibilities which
is available which you can explore when
you talk when you want to make this
stock container secure right so these
were some of the benefits which was
there for the docker here now let's talk
about the installation of docker here
now installation of docker is pretty
common and uh whatever platform you want
uh it's available over there so it's
available for ubuntu windows
it's available for mac operating system
so for ubuntu you have to run the
commands on the ubuntu part operating
system to download it and for windows
it's actually having a a particular exe
file so you can go for the installation
of exe file and then we have the mac
operating system so for mac operating
system you have the dmg files and when
you do the dmg file so it will uh help
you to install the
component over there so mac you can also
use the home view uh wants to do the
installation of that particular
component
now next one is the architecture of
docker
now the architecture of docker is pretty
straightforward there are key components
which is available there in the
architecture of docker here the very
first one is the as the client facing is
the docker client now docker client or
you can say that docker cli is available
there now this is the component it's a
command line interface which takes up
the request from the end user like for
example i'm running the command so it
will take all the requests from me as an
end user and it will send those
particular uh things are the
requirements to the docker daemon to the
server using the rest api interface so
this docker daemon is something which
keeps on running on the server and it's
a background process it gets deployed as
in service there in case this docker
demon is not available or it's not up
and running you will not get the proper
response from the docker command line
here so in order to get all your
activity or your uh procedures
implemented you need to have the docker
server or docker daemon up and running
in fact this docker cli can be
configured to connect to any other
servers or any other different server
docker daemon also so it's a
connectivity which is happening over the
rest api interface where all the
requests are processed are sent to the
docker demon and whatever response is
coming back that is given back to the
end user so what are the different
components of docker here let's talk
about that so docker client consists of
the cli component uh like we have
already discussed so that is something
which is uh going to take up all the
requests from the end user then um it's
using the rest api interface which is
there to have the connectivity with the
docker daemon so docker daemon is uh
something which is always up and running
so if you run couple of commands like
docker pull push and also that activity
you are actually sending the request to
the docker demon and docker daemon is
actually doing all the work so it's not
a docker client which is doing it just
taking its kind of interface which will
take the things up and send it back or
send it forward to the docker day
right so it's a background process which
keeps on running on the server on the
operating system and uh it's the same
process across all the infrastructure
all the different platforms whether you
use mac operating system you use windows
or you use linux everywhere this is the
basic functionality and uh it keeps on
listening to the rest api interface so
uh whatever the request new request
comes in it immediately process it and
whatever the response whether you are
stopping a container whether you're
running a container according to that
the action will be taken and the
response will be sent back to the rest
api to the docker client so a docker is
a processor it's a command line which is
used to start the docker daemon
when you run the command like service
docker status on the server you will be
able to see the command which is getting
executed in the back end so there you
can see that dockered is the process or
is the command line which is used to
initialize the docker daemon and of
course there is a kind of configurations
which you have to pass it on as a
parameters so even if you run psyphonyf
command you will be able to know that
what process is running from the docker
perspective and the third component is a
particular docker registry so we have a
ready-made uh cloud service which is
available known as the docker hub so you
can actually store the docker images on
these docker registry so there are a lot
of ready-made uh docker images which is
available there but of course you can
have your own uh docker image also over
there or you want you can have your own
custom
registry docker registries also for
example in jfrog you can have your
private hosted registries also so all
these are different repositories you can
use with your docker container so docker
containers is having the flexibility
that whichever registries or
repositories you want to connect or you
want to establish the connectivity you
can always do that now let's talk about
the docker image over here
in detail
now a docker image is nothing but a
template of instructions it's having a
couple of instructions in which you will
be using these instructions to create a
final dock container so docker image
is uh nothing but uh for example i want
to have a tomcat apache docker image so
what are the instructions i have to do
so the very first thing is that i have
to pick up a base operating system then
on top of that i will be installing the
jdk or some prerequisite packages and
then on top of that we will be
configuring on to the tomcat apache
there so these are the steps these are
the different instructions step by step
procedure which we are implementing so
that at the end of the
activity we will be able to have a
docker container ready which we can
deploy to host tomcat apache so it's a
template which is having all the uh
particular instructions in order to
build a docker image you require a file
called dockerfile which is uh of course
having all these different uh
instructions embedded in that so when
you run the docker file it acts like a
build tool so whatever the instructions
you are putting up over there all those
instructions are getting uh processed
and you are able to get a end result
then these docker images are actually
comprised of multiple layers so multiple
layers are available there so step by
step so you will be first of all having
a base layer from which the image starts
on top of that another layer for example
you did the installation of jdk so
another layer will be there and then you
did the configuration
of of the tomcat apache and then another
layer will be there so it's a
multi-layered in uh component which is
available and these layers are in
incremental order so definitely the
oldest one will be known as the base
layer and then on top of that all the
latest changes will be done in the
latest layers there so this is an
example now here you can see that
there are four instructions and these
four instructions are also known as the
four layered docker image so whatever
the final docker image you will get in
there you will be able to see four
layers of uh the docker image here now
the very first is ubuntu so ubuntu 18.04
we are pulling up and then we are
pulling like uh the file over here and
uh then we are running the make utility
and uh once that is done then we are
running that file dot
python file over here in this one so
these are four instructions which is
available right so uh which will
definitely help us to do that how
exactly we can make or we can
perform the different activities right
from the base so in this case the base
layer will be like uh the one two one so
one two one will be the base image and
the moment the final cmd attribute or
cmd
uh
attributions are processed and executed
after that you will be able to get a
final full-fledged docker image over
there so this will be a full uh complete
docker image or docker container which
you will get once the whole build
process is completed
now in this case you have
you can see that the previous docker
file which we processed so the base
layer is ubuntu 18.04 we are not
building that actually it's
automatically so it's by default getting
downloaded as in full base layer after
that only we have like layer 1 layer 2
layer 3 added up because those
modifications we are doing it after the
because from does not means that you are
doing any kind of layer modifications
it's just like you are importing some
base operating system or base image so
the modification or adding up the layers
is only done after the base layer there
so whenever a user creates a container a
new layer is something which is stopped
on top of the image these layers are
known as the containers layers so one to
one the very first instruction does not
comprises it it is it's not a kind of
container layer we can call it as an
base image layer there so every
container has a separate read write
container layer and any modification in
a container is reflected upon the
container layers only so layer one may
be having some different of uh
instructions layer two maybe having
different instructions so like that it's
a step-by-step
processor in case
you know whenever a container is deleted
the top layer also gets deleted over
there in that one so if i delete some
particular containers and that is
something which is gone so it was
suppose having like three layers so the
top layer will be simply deleted because
the container is also deleted for that
particular part now docker uses a copy
and write strategy with both docker
images and docker containers
so whenever we uh perform any activity
or whenever copy on uh write a
strategies and strategy to share and
copy files for better efficiency so
it's something which is being used to
increase the overall performance of the
docker containers it also makes docker
efficient by reducing the uses of disk
space because whenever uh required okay
whenever is needed only at that moment
of time it's actually performing the
copy and it definitely reduces the
overall disk utilization and this is
very important also because when you
have so many docker containers up and
running so you have to worry or you have
to make the utilization of a disk or
your disk users or resources also
minimum so that is also you need to make
sure that it does not exceed a
particular value
so once the utilization is also less
then definitely the overall performance
will also be better and improved over
here in this case
so uh let's talk about uh some of the
facts here so the base layers are
something which is purely read-only
format so you cannot do the
modifications union file system saves
the memory uh you know by avoiding the
duplications of the files the layers can
be combined in a union file system to
create a single image so all these mail
layers are combined and got a final
product or called you know you can call
it as docker image or docker containers
and this allows a file system to appear
as a writable uh which is known as copy
on right so copy and write strategy is
being used so to do the changes or to do
the perform the modifications to this
union file system by creating the
different different layers
so
now let's talk about the docker registry
very important component because even if
you prepare the docker image locally and
you don't have the collaborative tool or
you don't have the
tool where you can share these images
definitely it's not easy for you to port
these docker images from one system to
another so docker registry is very
important for the portability feature of
docker so docker registry is a service
to host and distribute docker images
among users so uh it can be built up by
one user and multiple users can use it
for example i'm using a jenkins one so
um jenkins uh image is prepared only
once but it's being used by different
people as such docker registry uh again
it's a repository is a collection of
docker images so in a repository you
will be having like different different
uh docker images as such
so in registry a user can distinguish
between the darker images with their tag
names so uh for example jenkins is an a
kind of a single image they might be
different type of images there let's say
that okay let's talk about uh jenkins uh
jdk8 so there will be image called
changes the name of the image will be
same but the tags will be different so
one tag would be like jdk8 one tag would
be like jtk9 and one time would be jdk
10 so the difference between all these
three docker images is that that jdk81
is prepared on jdk8 it's running on jdk8
and if you want to use jtk9 in that case
you have to pull down the the docker
image of jenkins with the jdk 9
installed so depending on the frameworks
or depending on the runtimes so with
these tags different tags are processed
so you can have the distinctive between
the uh
docker images and whichever docker image
you feel you want to use you can
implement according to your requirement
and docker
by default is having its own
cloud-based registry called as docker
hub which gets automatically connected
when the moment you do the docker
installation but in case you are working
into your private infrastructure so in
that case uh you may use the
repositories or docker repositories on
the
specific jfrog artifactory or the
private repositories also can be hosted
but docker hub is something which is
having a public and private repositories
both so you can create either the public
and private repositories you can use uh
push and pull activities to interact
with these docker images you want to
download a docker image so you can run
pull if you want to push your docker
image to the docker registry in that
case you can run the push activity so in
both the cases you are doing the
interaction with the uh docker hub so
when you run some build process or when
you run the containers there may be some
docker containers which is getting
pulled down from the specific registry
from the docker hub and uh if that
specific image and tag is available
definitely pull command will be
successful but in case of push command
you are pushing your custom docker
images
you cannot push the ready-made docker
images which is available you can
publish your own docker image only to
the docker hub and then you can further
on do the poll and push activity
accordingly to those repositories so
whatever the ready-made and third-party
images which is available you can only
do the pull activities to them you
cannot do the push activities push
command scenario will only come when you
are looking when you are interacting
with your custom docker image next one
is the docker container now docker
container is an executable package of an
application and its dependencies
together so when we prepare a docker
container we actually combine both the
dependencies and the uh application
source code inside it so the docker
container don't have to look for the
dependencies on the host machine on the
server so this is one of the benefit
where we see that the portability is
very easy because whatever i'm building
up on one system
everything is inside the docker
container so i don't really need to do
any further activity on other machines
so whatever works on one system can be
easily worked on in the system
so it's very lightweight also so it can
be easily deployed and executed on you
know on their particular
servers because it does not take that
much utilization like a virtual machine
so if you are looking forward for having
your application hosted into your local
system you can easily do it within the
docked container so the utilization is
very less as compared to the virtual
machine so you don't have to worry about
your operating host operating system and
the qualifications
so docker containers can run in totally
isolation just like a virtual machine so
there is no interaction or there is no
interference so they share the os called
uh kernel but uh the thing is they don't
have the interface as such over there so
it works totally in isolation uh two
different containers will not have any
interaction unless and until we do we
set up that the containers to have the
interactions
now there is a data volumes where which
can be shared and uh be used among the
multiple containers so um you have the
uh capability over here that you know if
the there is some on
used uh space that can be easily shared
across the multiple containers here so
uh it is uh built using the docker
images so uh using the docker images the
docker containers are built up and uh
docker run is a specific command which
is used to build a docker container so
if you got a docker image let's say that
i have prepared a docker image a custom
docker image using the docker file now
if i need to create a docker container
out of a docker image i have to run a
docker run command so docker run command
is nothing
but it initializes or creates an
instance of a docker image now next
component is the docker compose
now typically when we work with the the
docker containers so we have to run like
if i want to run like five six
containers i have to initialize like
five six times or i have to run docker
and commands five six times there so um
and if you want to create a relationship
between the containers then definitely
that is something which you need to
manage using the docker commands but
sometimes it's not an easy task for you
to run those commands manually or
remember those commands so docker
compose is a utility over here using
which you can actually run multiple
containers with a single service
you just got off
a kind of a single file you just run it
and all the containers definitions and
relationships everything is inside this
docker file here so you want to run two
containers that's totally fine instead
of running two commands now you just
have to run one file and that will do
take care of that now
you may be having more than two
containers five six seven whatever
number of containers you have that can
be easily deployed without any
manual activity or without any
maintainers onto the server
so
these containers totally run in
isolation but yes you can establish the
interaction that how they want to uh
interact with each other and that
interaction you can put up in these uh
docker compose files so docker compose
file is something which is written in
the vml format and in this you define
that okay i need two containers and this
in this image should be there these are
the parameters which you need to run and
if you want to have the interaction or
the linkage between the images that also
you can establish within this yml files
or this in within this docker compose
file here right so let's say for example
i want to have an application which
requires apache web server and mysql
database now uh i can create a docker
compose file which can run both
containers and uh without you know you
don't require to restart or start them
separately or initialize them separately
so i will be having a final docker
compose file which is having like uh
you know containers like apache
containers and mysql containers both
inside a single docker compose file here
so that's the benefit you're going to
get because now you don't have to run
them separately separate apache and
separate via mysql so you can get it
done with the help of a single docker
compose file here now what exactly is
the docker swamp now docker swam
is a in-built or it's a default
uh orchestration tool which is being
provided by the docker itself it's a
service
for containers which allows the i t
administrators and the developers to
create and manage a cluster of swamp
nodes so
in a typical world when you do the
installation of docker there is a
limitation that you some of the features
like high ability multiple
instances or scalability all these
things are not possible as it is with
the core docker now on top of that you
require the organization tools like
docker swamp where you have a swam of
node machines uh five six known machines
are there on which you can have your
highly available application
infrastructure implemented now this one
means that if i want to run my
applications five containers six
containers and seven containers for that
purpose we are using the docker spam so
each node of docker swamp is having a
docker daemon uh which is uh used to for
performing the interaction so there will
be a master node which is available so
uh it will be interacting with all the
known machine on the all the client
machines and this interaction will be in
such a way that it will let them know
okay i want to deploy the container or
onto the note 3 so it will perform that
activity and the container will be up
and running on the note 3 there so a
swamp consists of two type of nodes one
is the manager node and one is the
worker node so manager is the master
node which you can refer
and the worker node is the one which is
actually doing most of the work so uh
the manager node is not something which
is expected to host uh anything apart
from the main component but yes
you can always configure
if you feel that you want to only deploy
the container on the worker node so that
also you can uh do during the deployment
of the containers so manager will will
keep on connecting to the different
worker nodes there and whenever new
request comes in so it will basically
try to connect and see that okay i just
want to go ahead and deploy a container
so it will do the deployment of the
container on the worker node so the main
work will be done by the worker nodes
and manager is just doing the management
of all these resources the worker nodes
will be definitely receiving the request
from the manager and uh it will be
proceeding and performing those
activities and uh
if for some reason worker node is not
active or online so uh the master node
will not be able to deploy the
containers on that server so right now
let's talk about a demo in which we have
to create a docker image using a docker
file on the open220 so uh you want to
use a base operating system as an ubuntu
20 there and using that we will we are
going to create a custom docker image
so let's connect to our virtual machine
and see that how we can do that okay so
as part of this demo here we are going
to prepare a docker image and uh in that
we are going to use a base image of
ubuntu so let's take an operating system
of ubuntu 220 20 is the latest version
of the ubuntu operating system so i have
got a server so let's see so first of
all we have to install the docker.io
package which will install the docker
package and then we can enable the uh
service we can make sure that the docker
service is up and running because if the
service itself is down then we will not
be able to perform any activity and then
our sample if you run docker run hello
hyphen volt so that is going to pull a
darker image from the docker hub and a
particular activity will be done to you
so once that is done so we can say that
okay the container is up and running and
everything is got uh you know over there
up and running and then you can also try
some of the ubuntu docker image also if
you feel that you want to try you can do
that but the main uh demo which we need
to do over here is that we need to
prepare a custom docker image and in
this one we will be having like we will
be using an ubuntu base operating system
on top of that we will be installing php
engine x all these different components
so we are going to have a php based
website hosted onto the apache web
server as an nginx and then we will be
able to access that application so the
very first thing which we need to do is
that we need to create a folder uh let's
say that i just create a particular
folder called nginx hyphen image and
then uh i create a docker file over
there so docker file uh content we are
going to take from this one so let's go
to the server and see that how we can go
ahead with the activity
now uh what we can do is that uh what uh
we have got a server over here
now in this server what i'm going to do
is that i'm going to proceed with the
installation of docker first now when i
do the docker installation first so what
will happen that i will be able to have
my docker installation completed and
then further on i can take the further
steps of having the accessibility of uh
going through the understanding that
what is this uh particular platform or
how to prepare different different kind
of containers so
i have got a particular container over
here so what i can really do is that i
can simply say that okay i have got a
server so this is a one-two server so
i'm going to run the command called app
update first now this will do the update
locally so all the links and everything
will be updated now the whole idea about
doing the updates is that so that i will
be able to ha establish the fact that i
am trying to connect i'm trying to uh
connect with the 0.2 url so that at any
moment of time i should be able to fetch
on the latest packages now once that is
done so i'm going to run the command
called apt install docker dot io now the
moment i do this what will happen that
it will try to download some packages it
will ask for the confirmation you can
give your confirmation and i can say yes
the moment you give the confirmations
the download of the packages will
proceed over here step by step it will
download the packages and the
installation will go on now once the
installation is done so what you can do
is that you can see that docker is
deployed into your system or not you can
run docker version command or you can
also use the service command to check to
make sure to ensure that the docker
service is always up and running if the
service is not up and running you have
to make sure you have to enable it you
have to start that service so these are
some couple of steps which you need to
do in order to make sure that your uh
connectivity or your environment is
ready for with the docker installation
and once the docker installation is done
then only you will be able to proceed
further with the further activities like
preparing the containers preparing the
images and all that stuff but if you
don't have the docker installed prior to
that then definitely it's going to be a
problem so
just make sure that before even doing
any kind of activity before even doing
any kind of steps we ensure that the
docker is fully up and running so it's
going to take some time to download the
packages and we will wait for that and
once the installation is done we will
continue further on that part
okay now once the installation is done
so you can run the command call service
docker status and when you do that
it will let you know that whether the
docker service is available there or not
so uh you can start the service
in case you don't get uh the proper
response
and
now you can see that it's showing up
that a process is running so earlier it
was not uh up and running it was
inactive but now it's active and you can
see here that dark ride is the process
which is running over here as an uh
process to initialize the docker daemon
so docker demon is up and running now
and we are good to go here so now uh if
we go and say like docker
run
hello hyphen vault so we are doing a
validation to our docker instance that
whether our docker instance is working
fine as expected or not because uh if
there is any kind of problem with the
docker demon and docker demon is not up
and running properly we would be able to
get an error message over there but
right now there is no error message
which represents that uh yes you are
pretty much running the docker image and
it's giving you the proper response so
you will be able to see the uh
docker images when you run so you will
be able to see that the docker image is
pulled down to your system and
definitely you have executed that and it
got you the response now the next thing
which we need to do is that we need to
run a particular
ubuntu one so for example if i go for
docker
run
iphone it
open to bash so what exactly we are
doing in this one is that we are pulling
down a one to docker image and we are
running the bash executable on top of
that the whole purpose of doing that
activity is that so that if i want to do
some uh process or i want to perform
some activity i should be able to
connect to that docker image so what the
moment i do this first of all if this
docker image is available locally that's
great it will immediately create the
container if the docker image is not
available locally the very first thing
which it will perform over here is to
pull down the docker image the correct
one and as you can see here that it uh
definitely pulls down the docker image
and once it is done so it got a terminal
for you now you can see it shows that
root at the id uh root at the rate one
id is there this id is nothing but it's
a container id which we are getting here
so definitely you are inside the docker
container and when you run the docker
when you run the exit command you will
see that you have come out of the docker
container over here and the moment you
run docker ps hyphen a command you can
actually see also that how many
container you deployed so far so you ran
hello world you ran the one to one both
of them are stopped there you can see
the exit zero in the status over here
because both of them are something which
you ran in the interactive mode so they
are done so if you want to keep your
container up and running you need to
have a container which runs in the dash
mode and always up and running but for
that you have to go ahead to the level
where we need to create a custom docker
image and do the setup accordingly so
let's see that how we can do that now
i'm going to create a particular folder
called nginx hyphen image
you can pretty much give any name
whatever name you feel you want to
perform you can do that now in this one
i'm going to put up a file called docker
file so let's see that what content we
need to put as such when we talk about
the docker file because whatever content
you put over here that is what according
which the docker image will be prepared
now here
we have to talk about so first we have
to see a base image so we are saying
that okay upon 220.04 is what i want to
use then we are giving some labels now
these labels are used to give some
information like uh what is the version
who is the maintainer
what is the description uh you can do
the customizations to this one so uh
these labels are actually defined and
utilized so that i will be able to give
an information that okay so and so
developer is something which we can
contact so if there is any kind of
problem with the uh docker file or will
this uh build script we have to reach
out to that specific person so this is
what we typically do with the labels
here now um we also have to
set up a parameter like deviant
underscore fronted as in non-interactive
because whenever we talk about any build
process in docker file it it cannot be
there in the interactive session it
should be there in the non-interactive
and definitely a typical uh scenarios
like you can run app update command and
then we are installing the php engine x
super supervisor all these things we are
doing we are doing the installation uh
we are using the run at tribute run a
particular step and in there whatever
the commands are executed these
statements will be executed when we will
be doing the build process and then we
are using some environment variables
okay so nginx virtual host php
underscore conf engineering centers for
conf and supervisor and disco conf these
are the different environment variables
which we configuring over here now next
thing which we have is that uh
we have to transfer some files like
probably nginx and the virtual host file
we may have to transfer from our linux
server to the destination to the
docker container so for that we are
going to run some copy commands copy
statements so that we can do that stuff
and uh then definitely we are
transferring the supervisor
configuration file also to the server so
that we can have that configurations uh
setup over there and uh these are config
uh supervisor underscore config and all
these different variables we have
already established where we are seeing
that what exactly configuration we are
looking forward over here and then uh we
are um you know creating some folder
structure we vw html folder structure we
are creating so that we will be able to
push some content over there and then we
have the volume configurations so
whatever the volume configurations are
there we are putting up so that
you know we will be able to have all the
uh specific direct directories mounted
on the host machine on the whole server
so that we can even talk about locally
also and then the star.search is
something which we need to run because
that's uh that will go into the command
statement which needs to be executed
because when you want to run your
process when you want to run your nginx
process or your docker container some
process should be up and running that's
where
if any interactive process will run then
only the docker container will be hold
up so that's what you can
do or you can configure over there so
i'm going to copy this whole content now
this whole content represents the
complete docker file so uh we have
already gone through this content one by
one but uh if we combine all these
content together till the exposed part
that's where we come up into these one
so expose we are doing atn 443 over here
right after this one we have to create
the host file virtual host file
supervisor d file and the star.search
file so let's go back to the server here
now
in this one you have to uh you can use
whatever editor you feel you want to use
you can do that uh so this is what i
will my
master file will look like you can see
i'm running some run commands uh these
are the environment variables i'm using
then further on these variables i'm
using just to define the paths okay so
you can see that this default file we
are copying from the uh host machine
from the server to the docker container
and then second file is super uh wiser d
not con file and then we have star dot
sh file so these are the different files
which we want to configure here so once
this file is prepared we have to uh type
in or we have to create a default file
over here in this current directory
so in this current directory we have to
put up a file called default now in this
one we will be having the default
virtual host configuration config so we
need to put our server attribute
saying that we have to look forward for
index.html or index.php and these kind
of files from the www.html directory
there so i'm just going to copy this
content
and
put it up into this one
so this is how my final file look like
so i'll save it
and then we have a supervisord dot com
file so
so i'll just copy the content of this
one
i'll copy it and we have to create a
file called
supervisor d dot con file
now names we can double check because we
are referring these names into a docker
file so
we can double check that
so once this is done
save it
and we can check the docker file we can
grab
so you can see okay this one so super
wiser d so the name is correct that
scroll so we got default we got
supervisor d now we have to create the
star dot sh file because in this one we
will be configuring that how we want to
start our process of this nginx or this
web server so in this one again we have
to run the supervised process over here
and a configuration file so we are going
to put this one
and we'll go here and put this content
right so we got the supervised config
also available so that's also there and
the moment it is done so you are going
to give the execute permission to this
one because um you can see that into our
docker file that we are having the
attribute where we want to run this into
the dots
slash there so if you want to refer in
that mode you have to change the
permissions in case so that
change mode you have to give the execute
permission to the start dot sh here now
once this is done
so what you got is that you got a
particular uh components like you got uh
some couple of commands you have uh you
know uh got dockerfile super isd.com
default all these files are there now
the only thing which we need to do next
is that we need to build to the build
process
so uh if we look forward for the build
process so what happens that docker
build is the command which we need to
use and uh nginx iphone image is the
name which you want to refer now you can
totally use this custom name you
whatever name you feel that you want to
use you can always use that there is no
restriction on that part and once that
is on so you will be able to list down
those images that you got a new custom
docker image here so you can see that
you got the ubuntu as on base image
which is built down and the nginx hyphen
image is also prepared over there
and once that is done so you are going
to create a web root folder and uh you
can run the docker run command to see
that if you really got connected with
that particular one so let's go back and
uh see that how we can create uh the
docker custom docker image here so the
moment i do this
so it will pick up the docker file over
here and start performing the activities
uh the package installations all those
configurations ones will be performed
over here in a non-interactive mode
there is no confirmation which will be
asked from the user because you cannot
put that confirmations so the command
should be in such a way that it should
not take any kind of confirmations at
all from the
end user so because tomorrow you may be
putting up these things in the jenkins
so that will not be a feasible thing for
you to put up the commands and put up
the
confirmations during the execution so so
it's trying to run do the package
installation for the php so fbm packages
are getting installed and um
here we go so we caught the
successful message now you can see it
says successfully tag this one this
means that there is no issues at all
with the docker image and when you run
the docker
images or docker images ls you can run
these two couple of commands so when you
do that you got a 203
mb of the size of this image that
represents that this docker image is
fully ready to run to execute so now
what we are going to do is that we are
going to map a volume over here with the
wwe html directory during the execution
of this container because i really want
to deploy some pages some web pages
there if you have the web pages now as
part of the build process as part of the
docker file you can do a git clone also
of some repository but i don't want to
do that during the preparation of docker
image i just now got an environment
where the nginx is set up properly and
it's up and running there now it should
be upon me that how i want to put up my
content and all so that's the reason why
i'm putting up a kind of a folder
structure over here and sharing it with
the docker container so that the moment
i put the
html files or the php files into that
local folder i should be able to get
some webpage up and running there so
that's what i'm going to do over here in
this one so i'm going to create a folder
structure saying slash
web root here okay so there is a folder
structure which is created now in this
web root i will be putting up some files
and then same files will be redirected
inside the docker container with the
help of docker volume so let's go back
to the document now here
you have to run uh the uh once like i
said that uh you are going to connect on
that part okay so uh you can use this
port as an at also but here 880 is used
so whatever port you feel you want to
use you can do that and uh we are giving
the container name as test and iphone
container that also you can change and
genex hyphen image is the one which we
are using so if you use some different
uh particular image you can also use
that and uh you can see that the web
root is something which we are
connecting with the www html directory
so the moment you put some file in the
web root the same file will be reflected
into the
ww html directory there
so uh i'm going to run this command and
once this is done so you can see that
for the testing purpose we are putting
up some content in the html one so i'll
come to that point also and we'll
validate as of now we should be having
our container up and running over here
in this one now i'm going to copy that
command
okay and hit on so if uh the at port is
used so you have to make sure that port
gets uh you know gets stopped
automatically or it should not be up and
running so just double check whatever
port you are using that should be free
now when you run the docker ps command
so uh you will be able to see a docker
container up and running but if you see
like docker psyphony that gives also the
stopped and running both the containers
are there but the main thing which we
want to run is that we want to run the
docker ps command and you can see that
this is a container which is running so
8080 is the container which is running
and test hyphen container is the name
now you got a container up and running
so you can actually do a call on
localhost colon 8080 so
this is a way to get the content
you can get the public ip also and in
the browser you can put up and you can
have the content there but right now we
are getting the response at least uh
it's showing his 403 error forbidden
error but that's fine we will be putting
up some web pages there in the rwb html
directory or we can say in local web
root directory so that we will be able
to have some content so what we can do
is that we can have some echo commands
executed so that we can have some added
some content added up into the uh
particular uh files there so let's see
that what different contents we can do
so uh you can use the vi mode also to do
a
you know couple of files so
i'm just using this echo command
so um
the moment i go for this execution so
what happens that a file will be created
into that uh slash web route there so um
i'm expecting that i have put up a
index.html page so if you feel that you
want to put some different page you can
always do and the moment you do the curl
now you will be able to see the same
response so whatever the things you put
up in the index.html file the same
content is going to pop up when you run
the curl command now um you want to use
some php files you want to put up some
php content all that stuff you can do it
now what i'm going to do is that rather
than just a html static content i'm
going to put some php content that
is going to help me to get a file so my
web root will have now two files so
if if you feel
uh that index.html file should have some
meaningful content you can always do
that you can pull some of the websites
also you can put that into the you can
do a git clone in the web root and the
whole application will be started and
now
if you feel that i got a info.php file
so i can use the nut name into the url i
have to modify the url because
index.html file is the what as in
default name page you do if you want to
put up some different name you can
change the server configuration of nginx
and according to that it will work
so um when i do this so you will start
getting the output so this is the php
content output which is there it's a
complete information now it may look
like a very bulky content to you but
when you put up this one into the
browser into the web browser that will
be a meaningful information probably in
terms of some tables or something like
that right so um let me scroll to the
top here so you can see that it's
showing an error sorry showing in the
output and this output represents that
you got a particular php content here so
this is how we will be able to have a
container and uh you know this container
is up and running you can modify to at
any level you feel that you want to
prepare a darker image with the code
embedded also uh you can have the git
clone or you can have this configuration
into some git repository have the source
code also there and then prepare a
complete bundle altogether so this is
what we have in this demo how we can
deploy a container and a container up
and running in case of the docker here
today we're going to cover what is a
docker container why you would want to
consider using it in your devops
environment so let's have a look at what
we have in our current environment so
today when you actually have your
standard machine you have the
infrastructure you have the host
operating system and you have your
applications and then when you create a
virtual environment what you're actually
doing is you're actually creating
virtual machines but those virtual
machines actually are now sitting within
a hypervisor solution that sits still on
top of your host operating system and
infrastructure and with a docker engine
what we're able to do is we're able to
actually reduce significantly
the different elements that you would
normally have within a virtualized
environment so we're able to get rid of
the the bins and the so we're able to
get rid of the guest os and we're able
to eliminate the hypervisor environment
and this is really important as we
actually start working and creating
environments that are consistent because
we want to be able to make it so it's
really easy and stable for the
environment that you have within your
dev and ops environment now critical is
getting rid of that hypervisor element
it's just a lot of overhead so let's
have a look at a container as an example
so here we actually have a couple of
examples on the right hand side we have
different containers we have one
containers running apache tomcat and
with java a second container is running
sql server and microsoft.net environment
the third container is running python
with mysql these are all running just
fine within the docker engine and
sitting on top of a host os which could
be linux it really could be any host os
within a consistent infrastructure and
you're able to have a solution that can
be shared easily amongst your teams so
let's have a look at an example that
you'd have today if a company is doing a
traditional java application so you have
your developers working in jboss on his
system and he's coding away and he has
to get that code over to a tester now
what will happen is that tester will
then typically in your traditional
environment then have to install jboss
on their machine and get everything
running and cool and hopefully set up
identically to the developer chances are
they probably won't have it exactly the
same but they're trying to get as close
as possible and then at some point you
want to be able to test this within your
production environment so you send it
over to a system administrator who would
then also have to install jboss on their
environment as well yeah this just seems
to be a whole lot of duplication so why
go through the problem of installing
jboss three times
and this is where it things get really
interesting because the challenge you
have today is that it's very difficult
to almost impossible to have identical
environments if you're just installing
software locally on devices the
developers probably got a whole bunch of
development software that could be
conflicting with the jboss environment
the tester has similar testing software
but probably doesn't have all the
development software and certainly the
system administrator won't have all the
tools that the developer and tester have
their own tools and so what you want to
be able to do is kind of get away from
the challenge you have of having to do
local installations on three different
computers and in addition what you see
is that this uses up a lot of effort
because when you're having to install
software over and over again you just
keep repeating doing really basic
foundational challenges so this is where
docker comes in and docker is the tool
that allows you to be able to share
environments from one group to another
group without having to install software
locally on a device you install all of
the code into your docker container and
simply share the container so in this
presentation we're going to go through a
few things we're going to cover what
docker actually is and then we're going
to dig into the actual architecture of
docker and kind of go through what
docker container is and how to create a
docker container and then we'll go out
through the benefits of using docker
containers and then the commands and
finalize everything out with a brief
demo so what is docker so docker is as
you'd expect because all the software
that we cover in this series is an open
source solution and it is a container
solution that allows you to be able to
containerize all of the necessary files
and applications needed to run the
solution that you're building so you can
share it from different people in your
team whether it's a developer tester or
system administrator and this allows you
to have a consistent environment from
one group to the next so let's kind of
dig into that architecture so you
understand why docker runs effectively
so the docker architecture itself is
built up of two key elements there is
the docker client and then there is a
rest api connection to a docker daemon
which actually hosts the entire
environment within the docker host and
the docker demon you have your different
containers and each one has a link to a
docker registry the docker client itself
is a rest service so as you'd expect a
rest api and that sends command line to
the docker daemon through a terminal
window or command line interface window
and we'll go through some of these demos
later on so you can actually see how you
can actually interact with darker the
docker demo then checks the request
against and the docker components and
then performs the service that you're
requesting now the docker image itself
all it really is a collection of
instructions used to create a container
and again this is consistent with all
the devops tools that we have the devops
tools that we're looking to use
throughout this series of videos are all
environments that can be scripted and
this is really important because it
allows you to be able to duplicate and
scale the environments that you want to
be able to build very quickly and
effectively the actual container itself
has all of the applications and the
dependencies of those applications in
one package you can kind of think of it
as a really effective and efficient zip
file it's a little bit more than that
but it's one file that actually has
everything you need to be able to run
all of your solutions the actual docker
registry itself is an environment for
being able to host and distribute
different docker images among your team
so say for instance you had a team of
developers that were working on multiple
different solutions so say you have a
team of developers and you have 50
developers and they're working on five
different applications you can actually
have the applications themselves the
containers shared in the docker registry
so each of those teams at any time check
out and have the latest container of
that latest image of the code that
you're working on so let's dig into what
actually is in the container so the
important part of a docking container is
that it has everything you need to be
able to run the application it's like a
virtualized environment it has all your
frameworks and your libraries and it
allows the teams to be able to build out
and run exactly the right environment
that the developer intended what's
interesting though is the actual
applications then will run in isolation
so they're not impacting other
applications that using dependencies on
other libraries or files outside of the
container because of the architecture it
really uses a lot less space and because
it's using less space it's a much more
lightweight architecture so the files
the actual folder itself is much smaller
it's very secure highly portable and the
boot up time is incredibly fast so let's
actually get into how you would actually
create a docker container so the docker
container itself is actually built
through command line and uh it's built
of a file and docker image so the actual
docker file is a text file that contains
all the instructions that you would need
to be able to create that docker image
and then we'll actually then create all
of the project code with inside of that
image then the image becomes the item
that you would share through the docker
registry you would then use the command
line and we'll do this later on select
docker run and then the name of the
image to be able to easily and
effectively run that image locally and
again once you've created the docker
image you can store that in the docker
registry making it available to anybody
within your network so something to bear
in mind is that docker itself has its
own registry called docker hub and that
is a public registry so you can actually
go out and see other docker images that
have been created and access those
images as your own company you may want
to have your own private repository so
you want to be able to go ahead and
either do that locally through your own
repository or you can actually get a
licensed version of docker hub where you
can actually then share those files
now something that's also very
interesting to know is that you can have
multiple versions of a docker image so
if you have a different version control
different release versions and you want
to be able to test and write code for
those different release versions because
you may have different setups you can
certainly do that within your docker
registry environment okay so let's go
ahead and we're going to create a docker
image using some of our basic docker
commands and so there are essentially
really you know kind of just two
commands that you're going to be looking
for one is the build command another one
is to actually put it into your registry
which is a push command so if you want
to get a image from a docker registry
then you want to use the pull command
and a pull command simply pulls the
image from the registry and in this
example using nginx as our registry and
we can actually then pull the image down
to our test environment on our local
machine so we're actually running the
container within our docker application
on our local machine we're able to then
have the image run exactly as it would
in production and then you can actually
use the run command to actually use the
docker image on your local machine so
just a you know a few uh interesting
tidbits about the docking container once
the container is created a new layer is
formed on top of the docker image layers
called the container layer each
container has a separate read write
container layer and any changes made in
that docking container is then reflected
upon the particular container layer and
if you want to delete the container
layer the container layer also gets
deleted as well so you know why would
using docker and containers be of
benefit to you well you know some of the
things that are useful is that
containers have no external dependencies
for the applications they run once you
actually have the container running
locally it has everything it needs to be
able to run the application so there's
no having to install additional pieces
of software such as the example we gave
with jpos at the beginning of the
presentation now the containers are
really lightweight so it makes it very
easy to
share the containers amongst your teams
whether it's a developer whether it's a
tester whether it's somebody on your
operations environment it's really easy
to share those containers amongst your
entire team different data volumes can
be easily reused and shared among
multiple containers and again this is
another big benefit and this is a
reflection of the lightweight nature of
your containers the container itself
also runs in isolation
which means that it is not impacted by
any dependencies you may have on your
own local environment so it's a
completely sandboxed environment so some
of the questions you might ask us you
know can you run multiple containers
together without the need to start each
one individually and you know what yes
you can with docker compose docking
compose allows you to run multiple
containers in a single service and again
this is a reflection on the lightweight
nature of containers within the docker
environment so we end our presentation
by looking at some of the basic commands
that you'd have within docker so we have
here on the left hand side we have a
docker container and then the command
for each item we're actually going to go
ahead and use some of these commands in
the demo that we're going to do after
this presentation you'll see that in a
moment but just you know some of the
basic commands we have are committing
the docket image into the container kill
is a you know standard kill command to
you know terminate one or more of the
running containers so they stopped
working then restart those containers
but suddenly you can look at all the
image all of the commands here and try
them out for yourself so we're going to
go ahead and start a demo of how to use
the basic commands to run docker so to
do this we're going to open up terminal
window or command line deploying whether
you're running linux pc or mac and we're
going to go ahead and the first thing we
want to do is see what our docker image
lists are so we can go sudo docker
images and this will give us well first
we'll enter in our password so let's go
enter that in and this will now give us
a list of our docker images and here are
the docker images that have already been
created in the system and we can
actually go ahead and actually see the
processes that are actually running so
i'm going to go ahead and open up this
window a little bit more but this will
show you the actual processes and the
containers that we actually have and so
on the far left hand side you see under
names we have learn simply learn be
underscore cool these are all just
different ones that we've been working
on so let's go ahead and create a docker
image so we do sudo
docker
run
0.0.0.0
go on 80 colon 80
ubuntu and this will allow us to go
ahead and run an ubuntu
image and this will run the latest image
and what we have here is a hash number
and this hash number is a unique name
that defines the
container that we've just created now we
can go ahead and we can check to make
sure that the container actually is
present so we're going to do
sudo docker.ps and this actually shows
sound there so it's not in a running
state right now but that doesn't mean
that we don't have it so let's list out
all the containers that are both running
and in the exit state so let's do sucker
ps dash a and
this lists all the containers that i
have running on my machine
and this shows all the ones that have
been in the running state and in the
exit stage and here we see one that we
just created about a minute ago and it's
called learn
and these are all running ubuntu and
this is the one that we had created just
a few seconds ago
let's open it up and
there we go
so let's change that to that new dock
container to a running state so scroll
down
and we're gonna type sudo
docker
run
dash
i t dash dash
name
my
um
so this is going to be the new container
name it's going to be my docker so this
is how we name our docker environment
and we'll put in the image name which is
ubuntu
and bin dash bash
and it's now in our route and we'll exit
out of that
now we're going to go ahead and start
the new my docker container so sudo
docker
start
my
and we'll get the container image which
will be my docker
my docker
return and that started that docker
image
and let's go ahead and check against the
other running docker images to make sure
it's running correctly so sudo docker
ps
and there we are underneath name on the
right hand side you have to see my
docker along with the other docker
images that we created
that's been running for 13 seconds
quite fast so we want to rename the
container let's use the command sudo
docker
rename we can take another docker image
this is grab this one and we'll put it
in rename
and we'll rename
i'm putting the old container name which
is image and then we'll put in the new
container name and let's call it
purple
so now the container image that had
proved something called image is now
called purple
so we do sudo docker
ps
to list all of our docker images
and we scroll up and there there we go
purple
how easy is that to rename an image
and we can go ahead and use this command
if we want to stop containers so we're
going to write sudo docker
stop
and then we have to put in the container
name and we'll put in my docker the
container that we originally created
and that image has now stopped
and let's go ahead and prove that we're
going to list out all the docker images
and what you see is that it's not listed
in the active images it's uh not on the
list on the far right hand side
but if we go ahead and we can list out
all of the docker images so you actually
see it's still
there as an image is just
not in an active stage it's what's known
as in an exit state
so here we go
and there's my docker it's in an exit
state so that happened 27 seconds ago
so if we want to to remove a container
we can use the following command
so sudo docker
rm
will remove
my docker
and that will remove it from the exit
state
and we're going to go ahead and we're
going to double check that
and yep
yep
it's not not listed there under exit
state anymore
it's gone
and there we go
there that's where it used to be
all right
let's go back
so if we want to exit a container in the
running state so we do sudo kill and
then the name of the container
i think one of them is called yellow
let's just check and see if that's gonna
kill it
oops no i guess we don't have one called
yellow so let's find out name of
container that we actually have
so pseudo
docker
kill
oh we're going to list out the ones that
are running oh okay there we go now
yellow isn't in that list so let's take
i know let's take simply learn and so we
can actually go ahead and let's write
sudo docker
kill
simply learn
and that will actually kill an active
docker container
boom there we go
and we list out all the active
containers you can actually see now
that's the simply learn container is not
active anymore
and these are all the basic commands for
docker container hey everyone welcome to
this simply learn video on kubernetes
full course in this full course we will
learn everything about communities in
detail we will begin this full course
video with understanding what exactly is
kubernetes is next we will see how to
install kubernetes and the differences
between kubernetes and docker then we
will look into the services and
components of communities in detail
after that we will be discussing
everything about the architecture of
kubernetes then we will see how
communities can be implemented on aws
finally we will conclude this video by
discussing the important communities
interview questions and answers for
beginners and experienced candidates by
the end of this video i can assure you
that all your communities career related
queries will have been answered
so let's start with an exciting video on
the configuration management tool before
we begin make sure to subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit that bell icon
to never miss an update from simplylearn
hello and welcome to simplyline in this
session we're going to cover what
kubernetes is and why you would want to
be using it within your devops team but
before we get started remember to hit
the like button if you like this video
and the subscribe button if you want to
get notified about more of these videos
as they come out and as always if you
have any comments about content that
we're covering or questions that you
have on the subject please post them in
the comments below so let's get started
we're going to break up this
presentation into four key areas we're
going to talk about life before
kubernetes which some of you are
probably experiencing right now what is
kubernetes the benefits that kubernetes
brings to you particularly if you are
using containers in a devops environment
and then finally we're going to break
down the architecture and working
infrastructure for kubernetes so you
understand what's happening and why the
actions are happening the way that they
are so let's jump into our first section
of life before kubernetes so the way
that you have done work in the past
where you may be doing work right now is
really building out and deploying
solutions into two distinct areas one is
a traditional deployment where you're
pushing out code to physical servers in
a data center and you're managing the
operating system and the code that's
actually running on each of those
servers another environment that you may
potentially be using is to buying code
out to virtual machines so let's go
through and look at the two different
types of deployment that you may be
experiencing when you have applications
running on multiple machines you run
into the potential risk that the setup
and configuration of each of those
machines isn't going to be consistent
and your code isn't going to work
effectively and there may be issues with
uptime and errors within the
infrastructure of your entire
environment there's going to be problems
with resource allocation and you're
going to have air issues where
applications may be running effectively
and not look not effectively and not
load balance
effectively across the environment the
problem that you have with this kind of
infrastructure is that it gets very
expensive you can only install one piece
of software one service on one piece of
hardware so your hardware is being
massively under utilized this is where
virtual machines have become really
popular with a virtual machine you're
able to have better resource utilization
and scalability at much less cost and
this allows you to be able to run
multiple virtual machines on a single
piece of hardware the problem is is that
vms or for virtual machines are not
perfect either some of the challenges
you run with vms is that the actual
hardware and software need needed to
manage the vm environment can be
expansive there are security risks with
virtual with vms there are security
risks with vms there have been data
breaches recorded about solutions that
run in virtualized environments you also
run into an issue of availability and
this is largely because you can only
have a finite number of virtual machines
running on a piece of hardware and this
results in limitations and restrictions
in the types of environment you want to
be running and then finally setting up
and managing a virtualized environment
is time consuming it can take a lot of
time and it can also get very expensive
so how about kubernetes well kubernetes
is a tool that allows you to manage
containerized deployment of solutions
and inherently kubernetes is a tool that
is really a next level maturity of
deployment so if you can think of your
maturity curve as deploying code in
directly to hardware in a data center
and then deploying your solutions to
virtual machines the next evolution of
that deployment is to use containers and
kubernetes so let's kind of go through
and look at the differences between a
virtual machine and kubernetes we've got
a few here that we want to highlight and
you'll get an understanding of what the
differences are between the two so first
of all with virtual machines there is
inherently security risks and what
you'll find as we get dig through the
architecture later in the presentation
is that kubernetes is inherently secure
um and this is largely because of the
legacy code the legacy of kubernetes and
where it came from we'll talk about that
in just a moment but kubernetes is
inherently secure
virtual machines are not easily portable
now with that said they they are
technically portable they're just not
very easily portable whereas with
kubernetes it's working with docker
container solutions it is
extremely portable that means that you
can actually spin up and spin down and
manage your infrastructure exactly the
way that you want it to be managed and
scale it on the demands of the customers
as they're coming in to use the solution
from a time consuming point of view
kubernetes is much less time consuming
than with a virtual machine a few other
areas that we want to kind of highlight
from differences virtual machines use
much less isolation when building out
the
encapsulated environment than kubernetes
does for instance with a virtual machine
you have to run hypervisor on top of the
os and hardware and then inside of the
virtual machine you also have to have
the operating system as well whereas in
contrast on a kubernetes environment
because it's leveraging a darker
container and or container-like
technologies it only has to have the os
and the hardware and then inside of each
container it doesn't need to have that
additional os layer it's able to inherit
what it needs to be able to run the
application this makes the whole
solution much more flexible and allows
you to run many more containers on a
piece of hardware than versus running
virtual machines on a single piece of
hardware so as we highlighted here our
vms are not as portable as kubernetes
and kubernetes is portable directly
related to the use of containerization
and because kubernetes is built on top
of containers it is much less time
consuming because you can actually
script and automatically allocate
resource to nodes within your kubernetes
environment because it allows the
infrastructure to run much more
effectively and much more efficiently so
this is why if we look at our evolution
of the land of time before kubernetes
why we are running into a solution where
kubernetes had to come about because the
demand for having more highly scalable
solutions that are more efficient was
just really a natural evolution of this
software deployment model that started
with pushing out code to physical
hardware and then pushing code out to
virtual machines and then needing to
have a solution much more sophisticated
kubernetes would have come about at some
point in time i'm just really glad it
came back when it did so
what is kubernetes let's let's dig into
the history of kubernetes and how it
came about so in essence uh kubernetes
is an open source platform that is
allows you to manage and deploy and
maintain groups of containers and the
container is something like docker and
if you're developing code you're
probably already using docker today
consider kubernetes as the tool that
manages multiple docker environments
together now
we talk a lot about docker and as a
container solution with kubernetes the
reality is is that kubernetes can
actually use other container tools out
there but docker just simply is the most
popular container out there both these
tools are open source that's why they're
so popular and they just allow you to be
able to have flexibility in being able
to scale up your solutions and they were
designed for the post-digital world that
we live and exist in today so a little
bit of background a little bit of trivia
around kubernetes so kubernetes was
originally a successor to a project at
google and the original project was
google board google borg it does exactly
what kubernetes done does today but
kubernetes was rewritten from the ground
up and then released as an open source
project in 2014 so that people outside
of google could take advantage of the
power of kubernetes containerization
management tools and today it is managed
by the cloud native computing foundation
and there are many many companies that
support and manage kubernetes so for
instance if you're signing up for
microsoft azure aws google cloud all of
them will leverage kubernetes and it's
just become the the de facto tool for
managing large groups of containers so
let's kind of step through some of the
key benefits that you'd experience from
kubernetes and so we have nine key
benefits and the first it is highly
portable it is 100 open source code and
this means that you can actually go
ahead and contribute to this code
project if you want to through github uh
the ability to scale up the solution is
incredible um what's the the history of
kubernetes being part of a google
project for managing the google network
and infrastructure
kind of really sets the groundwork for
having a solution that is highly
scalable the
out of the high scalability also comes
the need for high availability and this
is the desire to be able to have a
highly efficient and highly energized
environment that also you can really
rely on so if you're building out a
kubernetes management
environment you know that it's going to
be available for the solutions that
you're maintaining and it's really
designed for deployment so you can
script out the environment and actually
have it as part of your devops model so
you can scale up and meet the demands of
your customer then what you'll find is
that the
load balancing is extremely efficient
and it allows you to distribute the load
efficiently across your entire network
so your network remains stable and then
also the tool
allows you to manage the orchestration
of your storage so you can have local
storage such as an ssd on the hardware
that the kubernetes is
maintaining or if the kubernetes
environment is pulling storage from a
public cloud such as azure or aws you
can actually go ahead and make that
available to your entire system and you
can inherit the security that goes back
and forth between the cloud environments
and one of the things you'll find
consistent with kubernetes is that it is
designed for a cloud-first environment
um kubernetes as well is that it's it's
really a self-healing environment so if
something happens or something fails uh
kubernetes will detect that failure and
then either restart the process kill the
process or replace it and then because
of that you also have automated rollouts
and drawbacks in case you need to be
able to manage the state of the
environment and then finally
you have automatic bin packaging so you
can actually specify the compute power
that's being used from cpu and ram for
each container so let's dig into the
final area which is the actual
kubernetes architecture i'm going to
cover this at a high level there's
actually another video that you can
that simply learn has developed which
digs deeper into the kubernetes
architecture and so the kubernetes
architecture is a clustered-based
architecture and it's really about two
key areas you have the kubernetes master
which actually controls um and all of
the activities within your entire
kubernetes infrastructure and then you
have nodes that actually are running on
linux machines um outs that are
controlled by the master so let's kind
of go through some of these um areas so
if we look at the kubernetes master to
begin with um
we'll start with uh etc is this is a
tool that allows for the configuration
of information and the management of
nodes within your cluster and one of the
key features that you'll find with all
of the tools that are managed within
either a the master environment or
within a node is that they are all
accessible via the api server um and
what's interesting about the api server
is that it's a restful based
infrastructure which means that you can
actually secure
each connection with ssl and other
security models to ensure that your
entire infrastructure and the
communication going back and forth
across your infrastructure is tightly
secured scheduler goes ahead and
actually as you'd expect it actually um
manages the schedule of activities
within the actual cluster and then you
have the control and the controller is a
daemon server that actually manages and
pushes out the instructions to all of
your nodes so uh the other tools really
are the the infrastructure and you can
consider them the administration site um
of the master whereas controller is the
management actually pushes out all of
the controls via the api server so let's
actually dig into
one of the actual nodes themselves and
there are three key areas of the nodes
one is the dark environment which
actually helps and manage and maintain
the container that's actually inside
of the node and then you have the
kubelet which is responsible for
information that goes back and forth and
it's going to do most of the
conversation with the api server on the
actual health of that node and then you
have the actual kubernetes proxy which
actually runs the services actually
inside of the node so as you see all of
these infrastructures are extremely
lightweight and designed to be very
efficient and very available for your
infrastructure and so here's a quick
recap of the different tools that are
available and it really breaks down into
two key areas you have your kubernetes
master and the kubernetes node now the
kubernetes master has the instructions
of what's going to happen within your
kubernetes infrastructure and then it's
going to push out those in structure to
indefinite number of nodes that will
allow you to be able to scale up and
scale down your solution in a dynamic
way hi guys in today's video i am going
to show you how to install ubuntu on
kubernetes kubernetes is an open source
platform used for deployment and
management of containers so let's get
started now the first step is to install
the necessary dependencies using two of
the commands first is sudo apt get
update which gets all the updates
and then you have to enter a password
so this will take a few seconds
that's done the next step is to install
app transport https this is basically
used to make repositories via https so
let's go ahead with that sudo
okay that's done going ahead the next
thing we have to do is to install the
docker dependency using the command sudo
apt install docker dot io
you have to choose why
and this will take a few minutes
okay that's done so after installing the
docker we have to start and enable the
docker using the command sudo system ctl
start docker and sudo system cto enable
dock
so now the docker is enabled so now we
are done with the first step of
installation the next step is we have to
install the necessary components for
kubernetes before that we have to
install the curl command because current
command is used to send data using a url
syntax let's install the curl command
using the command sudo apt-get install
curl
[Music]
so you have to select y
and this will take few minutes
so moving on the next step we have to do
is download and add key for kubernetes
installation from a url so let's go
ahead with that sudo curl
so this is where we get the key and then
we have to add it using sudo apt key add
and it's done so the next step is we
have to add a repository in a certain
location so before doing that we have to
change the permission of that file so we
do that using c or sudo c h mode command
okay so the permission is changed now
let's go ahead and save this file in
that location first we have to enter
this command into the file
this is a url
save as
so we have to save it in this location
let's rename this to
kubernetes
dot
list now let's see
okay so here it is now moving forward
now we have to check for any updates
available
in the next command we are going to
install the kubernetes components that
is cubelet cubadium cubectyl and
kubernetes cni so let's go ahead with
that
so this is going to take a few minutes
now that's done so the next step we have
to initialize the master node and to do
this we have to first use a swap off
command to disable the swapping on other
devices so let's do that pseudo swap off
hyphenate
now let's go ahead with the
initialization sudo
cube adm init
this is going to take a few minutes
okay so before going to the next step to
start the cluster we have to use these
three commands let's just copy paste it
okay that's done
so
moving forward the next step is to
deploy paths using the following command
[Music]
now the pods have been deployed to our
network to see all the parts you have to
use the command sudo cubic till get pods
there you can see the parts that have
been deployed hello and in this video
we're going to cover a common
conversation which is kubernetes versus
darker but before we jump into that i
want you to hit the subscribe button so
you get notified about new content as it
gets made available and if you hit the
notification button that notification
will then pop up on your desktop as a
video is published from simplyland in
addition if you have any questions on
the topic please post them in the
comments below we read them and we do
reply to them as often as we can so with
that said let's jump into kubernetes
versus docker so let's go through a
couple of scenarios let's do one for
kubernetes and then one for docker and
we can actually go through and
understand what the problem specific
companies have actually had and how
they're able to use the two different
tools to solve them so our first one is
with bose and bose
had a
large catalog of products that kept
growing and their infrastructure had to
change so the way that they looked at
that was actually establishing two
primary goals uh to be able to allow
their product groups to be able to
easier more easily catch up to the scale
of their business so after going through
a number of solutions they ended up
coming up with a solution of having
kubernetes running their iot platform as
a service inside of amazon's aws cloud
service and what you'll see with both
these products is they're very cloud
friendly but here we have
bose and kubernetes working together
with aws to be able to scale up and meet
the demands of their product catalog and
so the result is that we're able to
increase the number of non-production
deployments significantly by taking the
number of services from being large
bulky surfaces down to small micro
services being able to handle as many as
plus deployments every year an
incredible amount of time and value has
been opened through the use of
kubernetes now let's have a look at daca
and see what a similar problem that
people would have so uh the problem is
with paypal and paypal and process is
something in the region of over 200
payments per second across all of their
products and paypal doesn't just have
paypal they have braintree and venmo so
the challenge that uh paypal was uh
really being given is that they had
different architectures which resulted
in different maintenance cycles and
different deployment times and an
overall complexity from having a
decades-old architecture with paypal
through to a modern architecture with
venmo through the use of docker paper
was able to unify the application
delivery and be able to centralize the
management of all of the containers with
one existing group the net net result is
that paypal was able to migrate over 700
applications into docker enterprise
which consists of over 200 000
containers this ultimately opened up a
50 percent increase in availability for
being able to and add in additional time
for building testing and deploying of
applications just a huge win for paypal
now let's dig into kubernetes and docker
and so kubernetes is an open source uh
platform and it's designed for being
able to maintain a large number of
containers and what you're going to find
is that your argument for kubernetes
versus docker isn't a real argument it's
kubernetes and docker working together
so kubernetes is able to manage the
infrastructure of a containerized
environment and docker is the number one
container management solution and so
with docker you're able to automate the
deployment of your applications being
able to keep them in a very lightweight
environment and being able to
create a nice consistent experience so
that your developers are working in the
same containers that are then also
pushed out to production so with docker
you're able to manage multiple
containers running on the same hardware
much more efficiently than you are with
a
vm environment the productivity around
docker is extremely high you're able to
keep your applications very isolated the
configuration for docker is really quick
and easy you can be up and running in
minutes with docker once you have it
installed and running on your
development machine or inside of your
devops environment so we look at the
deployment between the two um and the
differences kubernetes is really
designed for a combination of pods and
services in its deployment whereas with
docker it's around about deploying
services in containers so the the
difference and here is that kubernetes
is going to manage the entire
environment and then and that
environment consisting of pods and
inside of a pod you're going to have all
of your containers that you're working
on and those containers that can control
the services that actually power the
applications that are being deployed
kubernetes is by default an auto scaling
solution has it turned on and is always
available whereas docker does not and
that's not surprising because docker is
a tool for building out solutions
whereas kubernetes is about managing
your infrastructure kubernetes is going
to
run health checks on the liveness and
readiness of your entire environment so
not just one container but tens of
thousands of containers whereas docker
is gonna limit the health check to the
services that it's managing within its
own containers now i'm not gonna kid you
kubernetes is quite hard to set up it's
it's if of the tools that you're going
to be using in your devops environment
it's it's not an easy setup for you to
use um and for
this reason you want to really take
advantage of the services within azure
and other similar cloud environments
where they actually will do the setup
for you docker in contrast is really
easy to set up you can as i mentioned
earlier you can be up and running in a
few minutes as you would expect the
fault tolerance within kubernetes is
very high and this is by design because
the architecture of kubernetes is built
on the same architecture that google
uses for managing its entire cloud
infrastructure in contrast docker has
lower fault tolerance but that's because
it's just managing the the services
within its own containers what you'll
find is that most public cloud providers
will provide support for both kubernetes
and docker here we've highlighted
microsoft azure because they were very
quick uh to jump on and support
kubernetes uh but the reality is is that
today google amazon and many other
providers are having first level support
for kubernetes has just become extremely
popular in a very very short time frame
the company's using both kubernetes and
docker is fast and every single day
there are more and more companies using
it and you should be able to look and
see whether or not you can add your own
company to this list hello and welcome
to simply learn today we're going to be
giving you a kubernetes tutorial we'll
provide the overview of how and why you
should be using kubernetes but before we
get started don't forget to hit the
subscribe button and the like button if
you want to get notified about
additional content from simply learn and
as always if you have any comments about
the material that you're about to see
and you have any questions please post
them in the comments below we do read
them and we do reply to them so with
that said let's jump in so we're going
to go through a bunch of things today
around kubernetes we're going to cover
what kubernetes is and why you should be
using it along with the features of
kubernetes we're also going to take a
little bit of a look at kubernetes
versus docker swarm as the two
technologies do tend to get referred to
quite frequently and then we're gonna do
a deep dive into the actual kubernetes
architecture itself and how kubernetes
runs and operates within your network
and then finally we're going to look at
some kubernetes use cases of how you can
actually apply best learnings that other
companies have used with kubernetes
we'll finish everything off with a demo
where we actually step through and use
some of the actual codes that you can
actually use to run
from your terminal window to actually
activate kubernetes itself so with that
said let's jump in so why kubernetes
well kubernetes is really being built
from allowing you to be able to have a
more reliable infrastructure the tool
itself is designed to manage the
containers you have within your network
it's very modular in architecture which
allows it to be very easy to be able to
maintain and to be able to scale and
meet the demands that your current
customers are offering you today the
actual ability for you to be able to
deploy and update software at scale is
really at the heart and center of
kubernetes it's really one of the
reasons why kubernetes was created was
to be able to scale up the deployment of
software into tens of thousands of
networks and servers uh within a data
center and then finally uh when you
start working with kubernetes really
what you're doing is laying the
foundation for building cloud native
applications and part of this comes from
the architecture and history of
kubernetes which we'll get to in a
little bit but it's good to know that as
you're using kubernetes and
containerized solutions that you're
really building out an infrastructure
that's designed for cloud-centric
solution delivery so let's dig into why
what kubernetes is so the history of
kubernetes is that it was originally
developed by google google actually used
the precursor to kubernetes to manage
and maintain the
data structure and data infrastructure
that they had within their network they
really liked it and one of the big
benefits that kubernete that google
provided is that they converted their
code into an open source program that
they released as kubernetes in 2014 and
made an open source this means that any
company can use kubernetes there's no
charge for it all you have to do is know
how to use the command lines to actually
get up and running the benefit of
kubernetes being open source is that
most cloud providers now support
kubernetes so whether you're using
microsoft azure you're using google
cloud or aws you'll find that you can
actually use kubernetes and kubernetes
and edit core really helped eliminate
manual processes so it allowed for
deploying and scaling your
container-based solutions much more
effortless within a cloud environment so
let's jump into the features of
kubernetes and why you'd want to be
using it and we have a number of
features that we want to kind of step
through again the first thing that
kubernetes is a strong benefit of is
that it eliminates those manual
processes and allows you to automate
them the benefit you have from this is
that you can then scale up your
automation across your entire network so
whether you are managing 10 nodes and
within your network or whether you're
managing 10 000 doesn't matter you have
the ability to scale that something you
simply didn't have before kubernetes
also will manage the actual containers
themselves um including the security and
the storage and the networking within
those containers the great uh benefit of
working with kubernetes is that uh not
only is it a cloud-centric solution but
it was really built from a core
need of a secure solution so security is
at the heart and center of all the work
you're doing which really helps benefit
any teams scaling out containers your
kubernetes environment will be
constantly monitored and so that when
you have nodes that have your containers
the health of those nodes is being
constantly communicated back to
the
kubernetes environment so that the
entire environment is always being
managed and checked so if you have any
um additional hosting and launching that
needs to be done kubernetes will help
you automate those manual processes uh
if something does go wrong you can
actually set up your kubernetes
environment to do an automatic roll back
again this is just allowing you to have
that confidence that when you're
deploying a solution that everything is
going to work within that environment
and then finally kubernetes will allow
you to mount and add the storage needed
to run your apps so whether you have
storage such as a local ssd storage
device physically on the hardware or if
you're connecting to storage via the
cloud kubernetes will allow you to
access the storage you need how you're
accessing it so let's look a little bit
into the differences between kubernetes
and docker swarm so if we just step back
a little bit kubernetes and docker often
get connected with each other largely
because kubernetes manages containers
and docker is really famous for creating
the most popular
container management solution which is
called docker if you're a developer
you're probably already using docker
today so one of the things that
kubernetes is really really good at is
that it manages containers at scale just
massive volume of containers docker
swarm is docker's alternative to
kubernetes it's a tool that allows you
to also manage large number large
numbers of containers and there are
differences between the two of them and
right now without doubt the most popular
open source solution out there is
kubernetes from google it just has a
massive community behind it and uh the
community uh really have embraced um
kubernetes um yes the original product
was by developed by google but google
has been great stuart and they've
allowed the community to drive the
future evolution of the product uh
docker swarm is actually managed and
developed by docker um there is a
smaller community but it is also a very
passionate community and the reason
being is that both products are actually
pretty good and you just really kind of
have to choose which one you want to go
with without doubt there is more
customization and extensions built for
kubernetes simply because community is
just so much bigger than the docker
swarm community but with that said
docker swarm is really easy to set up so
if you are used to working within the
docker environment you will be able to
set up docker swarm very very quickly
whereas kubernetes does require some
heavy lifting to get up and running now
with that said if you are using
microsoft azure or google cloud very
often those environments will actually
set up kubernetes for you so you don't
have to do it and you can actually then
focus on writing the instructions to
maintain your kubernetes environment
kubernetes um has extremely
high fault tolerance again
it's because kubernetes is has been road
tested the foundation for kubernetes is
based on managing sites such as gmail
google.com
youtube i mean just incredibly robust
environment compared to docker swamp
which has lower fault tolerance
and this really kind of leads into
the final areas where kubernetes does
guarantee um strong clusters and
management just a really reliable
environment dr swarm however is able to
take containers and deploy them into
large casters very very quickly two
interesting differences is that with
kubernetes the load balancing is still
manual and be interesting to watch how
kubernetes matures that skill set uh in
contrast load balancing is automatic
within docker swarm so let's dig into
the kubernetes architecture and just
kind of expose some of those key
elements um if you're interested in
actually having a very deep dive into
kubernetes architecture we have already
got another video and we should have a
link in the comments that you can select
that will take you to that video as well
but this will provide you an overview as
well um so the way that kubernetes runs
is that it uses nodes to actually manage
all the individual hardware within a
specific unit and so a node is really a
physical machine uh in a data center or
a virtual machine and when you're
setting up an environment on a cloud
environment such as microsoft azure or
google cloud or aws kubernetes will be
managing the containers within that node
so it's important to know that
kubernetes itself doesn't work with the
individual nodes but actually works with
the cluster as a whole and and why
that's important is that it's a tool to
manage your entire environment it's not
going to come down and manage the
individual node itself it's going to
match the entire environment the actual
control of data within a cluster and
it's very very flexible within
kubernetes you can have local storage
such as an ssd
card or a traditional local storage or
you can actually connect to the cloud
and use cloud-based storage and the
benefit that cloud-based storage offers
you is that you are increasingly moving
your solution into more of a
hardware free environment cloud-based
architecture where you're not reliant on
a physical piece of hardware within your
data center and why that's important is
that it gives you the opportunity to
scale up your solutions much more
effectively so if you need to increase
the hard drive space you can do that
very easily from the cloud whereas local
hardware is a little bit harder to
manage great news kubernetes gives you
both options to be able to
choose from and so the the next layer
down is the actual management of the
application that's within a container
and as mentioned earlier docker is the
most popular container solution out
there and again if you're a developer
you're probably already using docker as
it was a natural maturity from using a
virtual machine but kubernetes itself
will actually manage the containers that
you have within your nodes and so you
have a collection of containers working
together and then you pull those
together into what's called a pod and
what's great is kubernetes will actually
manage the health of that part so if a
container or a pod fails kubernetes will
automatically deploy out a replica so
your entire environment can stay running
and being efficient and so the pots
themselves will actually be managed by
kubernetes and you really want to
let kubernetes um do this because it's
allowing you to
step away from the manual management of
pods your environment is just going to
be healthier relying on kubernetes to do
the actual management of all the pods
you have out there so you are able to
allow access to from services outside of
your kubernetes and this is done through
a process called ingress and
going back earlier we talked about how
security is a key part of all the work
that goes into kubernetes and this is a
great example of where you can use an
external service but still have that
layer of security that is vital for your
solution because to be able to provide
the ingress connection kubernetes
requires an ssl connection which um
automatically allows for a secure data
transfer absolutely fantastic so here we
have an overview of the actual
architecture on the right hand side we
have our nodes and the pods within our
nodes and within those pods are the
containers on the left hand side we have
the master architecture and the master
architecture is the actual brains behind
the work that you're doing it's actually
managing the schedules the controllers
uh for all of the nodes and then at the
bottom left-hand side we have commands
which are written on a local workstation
and those commands are pushed up to the
master so let's kind of dig a little bit
further into the architecture of the
master um so the master itself is uh
comprised of a number of key components
um again this is the tool that's going
to
manage your
entire kubernetes infrastructure the key
components that you have are the
etcd control manager scheduler api
server and the key four components are
etcd
or the cluster store the controller
manager the scheduler and the api server
the cluster store is the tool where all
the details of the work that you're
doing is stored and it's going to manage
the rules going to manage all the
instructions and this is where you're
going to post that information the
controller is actually going to then
perform the tasks that are stored in the
cluster store and as you'd expect the
schedule is the tool that actually
controls when instructions and tasks are
pushed out to
all the pods and nodes within your
network and then finally you have an api
server which allows you to be able to
control all the operations the actual
operations themselves are all
instructions written um as rest
instructions and which allows you to
take advantage of the security that has
been built into rest and so you end up
with a worker slave architecture and
slaves are all the different nodes and
pods within your network and so a part
itself will have multiple one or more
multiple containers and then each
container and then each pod will have a
docker container a kubelet and a
kubernetes proxy and the these are tools
to allow you to communicate back up to
the master layer so the docker is the
actual container itself and this is
going to actually run your application
and
the instructions here are to pull down
the correct container from the docker
images that you have within your library
the cubelet is going to manage your
containers and your container
instructions that will be deployed to
the cubelet are going to be written in
either yaml or json format yaml is just
great if you haven't had a chance to
start working with yaml i certainly
encourage you to do so it's very easy to
pick up if you know any xml uh you'll
pick up yaml very quickly and finally
the kubernetes proxy is the tool that
interacts with the master environment
within the kubernetes network and allows
all the instructions from that are
pushed to the kubelet and to docker to
be able to perform effectively so let's
have a look at some of the companies
using kubernetes there are a lot and if
you're doing any work today in the cloud
and even if you're just starting off and
doing some simple
work in the cloud there's a really good
chance that you are using kubernetes but
some of the companies that you would are
probably not surprised at using
kubernetes are spotify sap ebay
and of course some of the the big
companies out there google with their
entire network of solutions and
microsoft with office and their tools so
let's take a a step into a uber now
let's have a look at a kubernetes use
case and in this example we're going to
look at the new york times and how they
use kubernetes to solve a problem that
their iit department was struggling with
so when uh new york times started
working out of their data centers their
their actual deployments were small and
the applications were managed across vms
but the problem is is that as new york
times became more of a digital company
they started building more digital
solutions and at some point they
realized that uh what they needed to do
was to embrace the cloud and move all
their solutions to the cloud however
their first step of using the cloud and
this is i think typical for a lot of
companies is that they treated the cloud
hosted provider in the same way as they
would with a data center and they at
some point they realized they had to
take a change and this is where the
development team came in and they said
look how about we stop thinking of our
solutions as a data center even though
they're being run in amazon and start
thinking them as cloud first solutions
and so what they proposed and what they
ended up doing was using google cloud
platform with kubernetes as servers um
to
provide greater efficiency and so by
using kubernetes they had the following
advantages they're able to deliver
solutions at a much faster speed and in
the world of digital content speed is
everything they were able to reduce the
time for deployment from minutes to
seconds and by doing this they were able
to increase the amount of time that up
time for the actual infrastructure
updates began to be deployed
independently and when required so you
didn't have to schedule an event when
you did the deployment it just happened
and there was more unified approach to
deployment from the engineering staff
which just made the whole solution more
portable so the fundamental end line for
the new york times is that by leveraging
kubernetes they were able to
automatically manage their deployments
and scheduling of solutions instead of
having to do solutions through a more
traditional ticket-based system it just
really speed up the efficiency of the
new york times website so let's finally
kind of look into some of the important
terminologies before we take our time to
do a demo so we have six terms that
we're going to look through um and we'll
let you uh read through these but uh we
have a cluster which is a set of
machines physical vertical in which
applications are managed and run we have
a node that are the working machines
that run containerized applications and
other workloads there is the pod which
is within a node and is a group of
containers that are deployed together on
the same host we have replication
controllers and a replication controller
is used to define a pod life cycle
rather than to create the pods directly
we have a selector which is an
expression matched label to filter
specific resources uh labels are key
value pairs that are attached to objects
such as parts and the key value pair or
the label can be filter organize and
perform operations on resources
replication sets define how many
replicas of each pod will be running and
managed when you want to either replace
a pod when it dies annotation is a label
with much larger data capacity a name is
a resource as it is identified volume is
the directory which data is accessible
to a container namespaces provide
additional qualification to resources
name and then finally service is an
abstraction of a top-tier pods which
provide a single iep address and dns
name by which the pods can be accessed
so at this time what we want to do is
take you through kubernetes demo
actually runs through some of these
basic controls so i'm going to take you
through a video of how to actually
install kubernetes um and to use some of
the basic instructions so kubernetes is
the most widely used platform for
container management the first step is
to actually install the necessary
dependencies so let's see if there's any
updates first so the first
so to check if there's any updates we
use the command sudo app dash get update
we're entering our password and this
looks like it's going to take a few
minutes because we've got a few updates
that need to be running all right we're
done all right next we're going to write
sudo apt-get install dash y apt
transport https and this will install
all the dependencies we need to actually
start installing the solutions needed
for kubernetes all right that was quick
now we're going to put in the docker
dependency and the way we do that is
write the command sudo apt install
docker dot io i'll go typo correct that
quickly and put in y so for yes and we
continue and it's going to take a while
because we're going to download and
install docker off the internet and it's
quite a large installation now would be
a good time to go get a cup of coffee
because it'll take us about a minute to
get this all done once we actually have
docker installed we'll let you go ahead
and we'll start docker and enable docker
using our sudo commands
all right so that's all done so let's
start to enable docker we're using so
we're going to use sudo systemctl start
docker and sudo systemctl enable docker
this will be quite quick
so the next step is to install all the
components for kubernetes and we're
going to uh install the curl command and
then kubernetes cube c
and then cube adm and we're going to
install all the necessary tools we'll do
the curl command cubelet cubic c2 and
cube adm and so let's go ahead and put
in the sudo apt-get install curl we're
going to get a prompt we can say yes for
that and then after this we'll go ahead
and install kubernetes so the first what
we're going to do is we're going to
actually put in the kubernetes key so
that's going to be sudo curl dash s and
then we have a long url which is https
packages.cloudgoogle.com apt doc apt
dash key dot gpg
sudo apt dash key there we go uh create
my typo there
okay now we have to go ahead and change
permissions of like folder so we do that
with sudo chmod
777 slash etc
apt
sources.list.d all right we're good okay
now you want to go ahead and open up
your text editor and we're going to make
um an actual edit
and we're going to create a simple file
and so what we're going to type in is
the following command db http apt
dot kubernetes dot io slash kubernetes
dash xenial
main and we're going to save this file
in the etc folder and then look for and
then a apt which is going to be down a
little bit and there we have it and
we're going to save it in the
apt-get updates and we're going to name
this file as
kubernetes.list and we'll save that and
then we can close out the notepad and go
back to the terminal window and let's
look and see if there are any updates
again so we're going to go ahead and run
apt-get update and it's going to run any
updates from what we've created and we
want to check what's in the folder and
so we do
cat slash accept
etc
apt sources.this dot d slash kubernetes
dot list and there we are it shows what
we have in that text file and so we're
going to go ahead
and we're going to uh install uh cubelet
cubic cubic 2 and cube adm but first
we're going to have to initialize the
master i'm going to show you what an
error you would get if you were to
install cubelet um and the other files
too quickly you get the following error
all right so we have installed cubelet
qbadm cubexo and kubernet cni and so
we're going to go ahead and use sudo
swap
dash hyphen
a and now we're going to initialize the
master node and we're going to do that
with sudo cube
adm in it and this will take a few
minutes for it to initialize
all right so that's all done all right
so we're going to deploy the plot to a
network and we have two commands that
we're going to use we use sudo cube
cube ctl apply and then we have a
long
pathway to type out which is dash f
https raw githubs
content dot com koreo's final master
documentation cube dash final dot yml
what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead and deploy the nodes
first so we're going to do that by now
creating
mkdi
p and then we have
dollar sign home dash dot cube and
create that new directory and sudo cp
dash i and then the path will be uh etc
slash kubernetes admin dot conf and then
dollar sign home slash dot cube dot
slash config
and then final one will be
sudo
chow n dollar sign open paren id dash u
close paren colon dollar sign a brand id
slash dash g close paren dollar sign
home slash dot cube
config all right now we're going to go
ahead and deploy and uh let's see and oh
yeah i think i have a typo in my command
here yep oh yeah i did have a typo and
so um i've got that incorrect now so
documentation is actually about with a t
not an s and then we're gonna go ahead
and we're going to put in the next
line which is pseudo cubic
cube ctl apply
dash f and then we're just going to
change a little bit of the
actual link here and that runs great and
now we want to be able to see all of the
pods that we have in our network and so
we're going to do that by
writing the command sudo qbec ctcl get
pods dash all dash dash name spaces and
it should list all of our pods we only
have one
there we are as all of our content now
we're going to so there's only one node
so let's see what we have here so we can
use the command sudo you know cuba tl
get nodes there we are just one node so
our final step is to actually go ahead
and deploy a service and so what we're
going to go ahead is deploy the nginx as
service and we're going to do that with
the command sudo cubex ctl run dash dash
image equals nginx and we're going to
put this into port 80 so it's going to
be nginx
app dash dash port equals 80 dash
environment emv equals uh ubuntu
open quotes uh domain equals cluster
close quotes
and we're going to write one more
command which is sudo cube ctl expose
deployment nginx dash app dash dash port
equals 80
name equals nginx dash http and once
we've done this we will be able to then
run the command to actually see our
services and there'll be quite a few of
them
and our final command is sudo docker ps
dash a
and we have quite a lot of lists quite a
lot of services listed so there you are
that's the instructions on how to get
docker up and running and
with some basic commands and it it's
worth going through a few times to
get right um but
once you actually have um the kubernetes
environment up and running and managing
your docker environment and containers
it's extremely powerful if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
welcome to kubernetes architecture from
simplyland we're going to take a deep
dive into the kubernetes architecture if
you're new to kubernetes we already have
an introduction that goes and provides
an overview of kubernetes and we have
the link below so you can go straight to
that if you want to have a refresher
otherwise hang around and join us in
this presentation and if you want to see
more of these videos hit the subscribe
button and if you want to get notified
hit the notification bell and every time
we post up a new video you'll get the
notification right onto your phone or on
your desktop that the new video has been
uploaded and as always if you have any
questions please post them in the
comments below we do read the questions
and we try to respond to all of them as
quickly as we can with that said let's
jump into kubernetes architecture so
we're going to break out the
presentation to the following areas
we're going to cover what kubernetes is
and why you want to be using it we're
going to introduce the actual
architecture and provide an overview of
how it contains the containers and the
other components that you'd have within
the architecture we'll also compare
kubernetes with docker swarm and one of
the things that you hear with kubernetes
almost in the same breath as daca and we
have to be careful not to confuse daca
from a container point of view and
docker swarm which is a container
management tool and kubernetes is also a
container management tool so compare the
two of those and then we'll look at the
hardware and software components and
then finally do a deep dive into the
architecture of kubernetes and provide a
case study of where kubernetes has been
used successfully in the past so let's
jump into this so what actually is
kubernetes so kubernetes is a tool that
was designed to actually help manage and
contain large groups of containers it
was developed originally uh by google
out of the google borg solution and then
open source by google the actual
environment allows you to manage large
groups of containers so if you're a
developer in devops and you're working
with docker then you're used to the
concept of a container and
you'll also know that containers and
cloud technologies tend to be almost
breathed in the same breath so the work
that you're doing with kubernetes is to
be able to manage large groups of
containers inside of the cloud the thing
that's great about working with
kubernetes is that it is incredibly
flexible and allows you to have
incredibly complex applications run
efficient efficiently so let's step into
why you'd want to use kubernetes so a
couple of key points kubernetes itself
is an open source solution originally
developed by google but it is available
on most cloud platforms today so aws
google cloud microsoft azure all of them
support kubernetes and what you'll find
is as you're setting up your
infrastructure particularly if you're
using containers you'll see that the
support for kubernetes is floated up
very very efficiently and effectively by
all three vendors it's extremely um
useful for being able to manage large
modular environments and that's really
kind of these
i think one of the big benefits of
kubernetes is its modularity is that it
really breaks down uh containers into
their smaller parts and once you do that
it becomes much more efficient for you
as an administrator to be able to manage
that entire entire environment the
reproductibility of kubernetes is
extremely high you can build out
infrastructures very quickly and have
them being able to imagine and have
containers coming on and off and killed
and created to be able to help load
balance your entire environment and so
again you know we keep talking about
containers but that's really what
kubernetes is all about is being able to
manage your applications that are
managed through containers and be able
to do that in a virtualized
infrastructure and the thing that's also
really good with kubernetes is it's
really easy to deploy solutions you just
have to use a simple curl call and you
can actually push out your kubernetes
infrastructure so let's have an overview
of the kubernetes architecture so
kubernetes is really broken up into
three key areas you have your
workstation where you develop your
commands and you push out those commands
to your master and the master is
comprised of
four key areas um which essentially
control all of your nodes and and the
node contains multiple pods and each pod
has your docker container built into it
so consider that you could have a really
almost an infinite number of pods sorry
infinite number of nodes are being
managed by the master environment so you
have your cluster which is a collection
of servers that maintain the
availability and the compute power such
as ram cpu and disk utilization and you
have the master which is really
components that control and schedule the
activities of your network and then you
have the node which actually hosts the
actual docker virtual machine itself um
and be able to actually control and
communicate back to the master the
health of that pod and we'll get into
more detail in the architecture later in
the presentation so
you know you keep hearing me talk about
containers but they really are the
center of the work that you're doing
with kubernetes and can the concept
around kubernetes and containers is
really just a natural evolution of where
we've been with internet and digital
technologies over the last uh 10 15
years so
before kubernetes
you had tools where you're either
running virtual machines or you're
running uh data centers that had to
maintain and
manage and notify you of any
interruptions in your network kubernetes
is the tool that actually comes in and
helps address those interruptions and
manages them for you so the solution to
this is the use of containers so uh you
can think of containers as that natural
evolution from you know uh 15 20 years
ago you would have written your code and
posted it to a data center more recently
you probably post your code to a virtual
machine and then move the virtual
machine and now you actually just work
directly into a container and everything
is self-contained and can be pushed out
to your
environment and the thing that's great
about containers they're isolated
environments very easy for developers to
work in them but it's also really easy
for
operations teams to be able to move a
container into production so let's kind
of step and back and look at a competing
product to kubernetes which is docker
swarm now one of the things that we have
to remember is that docker um containers
which are extremely popular i'm built by
the company docker and made open source
and docker actually has other products
one of those other products is docker
swarm and docker swamp is a tool that
allows you to be able to manage multiple
containers so if we look at some of the
uh the benefits of using docker swarm
versus kubernetes and one things that
you'll find is that both tools have
strengths and weaknesses but it's really
good that they're both out there because
it helps keep it really kind of
justifies uh the importance of having
these kind of tools so a kubernetes was
designed originally from the ground up
to be auto scaling whereas docker swarm
isn't the load balancing is automatic on
docker swan words with kubernetes you
have to manually configure load
balancing across your nodes the
installation for docker swarm is really
fast and easy i mean you can be up and
running within minutes kubernetes takes
a little bit more time is a little bit
more complicated eventually you'll get
there um i mean it's not like it's going
to take you days and weeks but it's it
is a tool that's a when you compare the
two docker swarms much easier to get up
and running now what's interesting is
that kubernetes is incredibly scalable
and it's you know that's its
real strength is its ability to have
strong clusters whereas with docker
swarm its cluster strength isn't um as
strong when compared to kubernetes now
you compare it to anything else on the
market it's really good um so this is
kind of a splitting hairs kind of
comparison um but kubernetes really does
have the advantage here if you're
looking at the two compared to each
other for scalability kubernetes was
designed for by google to scale up and
support google cloud network
infrastructure they both allow you to be
able to share
storage volumes with docker you can
actually do it with any container with
that is managed by the docker swamp
whereas with kubernetes it manages the
storage with the podge and a pod can
have multiple containers within it but
you can't take it down to the level of
the container interestingly uh
kubernetes does have a graphical user
interface
for being able to control and manage uh
the environment the reality however is
that you're likely to be using terminal
uh to actually make the controls and
commands to control your either docker
swarm or kubernetes environment and it's
great that it has a gui and to get you
started but once you're up and running
you're going to be using terminal window
for those fast quick administrative
controls that you need to make so let's
look at the hardware components for
kubernetes so and what's interesting is
that the kubernetes is extremely light
of all the systems that we're looking at
it's extremely lightweight um it allows
you to have if you compare it to like a
virtual machine which is very heavy you
know
kubernetes is extremely lightweight and
harder uses any resources at all
interesting enough though is that if you
are looking at the usage of cpu it's
better to actually take it for
the cluster as a whole rather than
individual nodes because the nodes will
actually combine together to give you
that whole compute power again this is
why kubernetes works really well in the
cloud where you can do that kind of
activity rather than if you're running
in your own data center um so you can
have persistent volumes such as a local
ssd
or you can actually attach to a cloud
data storage again kubernetes is really
designed for the cloud i would encourage
you to use cloud storage wherever
possible rather than relying on physical
storage uh the reason being is that if
you connect to cloud storage and you
need to flex your your storage the cloud
will do that for you i mean that's just
an inherent part of why you'd have cloud
storage whereas if you're connecting to
physical storage you're always
restricted to the limitations of the
physical hardware so that's um kind of
pivot and look at the software
components as compared to the hardware
components so the main part of the
components is the actual container and
all of the software running in the
container runs on linux so if you um
have docker installed as a developer on
your machine it's actually running
inside of linux and that's what makes it
so lightweight and really one of the
things that you'll find is that most
data centers and cloud providers now are
running predominantly on linux inside of
the um the container itself is then
managed inside of a pod and a pod is
really just a group of containers
bundled together and
the kubernetes scheduler and proxy
server then actually manage what how the
pods are actually pushed out into your
kubernetes environment the the pods
themselves can actually then share
resources both networking and storage so
parts aren't um pushed out manually
they're actually managed through a layer
of abstraction and part of their
deployment and and this is the strength
of kubernetes you use um to find your
infrastructure and then kubernetes will
then manage it for you and there isn't
that problem of um manual management of
pods uh if you have to manage the
deployment of them and you that's simply
taken away and it's completely automated
and the the final area of software
services is on ingress and this is
really the secure way of being able to
have communication from outside of the
cluster and passing of information into
that cluster and again this is done
security through ssl layers and allows
you to ensure that security is at the
center of the work that you have within
your kubernetes environment so let's
dive now into the actual architecture
before we start looking at a use case of
how kubernetes is being employed so
kubernetes again is um we looked at this
uh diagram at the beginning of the
presentation and there are really three
key areas there's the workstation where
you develop your commands and then you
have your master environment which
controls the
scheduling the communication um and the
actual
commands that you have created and
pushes those out and manages the health
of your entire node network and each
node has various pods so we they break
this down so the master node is the most
vital component with the master uh you
have four key uh controls you have etc
controller manager scheduler an api
server the cluster store etc this
actually measures the details and values
that you've developed on your local
workstation um and then we'll work with
the output control schedule and api
server to communicate that out those
instructions of how your infrastructure
should look like to your entire network
uh the control manager is really an api
server and again um this is all about
security so we use restful apis which
can be packaged in ssl to communicate
back and forth across your
pods and the master and indeed the
services within each of them as well so
um at every single layer of abstraction
uh the communication is secure the
schedule as the name would imply really
schedules um when tasks get sent out to
the actual nodes themselves uh the nodes
themselves are are dumb nodes they just
have uh the applications um running on
them the master in the scheme is really
doing all of the work to make sure that
your entire network is running um
efficiently and then you have the api
server which has your rest commands and
the communication and back and forth
across your network that is secure and
efficient so your node environment is
where all the work that you do with your
containers gets pushed out too so um a
work is really a it's a combination of
containers and each container will then
logically run together on that node so
you'd have a collection of containers on
a node that all make logical sense to
have together within each node um you
have
docker and this is your isolated
environment for running your container
you have your kubelet which is a service
for conveying information back and forth
to the service about the actual health
of the kubernetes node itself and then
finally you have the proxy server and
the proxy server is able to manage the
nodes the volumes the the creation of
new containers
and actually helps pass the community
the health of the container back up to
the master to see whether or not the
containers should be either killed stop
started or um updated so finally let's
look at see where kubernetes is being
used by other companies so you know
kubernetes is being used by a lot of
companies and they're really using it to
help manage complex existing systems so
that they can have greater performance
and with the end goal of being able to
delight the customer and increase value
to the customer and enhance increased
value and revenue into the organization
so example of this is a company called
blackrock uh where they actually went
through the process of implementing
kubernetes and so they
so blackrock had a challenge where they
needed to be able to have much more
dynamic access to their resources uh
they were running uh complex
installations on people's desktops and
it was just really really difficult to
be able to manage their entire
infrastructure and so they actually went
and pivoted to using kubernetes and this
allowed them to be able to be much more
scalable and expansive in the in the
management of their
infrastructure and as you can imagine
kubernetes was then hooked into their
entire existing system and has really
become a key part of the success that
blackrock is now experiencing of a very
stable infrastructure um and the bottom
line is that blackrock is now able to
have confidence in their infrastructure
and be able to give that confidence
as back to their customers through the
implementation and more rapid deployment
of additional features and services
kubernetes specific to aws cloud
platform so what's a part of this
tutorial and demo what's in store for
you at offset i would like to cover the
basics of orchestration tools as most of
you would know kubernetes is one of the
most popular orchestration tools in
recent times specifically for
applications which are cloud native and
deployed on some or the other types of
containers but what are these
organization tools why would one need to
use orchestration tools what are the
facilities or features provided by this
orchestration tools that's the first
thing that i'm going to cover after that
i will pick two orchestration tools
specific to container management docker
swarm versus kubernetes i'm going to
compare them with regard to the features
that they provide the use cases that
they cover what facilities that they
provide and when to use what after that
i will get into a little bit details of
the kuvernez architecture what exactly
is required for setting up a kubernetes
cluster what runs in a control plane or
a master node what runs as a part of the
worker node after that i will end the
tutorial by running you through a demo
by setting up a three node kubernetes
cluster on aws platform i will use
something called as cops which is one of
the admin tools for setting up
production grade kubernetes cluster so i
will use this to set up a three note
cluster on aws all right now that we set
the context right let me get started so
what are orchestration tools
the application development and the
lifecycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code to your continuous
integration to testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production managing
your production servers the dependencies
that your software has
the requirement that it has in terms of
the hardware the features of fault
tolerance self-healing capabilities auto
scaling all this has complicated over
the last few years as a part of devops
one thing that everyone is interested in
is managing all this application
dependency or life cycle management
using some or the other kind of a tool
so that's where these orchestration
tools have become very very popular so
what kind of features that they provide
is you'll have to just let them know
what are the kinds of tool sets that is
required what are the fault tolerance
mechanisms that it has to be adopted to
what kind of a self-healing capabilities
that application will have to need and
if at all there is any auto scaling
features that is required if at all you
can bake in all these specific
parameters into your tool your
orchestration tool becomes a one-stop
shop for all your deployment and
configuration management needs that's
where this orchestration tools have
become a very very popular and relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more interested in adopting
devops practices all right so having
said that about orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
orchestration tools specifically for
container management docker swarm and
kubernetes many of the applications that
are written for these kind of containers
are called or kind of fall into a
category of cloud native where the
application need not know much about the
underlying infrastructure or the
platform where these applications are
running so these two along with apache
missiles there are many other container
management systems but i'm going to pick
docker swarm and kubernetes for
comparing the features that is provided
by these two frameworks for the sake of
comparison i picked up docker swarm and
kubuntis just because of the reason that
both of them operate in the space of
container management they do something
very very similar to containers that's
the similarity that exists between these
two orchestration tools however there's
a big difference that exists when it
comes to the types of containers that
both of them cater to and also the
capacity of workloads they can be used
for docker swamp is a cluster management
solution that is provided by docker
container docker is one of the very very
popular containers of recent times and
in case you have your applications that
is totally powered by only docker
containers if you have a need where you
want to run a cluster of servers which
are running only docker containers
docker swarm should be your choice for
your orchestration tool kubernetes on
the other hand can cater to any other
types of containers other than docker
and including docker as well so in case
you have your applications which have
got docker in them which have got rkt in
them which they have got alex in them or
any other type of container kubernetes
should be your choice of orchestration
too a docker swarm can manage up to 40
50 or 60 max
nodes so in case your application is
totally written in docker containers and
the load or the expected cluster size is
about 50 60 nodes docker swarm should be
the choice of orchestration tool on the
other hand kubernetes is something that
was open sourced by google and the kind
of the scale of operations that
kubernetes can cater to is google scale
so if in case your applications are more
than a thousand nodes that is where
kubernetes comes into play that's the
big difference that exists between
docker swarm and kubernetes putting
those differences aside let me compare
docker swarm and kubernetes based upon
other features which are similar in
nature the first and important feature
that kubernetes provides is something
called as auto scaling if at all the
load on your cluster is too high and
your application is experiencing more
load so kubernetes can add new nodes to
your cluster of course you'll have to
configure kubernetes in order to have
those capabilities where it can spin up
new vms or new nodes if at all you do
that configuration correctly kubernetes
has got the capacity or it has got the
feature where it can bring up a new node
and add it to the cluster on the fly
based upon the load that exists at that
moment on similar lines if at all the
load is not too high it can identify a
few of those nodes which have got less
number of
replicas or less number of application
containers running on it it can move
them to some other node and also scale
down by deleting few nodes from your
cluster so that is the powerfulness of
auto scaling which is provided by
kubernetes and this unfortunately does
not exist in docker swarm the other
feature of load balancing specifically
application node balancing so docker
swarm gives you an application level
auto load balancing however kubernetes
gives you the flexibility of manually
configuring any other type of load
balancer of your choice for application
load balancing installation as i
mentioned earlier docker swarm is a
loose cluster of containers which are
running on nodes it is very easy to spin
up a new node and then connect them to a
swarm and this can be done in a very
very loosely coupled way where you can
create swarms of your choice notes are
allowed to connect to swarms and quit or
leave the swamps on the flag so in and
all the installation is pretty easy and
fast kubernetes on the other hand the
configuration of kubernetes the way to
spin up a big cluster specifying the
size of the node how many master nodes
how many config planes that you want how
many nodes that you want it's a pretty
tough thing to bring up a kubernetes
scalability kubernetes strength is very
very strong they are very tightly
coupled and even they have the
capability where on the cluster size
things or the nodes can be increased on
the fly based upon the requirement on a
darkest form the cluster strength is
weak as compared to cobra days worker
notes can be added to a swarm worker
notes can be asked to levers form or can
be taken out of a swarm based upon the
requirement so this is kind of a loosely
coupled architecture for docker swarm
while kubernetes the cluster is very
tightly coupled since docker swarm runs
only docker containers containers find
it very easy to share data a lot of
other things with each other because
they all have the same signature they're
all from the same family so it's very
easy for them to share not just volumes
but a lot of other things however for
kubernetes since it manages containers
of different types if your application
has to share some data across different
containers there's a little bit of a
complexity in how you would want your
containers to share data also when it
comes to kubernetes kubernetes groups
containers in something called as pods
while a pod can have either one
container that's a preferred choice or
multiple containers and the idea of pod
is like each part can run in any other
node it's not guaranteed that you would
want to have two or three parts to be
running on the same note that makes data
sharing a little bit of a different
thing compared to docker's form uh gui
so there's not a good enough ui tool in
docker's form at least uh the ce edition
of it which will allow you to get to
know what is running on your containers
what is the size of the containers what
is the volume of the containers and all
that stuff there are some free and open
source tools like proteiner which gives
you a good visibility into your running
docker containers however there's
nothing at a swarm level that is
provided by docker kubernetes gives you
an out of the box dashboard which is
easy to configure and set up you can
also club it with some metrics services
and you can also get information about
the size of the cluster that is running
what is the load on the nodes and stuff
like that all this across your cluster
in a very beautiful dashboard
perspective so that way um this is
little bit of a good ui for kubernetes
while for docker's form there isn't
anything that is provided out of the box
let me spend some time in explaining a
little bit about the kubernetes
architecture what comprises of the
kubernetes cluster what resides in a
master or a control plane and what
resides in a worker node this is a very
high level depiction of a kubernetes
cluster so this is the master node which
has got something called as a cluster
store a controller a scheduler component
and an api server and these are the
bunch of nodes that are connected or
administered by the master node the
master node can be one three five
typically an odd number this is as per
the typical cluster management thing
where you would need the masternodes to
be in odd numbers so that whenever
there's any contention in terms of what
needs to be deployed where or where to
give the job to whom and stuff like that
all the masters would cast their vote
and they would decide on the outcome so
that's the master node and there are a
bunch of uh nodes which can be connected
and administered by the masternode cube
ctl or the command from using which
anybody can assign some workloads to the
cluster can also be run either on the
same node or on a separate node so
cubectl is the command line tool that we
will be installing and using in order to
fire up our commands to our cluster so
if at all i have to put up a job on our
cluster if i have to give out any
specific commands to my cluster all this
is done using cuba ctl there's a bunch
of rest apis which is used by cuba ctl
and cubectl will talk to the api server
and fire up the commands specific to my
cluster what runs in the master node
master node without saying it's the most
important component of any of the
cluster if at all you're running um
cluster with only one master node if
your master node goes down there's no
other way that you know you can or any
user can talk to the different nodes in
the cluster so master node is the most
vital component responsible for the
complete kubernetes cluster there's
always one node that should be running
as a master node that's the bare minimum
requirement for your cluster so what are
the other components in the master node
the most important one is called etcd so
this is nothing but a data store a value
of key value pair which is stored which
contains all information about your
cluster so all the configuration details
which
node is up which worker node is down all
this information is stored in the
cluster store so all the managers would
access this cluster store before they go
ahead and decide any other work item or
anything else that has to be done
specific to your cluster what's in the
controller as the name says controller
is something it's like a daemon server
that is running in a continuous loop all
the time it is responsible for
controlling the set of replicas the kind
of
workloads that is running based upon the
configuration that the user has set in
so if at all if you are aware of
something called as replication
controllers endpoint controllers
namespace controllers all these
controllers are managed by the
controller component if any user asked
for some three replicas of a particular
pod or a service to be running and if at
all any of the nodes goes down or the
part goes down for whatever reason the
controller is the one who wakes up and
assigns this particular job or the part
to some other available node by looking
up for the details using in the cluster
store that's the importance of the
control manager or the controller the
scheduler the scheduler assigns the
tasks based upon whoever is asked for
any job to be scheduled based upon a
time frame or based upon some criteria
it also tracks the working load as to
what what exactly is the load who is
running what and in the cluster and
places the workload on whoever is the
available resource at that time all
right epa server this is one other
important component in in our kubernetes
cluster where how would the end user
deploy or give out any sort of a
workload onto your cluster all the
requests come to the api server so this
is an entry point for all your
requests that come into your cluster
anybody wants to deploy something
anybody want to scale up a controller
anybody who wants to bring down a few
services anybody wants to put in a
service all this will have to come in as
a part of a rest um api endpoint and api
server is the enter point in case you
don't want uh you know somebody to
access your cluster in case you want
only specific people or specific users
to be running some specific workloads
you can set all those role-based access
control for this apa server so this is
the entry point for anyone who wants to
submit any job to your cluster so that's
a quick overview about the master node
what what are the important components
of a master node now let's go over to
what runs in a worker or a slave node as
i mentioned earlier slave nodes are
something where the job that is
submitted to your cluster is eventually
run as a board as a service as a
container so in kubernetes world there
is something called as a pod a pod is
nothing but a combination of a container
it is a wrapper around your running
containers so slave nodes or the worker
nodes typically run these parts so that
is where the whole workload typically
gets run but there are a bunch of other
components in the in the node which also
manages what runs in the pod who has to
have access to the pod what is the state
of the pod is it in a running state is
it going down for some reason and all
the stuff so let's quickly go over those
components that is there in the slave
node the most important component in my
opinion that should be on the on the
node should be the container runtime as
i mentioned earlier kubernetes can run
any different types of containers not
just docker so in case you want to have
a node which wants to have docker
running on it rkt running or lkc running
on it or any other container environment
that is running on it you have to ensure
that the specific container runtime
environment is available on that
specific node so that whenever a job is
submitted description of what needs to
be run as a part of the pod what should
be the image with it should be powered
and what kind of a container to spin up
so that's what you know when the job is
finally assigned to this particular node
it would definitely need a container
runtime to be up and running so that
exists only if at all the container
runtime is installed and running on your
kubernetes worker node okay now that we
know what our kubernetes node can run
how would somebody assign a job to our
node that is using something called as a
cubelet as the name says cubelet or
cubelet is a small subset which talks to
the cube api server so any node which
has to run any kind of a pod all these
instructions are passed around by the
qbps server to the cubelet and cubelet
is capable of processing whatever job
that is assigned to it and ensuring that
so many parts and so many services are
spun up based upon the requirement the
last component that exists in the worker
node is the cube proxy or kubernetes
proxy this plays a very very important
role acting as a load balancer and a
network proxy so what typically happens
is whenever the pods are running in
nodes the parts can be typically running
in any node there is no
affinity towards any node on which these
parts are running because pods or
containers are something called as
ephemeral they can run anywhere so how
would somebody reach out to these
applications that is running in some pod
which is running in one container now
and running in probably another
container another node altogether
tomorrow so that is where your
kubernetes proxy contains a picture and
this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any pod
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these parts and kind of connects the end
points or acts like a dns server so that
it knows when somebody is trying to
reach out to this particular service
which is the part on which the service
is typically running so that plays a
very very important role by acting as a
load balancer and a network proxy now
that at a very high level we know what
are all the components that make up of
our kubernetes cluster let's go ahead
and create a small cluster and spin up
this cluster on aws platform finally we
get to the demo section of my tutorial
now that you guys are aware as to what
is kubernetes what is the use of
kubernetes you also know at a very very
high level what are the components of a
cluster what is a master node or a
control plane what are the components of
a master node and what should be
existing in a worker node you're
probably thinking that it's maybe pretty
hard to kind of set this up so let me
demystify that by running you with a
quick demo of how to set up a simple
three node kubernetes cluster using a
tool called cops and i will be doing
this whole setup on my aws cloud okay so
what is cops cops is nothing but a
simple tool this is an admin tool that
allows you to bring up production grade
kubernetes environments as i said
setting up a kubernetes cluster on a
bare metal is little challenging so that
is why i would use something called as a
cops and i will use this on my cluster
which i'll spin up on my aws instance so
i have an aws account and what i will do
first is i will first spin up an ec2
server i will power this with one of the
linux amis and i will install cops on it
now this will be my starting point from
where i'm going to trigger
running up a big cluster in our case
i'll try to keep it little small i don't
want too many nodes in my cluster i'm
going to have one master node and two
worker nodes this whole operation would
be done programmatically by installing
this cops admin tool so as you may know
aws is little hard for me to
programmatically run other components or
rather bring up servers it's not pretty
simple so what i would do is i will
create an iam role which will attach to
my ec2 server so that my ec2 server gets
powered with all the required role so
that it can go ahead and spin up cluster
based upon my configuration that i'm
going to specify all right so once i
have my cluster set up i will also
install cuba ctl which uh you would
probably know by now is nothing but a
command line utility using which i can
kind of connect to my cluster give it
some jobs put some parts and stuff like
that so i will use cuba ctl i will also
have a pair of ssh keys so that from
this machine i would be able to
successfully get onto the master node
and submit jobs on my behalf so let me
begin by first logging into my aws
account all the steps that i will be
following to bring up my aws cluster
kubernetes cluster will be documented
and i'll be sharing you this document in
a github repository so that in case
anybody wants to try you'll be more than
happy to find all the required
instructions in one place okay now the
first thing that i would need is to
launch an aws ec2 instance now this is
an instance where i'm going to install
cops and i will use it as a base server
from where i'm going to find some
commands which will bring up my
kubernetes cluster so let me log into my
aws account and um let me stick to one
particular region and let me bring up
some a one ec2 instance all right so let
me launch my instance let me choose um
it doesn't matter in the ways but in
case you want to try it on your free
tire i would recommend choose free tire
only and choose an ami of your choice
let me choose this instance i will make
it t2 micro that is good for me
configuration instance details all right
i don't want to change anything here
that looks good maybe i will change this
30 gig that's good for me let me add a
tag to my instance i will name this as
my cops server all right i would need a
bunch of posts to be opened up so what i
will do is i will create a new security
group uh called open to the word i would
not recommend that you do this since i
don't want to it will take a long time
for me to specifically uh to pick and
choose
the ports that has to be open for
running my cluster i don't want to do
that i will open up all the http and
https ports so that it's quicker so i
will say all tcp i would say from
anywhere just to be on the safer side
also open http and https and i will make
this anywhere and anywhere this is good
for me i will say review and launch all
right so i chose a t2 micro instance
just for the sake of easiness i've
opened up all the ports and um the
instant details are you've seen what is
that i've chosen all right now important
part is like i would need a key pair i
need to create a new keypad i will call
this as simply learn
keys i will download this
keypair and then i will launch the
instance it will take some time for my
ec2 instance to come up in the meanwhile
what i'll do is i will convert i have
this pen file which is the pair of keys
the ssh keys with which i need to log
into my ec2 instance so i'll need to
convert this because i'm trying to
connect from my windows box i would need
to convert this into a ppk file so i
have puttygen i'm going to load my set
of keys here and convert that key into a
ppk right open all right i would say
save hang on save private key yes i
would say simply learn or simply learn
private private key and save this here
and that that's all so this is my public
key which is the pem file and this is my
ppk or my private key now using the
private key i will log into my ec2
instance okay now my ec2 instance is up
and running it is running in this ohio
region and this is the ip address of my
public ipads of my machine so let me
connect to it so i use a moba x term
which is nothing but an ssh emulator you
can use putty or any of these sessions
which allow you to do an ssh this is my
ip address of my machine and since i've
spun up an amazon ami the user this is
the default user i would need to specify
the private keys for my session and this
is the private key for my session say
okay i am in my
amazon ec2 instance so let me look at
what are the other things that i need to
do all right so as i said i just brought
up my ec2 instance but i would need my
ec2 instance to
run few things on my behalf so that it
can spin up easy to other ec2 instances
it can also talk to an s3 bucket where
i'm going to store the instant state of
my kubernetes cluster also some sort of
an auto scaling group because i want to
spin up more and more instances i also
want to have a private hosted zone using
my route 53 so i would need my ec2
instance to have all these sort of
permissions for my server so what i
would do is i will go and create a
permission a rule in the ec2 or rather
in the aws im role and i will attach
this im role to my ec2 instance all
right so let me go to my iam which is
nothing but the identity and access
management i will create a role called
as possibly corpse role i will create a
role this role will be used by my ec2 so
i'm going to click on ec2 and say next
permissions they would need a lot of
permissions specific permissions to be
very honest and the permissions are all
listed out here s3 ec2 and all this
stuff just to keep it pretty simple what
i would do is i'll create a role with
the administrative access all right so i
don't want any tags i will review i'll
create a role name i will say cubs role
for ec2 all right so i'm going to create
a role which has got administrative
access rules i'm going to create a role
so this would ensure that my ec2
instance from which i'm going to run my
cluster would have all the prerequisite
permissions so that it can go and spin
up instances talk to s3 buckets and all
that stuff all right now let us have our
running instance get powered by this
role so i will connect this role to my
running instance all right so this is my
ec2 instant that is running
action attach attach attach attach
replace im rolls so there is no rule as
of now i would want my cops roll for
easy this row that i created so i want
this new room to be assigned to my ec2
all right great now my ec2 instance
which is my cop server has got all the
required permissions so that he can
create a cluster on my behalf great now
before this let me do a sudo yum update
iphone y so that any of the because this
is a newly provisioned vm i just want to
ensure that all my library system
libraries are all updated so that when i
do install cop and cube ctl and all
those things none of them will fail
because of some dependency or package
issues so i'm just running a sudo update
iphone y so that all the libraries are
updated okay looks like it is done so
let me go ahead and install cops cops is
a pretty simple installation it is
available in a particular location i
have to just copy this and ensure that i
do a curl and i install this particular
stuff all right so it is fetching uh the
cops tool is installing for me once it
is copied down let me change the mode so
that i can execute it and then also let
me move it to my user local bin so that
it is available for me in my path okay
that's pretty much the corpse
installation let me also do one other
thing let me install something called as
cuba ctl so this is what would be you
know a tool using which i'm going to be
firing my uh commands to my kubernetes
cluster once it comes up right this is a
pretty smaller executable so
ctl all right so i have cuba ctl as well
as cops installed on my ec2 server now
okay now what i'll do next is i'm going
to create an s3 bucket in aws so that
the equivalent is a cluster state is
persisted in this bucket so let me
create a simple bucket with this name s3
bucket with this name so let me go to s3
and let me create a simple bucket with
this name i will just say create a
bucket okay so the simply
learn.kubernetes is the bucket that i
created so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster let me now
uh go and create a dns entry or a dns
zone or aws route 53 hosted zone for my
cluster so this is required so that you
know i can give a cluster name for my
kubernetes cluster that i'm coming up so
i will create a private hosted zone and
possibility possibly i will call this as
simply learn dot in so this will be my
name of my private hosted zone in case
you already have any other public hosted
zones in your name you can always put a
route 53 hosted zone specific for your
domain name since i don't have anyone
i'm just going to create a simple
private hosted zone so let me head down
to route
53 click on any of these and you'll get
these hosted zones out here so i'm going
to create a hosted zone here i'm going
to create a hosted zone click on create
hosted zone um this would be simply
learn lot in i want to create a public
no i don't want public i want a private
hosted zone and i'm going to associate
my vpc id for this hosted zone since i'm
going to try out all my exercises in the
ohio region i will associate the vpc of
the wire region for this all right so
this is the one that is specific to the
ohio region so i will say this one i'll
say create a hosted zone great now let
me come back to my ec2 box my ec2 is all
powered with whatever it needs in order
to go ahead with the installation of my
cluster only few things that i need to
take care of is that you know now that i
put a name for my cluster i also have an
s3 bucket that i've configured for my
cluster i will have to ensure that i
need to put in these two configurations
as a part of my cluster building
activity so i will open my bash rc file
and i'm going to export these two
variables if at all you remember well
these two variables are nothing but the
cluster name which is nothing but the
public sorry the private hosted zone
that i created and the s3 bucket where
i'm going to create or rather i'm going
to store my cluster state so let me copy
these two and open up my
bash rc file all right so i will just
add these two and copy these add export
them out as my variable i'm going to
save this here now let me ensure that
this gets picked up all right i've got
these two that have configured and i
also ensure that these environment
variables are set now let me create a
pair of ssh keys this is to ensure that
i can log into the box that i'm going to
be provisioning as a part of my cluster
ssh hyphen keygen i don't want to give
any parameters let it go to the home
directory with the default name and
without any passphrase all right so i
created a bunch of my keypair now i'm
all set to go ahead and run my cops now
cops will ensure that this will take
some time for the cluster to come up but
this is exactly how i would define my
corpse command how do i have copied here
so corpse create cluster the state of
the cubs cluster will be stored in this
particular variable which is what i have
exported out the number of node count is
two node count is the worker node count
if at all i don't specify configuration
for specifying the master or the control
pane as well if i don't specify that the
default one is one so i'm going to
create
one primary or the master node and two
worker nodes size of my master node size
of the worker nodes uh what are the
zones where i want this to be created
and where do i store the cluster
information and uh okay i've already
added this master account this is
actually not required but this is the
command that i'm going to fire off so
that i bring up my cluster all right
that went off uh very fast but um this
actually did not create a cluster it is
just the definition of a cluster and
that's why this came out very fast
now that everything looks good with
whatever configuration that i specified
now let me go ahead and create the
cluster by saying corpse update cluster
iphone iphone 8 yes now this will take
some time a good five to ten minutes for
it to because this will actually start
provisioning the servers and as i
mentioned earlier based upon my
configuration i'm going to come up with
one master server and two nodes or the
worker nodes all right so this is the
command for me to validate the cluster
and i'm gonna try it out first i'm
pretty sure that it will fail because
all my servers are not up yet it is
taking some time the validation
everything failed but let me try to look
at my ec2 instances and
see how many servers do i have running
as of now if you see i had only one
server that i had started which was my
cop server and automatically the other
three instances one is called not start
simply not in this these two are the
nodes and this is the master node so
these three got automatically
provisioned by the cops command that i
ran all right so this may take a while
for it to get validated a good five to
ten minutes so what i'll do is i'll
pause the video now and i'll come back
once uh the server the cluster is up and
running it's been a good uh eight to
nine minutes uh since i started my
cluster so let me validate now okay
seems good so there's a master node
minimum one max one some nodes which are
nothing but the slave nodes or the
worker nodes there are two of them due
to micro
subnet so my clusters seem to be up and
running and my cluster name is simply
learn.n so what i would want to do is
now let me just log into the master and
see if i can run some parts so let me
get back to my
installation steps here the validation
cluster is done so let me login to my
since my cluster name is simply non dot
and this is the way to log into my box
so let me get into my box so if you see
here uh this is the host name of the
machine that i'm currently in if you see
this this is nothing but our this cop
server this is a server now from here
i'm trying to get into the master box
all right so if you see the ip address
has changed i was in a different box i'm
in a different box now if i see host
name you'll find a different host name
so this is 153 which is nothing but the
master node yep it's 153 this is the
particular host so i'm getting into this
machine now so i started the cluster
from my cop server here it ran and
brought up three nodes so i'm actually
getting into my master node and see if i
can run some parts on it all right so
let me try kubectl uh get cluster info
try cube ctl get nodes alright so there
are three nodes here master node and um
one master node and two worker nodes so
let me see if i have some pods here
cubic ctl gate pods so there's no port
as of now so what i'll try to do is let
me just pin up a very very simple part
just to check if my connections is
everything is correct or not correct i
have a simple
node.js application that i've built uh
and i've got a container for that this
is already pushed to the docker i've
registered is called simply learn docker
hub and the image name that i have here
is called my node app and i will use
this image to power one of my parts that
i will run so this is the way in which
i'm going to launch my pod let me show
you this commands cube ctl run the name
for my deployment that i'm going to run
hyphen iphone image and this is the
image that is going to be powering my
container so this is simply learn docker
hub forward slash my node app hyphen f1
replicas equal to i want two replicas to
be running and the port that i want to
expose this particular part is on 8 0 8
0. so let me run this as soon as this is
run it creates something called as a
deployment all right now let me just say
um i'm not really interested in the
deployment i'm interested in checking if
all the parts are up and running so i
will say cube ctl get both all right so
that was pretty fast so i have two parts
that are running here these are two
replicas because i asked for two
replicas these parts are running so i
can run cube ctl describe pod pickup all
right i can pick up any of the pod name
and see what is the pod what is the
information does it contain from what is
the image that is pulling what is the
image image name id this is actually
running my pod which is actually
spinning up a container great so far so
good so in kubernetes the pods can are
ephemeral so they can be there at any
time cannot be runtime if i need to
expose my pod outside i will have to
create a service for my pod so what i'll
do is i'll create a very very simple
service by exposing this particular
deployment before that let me check cube
serial get deployment so there's a
deployment that is created the
deployment name is simply run app so i
will expose my deployment simply learn
app as uh yeah i'll just expose this let
me see all right i'm not specifying what
type and all i don't want to get into
the complications of uh what are the
different types of exposing the service
and all that stuff so if i don't specify
anything uh it gives me something closer
cluster ip so this is where my pod is
actually exposed so let me just check if
at all this part is up and running i'll
just try a simple curl command curl http
colon this is my cluster ip and the port
is 8080 if at all i hit this it's
actually hitting my application and
giving me whatever i put a simple uh sys
dot out kind of a thing where i'm just
printing um the container id of whatever
pod is serving uh being sold off so i'm
actually hitting my container and i'm
getting this output from the content so
everything looks good my content is up
and running uh so let me just go and
clean it up i'll say equip ctl uh delete
deployment simply learn app this should
get rid of all the parts that i created
cubectl getpod all right these parts are
intermediating things let me just check
cubectl get services there's one service
i don't want this service let me delete
that cubectl delete service i want this
all right that sounds good so let me
come back to my host my cop server from
where i'm running so i managed to
successfully verify this part see if
everything is up and running so what
i'll do is i'll just go ahead and
complete this demo by going and uh
getting rid of my cluster so corpse
delete cluster hyphen f1 yes all right
so this will ensure that it will clean
up my complete cluster that i created so
i had three or four running instances if
you see that all the three are shutting
down because you know the cop server
which had cops installed on it uh has
now got a mandate to go ahead and shut
down and clean up the whole instances
and all those things that are created as
a part of my deployment hey everyone i
welcome you all to this puppet fill
course by simply learn in this complete
course we will learn everything that we
need to know to excel in puppet
we have math and anjali to guide us
through this journey we shall begin with
having a basic understanding of puppet
and what is its relevance today
after that we shall dive deeper and
understand the components of puppet
followed by its architecture
after checking its architecture we shall
look at the process to install puppet
and configure it in our local system
moving forward we shall see companies
that have adopted puppet and all about
writing manifest and puppet after that
we will check regarding the puppet
community and puppet dsl post switch we
shall see the hands-on demo that will
explain the working of puppet from
scratch after we have ample knowledge
regarding the tool we shall understand
the difference between chef
puppet ansible and salt stack
finally we shall take a look at some of
the interview questions that might
increase your chances of cracking any
puppet interview so before we begin make
sure that you have subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to
click that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn now without
further ado let's begin with our
introduction hello this is matthew from
simply learn we're going to focus
specifically on puppet so in this
session what we're going to do is we're
going to cover what and why you would
use puppet what are the different
elements and components of puppet and
how does it actually work and then we'll
look into the companies that are
adopting puppet and what are the
advantages that they have now received
by having puppet within their
organization and finally we'll wrap
things up by reviewing how you can
actually write a manifest in puppet so
let's get started so why puppet so here
is a scenario that as an administrator
you may already be familiar with you as
an administrator have multiple servers
that you have to work with and manage so
what happens when a server goes down
it's not a problem you can jump onto
that server and you can fix it but what
if the scenario changes and you have
multiple servers going down so here is
where puppet shows its strap with
puppets all you have to do is write a
simple script that can be written with
ruby and write out and deploy to the
servers your settings for each of those
servers the code gets pushed out and to
the servers that are having problems and
then you can choose to either roll back
to those servers to their previous
working states or set them to a new
state and do all of this in a matter of
seconds and it doesn't matter how large
your server environment is you can reach
to all of these servers your environment
is secure you're able to deploy your
software and you're able to do this all
through infrastructure as code which is
the advanced devops model for building
out solutions so let's dig deeper into
what puppet actually is so puppet is a
configuration management tool maybe
similar tools like chef that you may
already be familiar with it ensures that
all your systems are configured to a
desired and predictable state public can
also be used as a deployment tool for
software automatically you can deploy
your software to all of your systems or
to specific systems and this is all done
with code this means you can test the
environment and you can have a guarantee
that the environment you want is written
and deployed accurately so let's go
through those components of puppet so
here we have a breakdown of the puppet
environment and on the top we have the
main server environment and then below
that we have the client environment that
would be installed on each of the
servers that would be running within
your network so if we look at the top
part of the screen we have here our
puppet master store which has and
contains our main configuration files
and those are comprised of manifests
that are actual codes for configuring
the clients we have templates that
combine our codes together to render a
final document and you have files that
would be deployed as content that could
be potentially downloaded by the clients
wrapping this all together is a module
of manifest templates and files you
would apply a certificate authority to
sign the actual documents so that the
clients actually know that they're
receiving the appropriate and authorized
modules outside of the master server
where you'd create your manifest
templates and files you would have
public clients is a piece of software
that is used to configure a specific
machine there are two parts to the
client one is the agent that constantly
interacts with the master server to
ensure that the certificates are being
updated appropriately and then you have
the fact of it the current state of the
client that is used and communicated
back to through the agent so now that we
know what puppet is let's look into the
puppet architecture so puppet has a
master slave architecture as you can see
here on the top we have the puppet
master and below we have the puppet
clients so the puppet master is the
system where your system administrator
sits the clients are those systems which
require configuration you can have n
number of clients connected to the
puppet master so don't worry we look
into each of these components in detail
firstly we have the puppet master so the
puppet mask is where the system
administrator sits and he or she types
in the codes here so the codes are not
only written in the system but they are
also stored here and whenever the client
requires these codes for their
configuration they simply request it so
manifest is the first sub-component of
the puppet master these are the actual
files where the codes are written so in
case of puppet these are ruby files
modules tie manifests templates and
files into a single unit
now these codes dictate the instructions
for performing various tasks on your
client the next component is templates
so if manifests are your code templates
are the data so let me explain this to
you with an example consider you want to
create a file called index.html on one
of your client machines so what you do
is you write the code for creating this
file in your manifest and the content of
this file is written in your templates
then you simply link them but here's the
thing when you divide your code and data
in this way it's a very clean structure
so it's preferred to do it in this
manner files are your static contents so
the files are basically sent to your
client and they are simply downloaded at
the client there is no execution or
compilation involved with your files now
this is where files and templates are
extremely different because with
templates they are never sent over to
your client the templates are simply
read by the parser at the master itself
modules ties the manifest templates and
files into a single unit so modules is
not a separate component as such it just
provides a very clean hierarchy this is
the most important component of the
puppet master ca which stands for
certificate authority
now as we will see later in this video
the puppet master and the puppet client
communicate through an exchange of ssl
certificates so when the client sends
over the certificate to the master ca
provides the master the authority to
sign these certificates the minute the
master signs a certificate the master is
basically saying that yes this client is
registered with me and i agree to
exchange data with this client our next
component puppet client of course these
are the systems that require to be
configured agent is a service installed
on the client the agent is solely
responsible for all the communication
between the master and the client and
finally we have factor so factor is
responsible for collecting all the data
about the present state of our client
and sending this data over to the puppet
master at the master this data is
compared against the manifest which are
your code files and then these manifests
are sent over to the client depending
upon the results of this comparison so
now that we had a look at the various
components of puppet let's see how these
work together
so we have a master and we have three
clients now before any information can
be transferred between the master and
the client it's important that these
components recognize each other also
there needs to be an encrypted channel
of communication between each pair of
master and client now all the data which
is transferred between the master and
the client it flows through this channel
so let's see how this entire procedure
of recognizing each other works the core
of this procedure are the ssl
certificates ssl stands for secure
socket layer secure socket layer is a
security protocol and it forms an
encrypted channel between two components
what this encrypted channel ensures is
that all the data that is passed through
this channel is not accessible by any
other system outside so it provides
complete security okay so we will
consider a very general scenario we have
a master and a client here this is not
the puppet master or the puppet client
they're just two systems and we're just
going forward with master slave
architecture so the client so far is not
a client it is just a system and we will
refer to the system as system a so
system a sends over a client certificate
to the master associated with this
client certificate is the host name of
system a now master goes through the
certificate it sees the host name and
then it decides whether it wants to form
a communication link with the system a
if it does it signs the certificate and
the signed certificate is sent back to
system a now the system a is officially
a client the minute the master signed
the client certificate it said that yes
i am willing to exchange information
with this system and i do take the
system as one of my clients so now that
the system is officially a client it can
request for data from the master and the
master will simply send over the data
now we are here to talk about puppet so
if this was a puppet master and this was
a puppet client then the first three
stages will be the same so the puppet
client sends over the certificate to the
master the master signs the certificate
sends it back and the client requests
for data now by data here of course we
mean the configuration data those are
the manifest or even could be your files
so what happens after this request after
this request the factor service which is
present on your clients collects all the
information regarding the present state
of your client so this information could
include the operating system that's
installed on them the various number of
software present on them the versions of
these software now all this information
is collected it's called the fact and
it's sent over to the master at the
master this information that is the
facts is compared against the manifest
so why does the master do this the
master basically compares the facts
against a manifest to know if what the
manifest is about to perform is already
performed on these systems so if the
manifest has some additional
functionality they are compiled into
catalogs and then these catalogs are
sent over to the client now remember
those agent services which existed in
your clients here's where they come in
the agents take the catalog and execute
them on the client once executed these
catalogs make the required changes on
the client and a report is generated
this report is then sent back to the
master so the master keeps record of all
the changes that's made in the system
and this comes very handy when one of
the systems fail and it's required to be
rolled back to its previous working
state so this entire procedure can be
repeated n number of times and can be
repeated at regular intervals so if you
have a scenario where a system needs to
be configured every 30 minutes what you
can do is you can set your interval and
automatically every 30 minutes your
systems will be configured if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
so today i'll be showing you how you can
use puppet to install apache on one of
your client machines so we'll be using
two machines here we'll have a server
and we'll have a node machine the server
is essentially your master the node is
your client i'm just using the term
server and node instead because i want
to keep it very close to as they are
used in the commands now both these
machines are going to be sent to a seven
machines and i have oracle vm virtualbox
installed on my machine so on that i've
simply created two virtual boxes both
centos 7 of course so before we move on
to the actual demo i'll just take you
through the various steps so first we'll
install the puppet server on our server
or master machine we'll then start the
server service we then shift over to our
node or the client machine and we'll
install the puppet agent service we will
then start this service too and the
minute you start the puppet agent
service an ssl certificate is created so
this certificate will have the host name
of your node attached to it and this is
how the master or the server will
recognize this certificate and then it
will sign this certificate so once your
master or the server signs the
certificate you can write your manifest
so the manifesto is just the codes for
configuration and once that tool is done
you shift back to your client or the
node system and you run the asian
service so once you run the agent
service your manifest or your cat logs
because as you know the manifests are
compiled into catalogs these are
executed on your node and this will make
the required changes so that's how this
entire process is going to work now
let's move on to the actual demo
this is my oracle vm virtualbox manager
the last two machines you see here are
the ones we'll be using for this demo
the puppet server is your puppet master
puppet client of course is the client so
let's just have a look at these two
machines
this is my puppet server so just so you
can differentiate guys the terminals
have been set accordingly puppet server
has a black background with white text
and puppet client here has a black
background with green text
so we'll move on to server machine or
the master machine because that's the
one we'll be working on first so before
we begin we need to set the hostname of
our master to puppet so this is a very
essential step in the configuration of
puppet if you miss this out there are
quite a lot of other changes you'll have
to make in certain files
so let's do this first
so that's the command to set the host
name the last word you see there that's
the new host name you want
okay so now we'll just check if our
hostname is set so just type
name
and yeah it's puppet
so next we will check the ip of this
machine
so for that you just type if config
enter
so this is your ip guys
under enp0s3
in its value
that is
192.168.2.183 of course the ip will
differ for you guys
needless to say
so note that down somewhere because
we'll require it when we are configuring
our client
okay so now you want your puppet server
and your client
to communicate so for this we need to
remove certain firewalls so the command
for this is
sudo because we want the root permission
system
ctl
stop
firewall
d
and put in the password
okay so all your firewalls are removed
so the next step now we start on with a
puppet process so we download the puppet
labs at first now guys ensure that your
systems your virtual boxes in this case
are connected to the net
also you won't be getting an ip if it's
not for the first time
so here's a command to download the
puppet lag
enter the password again
okay so the puppet labs is downloaded
now you need to install this
so installation guys we will be
installing the puppet server on the
master machine or the puppet server
machine
so this may take a while
so that took a while so i just skipped
to the last part where it's completed
the installation process is over
now we need to make a small change
in our system config puppet server file
so let's just move to the file first
this file will open in vi editor
so this line here it basically allocates
memory for your puppet server now you do
not need 2gb
so we are going to reduce the size
512 mb should be enough
so guys notice here i did not type the b
okay so i just changed this to xms
m
let's save that
always remember to open this file using
sudo otherwise saving the changes you
made could be quite troublesome
okay so now we can start a puppet server
service
we enable the service
okay so that's done so basically our
puppet server service
has started it's running presently
so for a while we are done with the
server machine
let's move on to our client machine
okay first things first we open our edc
host file
with sudo because you need to make a few
changes and save it
open this in the vi terminal
okay guys so here
you have to add this one line at the end
type in the ip
for your puppet server machine
puppet
dash master
so let's save this file
now we'll move on to downloading puppet
labs on our puppet client so the command
is the same that we use for puppet
server
so puppet labs is downloaded now we need
to install the puppet agent service here
again this will also take some time
puppet servers installed
let me just clear this window
now that our puppet agent service is
installed we'll start the service so
i'll just type in the command for
starting the puppet agent service
okay
as you can see here ensure changed
stopped to running
so basically the service was not running
before and now it's changed to the
running state
and while we executed this command not
only did the service start running but
an ssl certificate was also created
so this certificate should have the host
name of this machine that's a puppet
client machine attached to it so let's
just check what the host name of our
machine is
that's
localhost.localdomain so our certificate
should have this attached to it so guys
the first time your client sends a
certificate the name of the certificate
itself is usually the host name of the
machine so our certificate's name should
be localhost.localdomain
we'll check this on our master system
and that's where we'll sign the
certificate to
so first we list out all the
certificates in our case since we have
just one client
and we just started the client we should
have technically just one certificate
and it will be so
yeah so this is our certificate
localhost dot local domain
we'll now sign the certificate
okay sorry about that just
need to remove these
brackets
here as you can see here the certificate
is signed
sign certificate request
so once the certificate is signed the
request for signing the certificate is
removed that's this line
now that a certificate is signed we can
begin to write a manifest so let's move
into a manifest folder and we'll create
a placeholder file
so we'll create a file called sample.pp
this is a sample file
we won't be writing anything in this
file as of now so we are just checking
here we are just creating this file and
then we'll go to our client machine and
just check the if we can access this
file from there
so now we'll move to our client machine
so let's test the connection
so as you can see here it says applied
catalog in 0.03 second so a catalog is
executed
on a client machine
now a catalog was just a placeholder
basically so the file that we created
which is sample.pp had no content and we
were just testing our client now let's
go back to our master server
put some content into this file and see
how the execution takes place
so we'll open our file sample.pp which
we created earlier in the vi editor
let's type our code here
so node and then within the brackets we
enter the hostname of our client machine
so this ensures that our manifest is
executed on this particular machine
now the apache service package on centos
is called the httpd
so this line that i just typed in is the
action it will ensure that the httpd
package is installed on your client
and that's it
so this is our code we'll save it
now let's go back to our client machine
and test it
so this is our client machine
and our catalogs applied on the client
so i just clear the screen now we'll
start the apache service
okay so how do we see if it's running we
just need to go to our browser
and at localhost you must have the
testing page for your apache
so we type localhost
enter
and yeah this is the testing page for
apache so as you can see we have
successfully used puppet to install the
apache service on our puppet client and
this is the end of our demo so let's
have a look at companies that are using
puppet today there are a number of
companies that have adopted puppet as a
way to manage their infrastructure so
companies that are using puppy today
include spotify google att so why are
these companies choosing to use puppet
as their main configuration management
tool the answer can be seen if we look
at a specific company staples so staples
chose to take and use puppet for their
configuration management tool and use it
within their own private cloud the
results were dramatic the amount of time
that the it organization was able to
save in deploying and managing their
infrastructure through using puppets
enabled them to open up time to allow to
experiment with other and new projects
and assignments a real tangible benefit
to a company so let's look at how you
write a manifest in puppet so so
manifests are designed for writing out
in code how you would configure a
specific node in your server environment
the manifests are compiled into catalogs
which are then executed on the client
each of the manifests are written in the
language of ruby with a dot pp extension
now if we step through the five key
steps for writing a manifest they are
one create your manifest and that is
written by the system administrator two
compile your manifest is compiled into a
catalog three deploy the catalog is then
deployed onto the clients four execute
the catalogs are run on the client by
the agent and then five end clients are
configured to a specific and desired
state if we actually look into how
manifest is written it's written with a
very common syntax if you've done any
work with ruby or really configuration
of systems in the past this may look
very familiar to you so we break out the
work that we have here you start off
with a package file or service as your
resource type and then you give it a
name and then you look at the features
that need to be said such as ip address
then you're actually looking to have a
command written such as present or start
the manifest can contain multiple
resource types if we continue to write
our manifest and puppet the default
keyword applies a manifest to all
clients so an example would be to create
a file path that creates a folder called
sample in a main folder called etc the
specified content is written into a file
that is then posted into that folder and
then we're going to say we want to be
able to trigger an apache service and
then ensure that that apache service is
installed on a node so we write the
manifest and we deploy it to a client
machine on that client machine a new
folder will be created with a file in
that folder and an apache server will be
installed you can do this to any machine
and you'll have exactly the same results
on those machines now let's have a look
at the puppet community
the puppet community is a rich community
of a lot of people officially there is
no count but counting the various
channels where people collaborate there
are a little over 2 900 committers to
github projects who are directly or
indirectly associated with puppet labs
there are
4893 modules on the official puppet
forge these include modules from the
puppet labs and also from open source
contributors to github
so that's nearly five thousand modules
of ready-made code available on the
puppet forge so before you write any
code for puppet you can check to see if
it's already been written by someone
now there's a mailing list which has
6588 participants apart from this on
slack overflow you have a big tag of
puppet labs and puppet which gives you a
list of only puppet questions that's a
good playground for you to interact with
people who are already using puppet
and who are contributing and helping
others now let's have a look at puppet
forge
so puppet forge is a github client for a
repository which is hosted by puppet
labs that has almost five thousand
modules of puppet code so these are both
puppet labs and community contributed
the best thing about this is that
they're easy to customize so when you
have a requirement for anything you're
doing with your infrastructure you can
just grab one of those five thousand
modules and then you can customize it
according to your needs one of the other
benefits is they have built-in tests so
they follow all of the best practices
now if you write your own module you
also have to write your own tests and
you have to spend extra time writing
best practice code
all of that has been taken care of and
you can just download any one of those
and customize it according to your needs
and you're good to go
so that's the benefit you get from such
a large community where people
contribute to the modules and the code
and share with the community the puppet
dsl puppet dsl is a puppet domain
specific language
it's the puppet's primary programming
language it's just like plain english
and you don't really need to be a
programmer to write code in it it's kind
of a sub child of ruby because it
approaches and uses is equal to and
greater than marks to define things so
it's very easy to learn
you can specify packages that you want
to install you can specify services to
be managed you can do things based on
the operating system you have so we'll
be writing a small puppet module which
will be using this puppet dsl
we will do that after we install the
puppet server and the client and then we
will write a simple puppet module to
show how to use the puppet dsl
let's have a look at the demo we are
going to do so you will be setting up
the machines using pseudo dns because we
want to have a resolvable dns because
only by having a resolvable dns can we
use puppet because puppet uses the ssl
certificates
now we'll be installing the puppet
server and the client will be signing
the certificates of the client on the
server side and then we'll proceed with
writing an ntp module which we'll be
using for installation of ntp on the
client and then we'll look at the puppet
programming language or dsl now we're
going to look at a demo here so we will
be setting up the machines we'll set up
a pseudo dns locally because puppet
requires a fully qualified domain name
in order to run since there is a
certificate communication taking place
here
we will be installing the puppet server
the puppet client will be signing the
certificate and finally we will write an
ntp module and make it run
[Music]
so now we will be starting a puppet
master and a client i have two machines
here one is the puppet master and the
second is the puppet client the puppet
master has got almost four gig of ram
and four v cpus which i can show you
here
because it's a ruby on rails application
it requires a lot of cpu and ram
for the client i don't need that much
ram and cpu so i've allotted one
gigabyte of ram and 1vcpu
i will start both of these machines and
find out the ip addresses right click
normal start
both of these machines are starting up
the puppet client has started up and the
first thing i'll do is log in using root
and red hat password and then i will
change the host name so i'll say vim etc
hostname
this will open a hostname file in a text
editor which is vim
then we'll do a dd which will delete
that existing hostname
and then i press the i for insert mode
and finally i'll type
the puppet hyphen client
which will be the host name of this
machine i'll save this file by doing
escape semicolon wq exclamation mark
and i'll reboot the machine
similarly going to the puppet master
i'll say root red hat
i'll open the hostname file
say dd then i'll say puppet hyphen
master
i'll save this file and reboot the
machine for the hostname change to take
effect the hostname change does not take
effect unless you reboot the machine
now both these machines are ready
i'm going to find out the ips and use
the mac terminal to log into these
so this is 23 and 21 so 23 is my server
and 21 is my client
i'll ssh to 23 first
now in order for the puppet master to be
installed i need a fully qualified
domain name here and a fake dns which
means a fully resolvable dns name so if
i do hostname here you see my host name
is puppetmaster in order to set up a
fake dns i need to go to the etc hosts
file
go to the end
then i say ip address host name local
then space host name
now this is one of the techniques which
makes the linux server believe that
there's a fully qualified domain name on
this machine
i'll save this
then i do a hostname hyphen f
you see it has a fully qualified domain
name now
so now we will be downloading the puppet
labs repository for ubuntu 16.04 which
is
xenial so i'll say curl hyphen zero
https
apt dot puppet labs
dot com
slash puppet labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dab
you can see there is a debian file which
has been downloaded here i will import
this using the dpkg command so i'll say
dpkg hyphen i puppet labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dap
and then i'll say apt-get update which
will update my app to package indexes on
this machine
and now i'll install the puppet server
so i'll say apt-get install
puppet hyphen
puppet server hyphen-y
so the puppet server is now installed
and we will be configuring the memory
allocation for the puppet server so i'll
say etc default puppet server so by
default
it has only
got two gigabyte allocated we'll give it
three gigabyte because it's jvm
i'll make this three and i'll change
this to three as well
and i'll save this file
i'll make sure the unconfigured firewall
allows port 8140 which is the puppet lab
puppet server port
the rules have been updated to allow
that i'll now start the puppet server so
i'll say a system ctl
start puppet server
it takes some time because it's jvm so
it takes a couple of minutes to start
the puppet server
so the puppet server is now running
i'll also enable it at boot time so i'll
say systemctl enable puppet to server
it will enable it boot time
now i also need to configure a fully
qualified domain name here so okay so
i'll do that by going into the hosts
file
i'll go to the end and i'll say
192.168.1.23 and then puppet
hyphen server dot local and then puppet
hyphen server
if i do a hostname hyphen f
put hyphen master.local because the
current hostname is
puppet hyphen master
so the trick is to have the
hostname.local in front of the ip
address in the host file
having a fully qualified domain name now
now we will go to the client setup the
client setup is almost the same with
just a small difference
the package which we need to install on
the client is puppet agent so we will go
to the client
so you see this has got a hostname
now we also need to set up the fake dns
here so i'll copy this hostname
open the host line
go to the end
write the ip address
and then dot local and then host name
again
so this will give me a fully qualified
domain name
so when i do a host name
it says puppet hive and client when i do
a host name hyphen f it says puppet
client local to install the puppet agent
on this machine i will need to download
the zenio packages so i'll say wget
https
apt.puppetlabs.com
puppet labs
hyphen release hyphen pc one hyphen
xenial.deb
i'll download this and then i'll say
dpkg hyphen i puppet labs iphone release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dap
so this is the repository package which
i'll be downloading here and then i'll
say apt-get
update hyphen y this will update my apt
caches on this machine
and now i'll finally install the puppet
agent
so i'll say apt-get install puppet agent
hyphen agent hyphen y
now the puppet agent is here i'll start
the puppet agent and i'll enable it at
boot time so i'll say system control
start puppet
then system control
enable puppet
now puppet is enabled now we have set up
the fully qualified domain name on the
client and the server but each of them
should know each other so we'll have to
do a cross certificate host mapping so
we will be copying the host file entry
of the client and adding it to the
server so i'll go to the etc hosts on
the server side go to the end paste it
there
okay and i'll be adding the entry of the
master on the client side
okay now both of the servers will
recognize each other now because one of
them has the host entry of the other
so if i do from the master ping puppet
iphone agent dot local
if i ping the agent from the server
hyphen client.local
it is able to ping it and if i ping the
master from the client
if i say ping puppet hyphenmaster.local
both of them will be able to ping each
other
now the next step would be to create a
certificate signing request so i'll go
to my to this directory which is opt
puppet labs puppet bin
and i'll say puppet agent hyphen t
hyphen knife and server
is equal to
and i'll give the fully qualified domain
name of the puppet master
then i'll say
hyphen f
when i do this it will create a
certificate signing request you see
now if i go to the server and i do an
opt
i'll check and see how many certificates
are pending to be signed
you'll see there's a puppet client
certificate which is pending to be
signed which is denoted by the absence
of a plus sign here
i'll be signing the certificate so i'll
say puppet search sign and then the name
so puppet hyphen client
dot local this will sign the
certificates
and when i go to the server on the
client side if i run the puppet agent
again
you see it's actually pulling down the
catalog as of now it has an empty
catalog
that says there is nothing
now we have configured the puppet agent
and the master now we will be taking a
module from puppet forge
puppet forge is a big collection of open
source modules which are free to use as
a first step we will be using a
ready-made module
and that would be a demonstration for
how to actually get up and running with
a module so search for apache module
here
this is the puppet labs apache module
i'll be using the puppet command line
puppet module install
this is the command for that but i will
make sure i run this command from the
puppet home so i'll go to the master
i'll go to etc puppet labs
code environments production
in this i'll do modules
now i will run it from the binary which
is present at the opt puppet labs bin
puppet
and then module install
puppet labs hyphen apache and then this
version so we are specifying the latest
version
and i'll hit enter when i press enter it
starts downloading from the forge api
so you see the module is downloaded in
addition to the dependencies so there is
concat std lib and apache
so now i'll go to a folder here which is
one level up called manifest so this is
the file here etc puppet labs code
environments production manifest
so in this there's a file which i'll be
creating called site.pp the site.pp will
specify and this is the main controller
of how the infrastructure looks in the
site pp
i specify
that i want
node to have the apache module included
i'll save this file and the only thing i
need to do now is
since all is set on the server side i
need to go to the client side and run
puppet agent it will automatically
download the apache module and compile
it and may then make sure the server is
in a state so
when i press enter we see a lot of
output it tries to configure apache on
this machine
and done now when i go to the front end
of this machine on this port i should be
able to see apaches default page so this
is apaches default page
so the module which we downloaded from
the forge was actually written in a way
that apache would be installed and run
at boot time so that is why it's running
here
and that is all we have from the uh
puppet module
and this concludes the demo today we're
going to go through a real tough battle
we're going to decide which is better
for your operations environment is it
chef puppet antipole or salt stank all
four are gonna go head to head so let's
go through the scenario of why you'd
want to use these tools so let's meet
tim he's our system administrator and
tim is a happy camper putting and
working on all of the systems in his
network but what happens if a system
fails if there's a fire a server goes
down well tim knows exactly what to do
he can fix that fire really easily the
problems become really difficult for tim
however if multiple servers start
failing particularly when you have large
and expanding networks so this is why
tim really needs to have a configuration
management tool and we need to now
decide what would be the best tool for
him because configuration management
tools can help make tim look like a
superstar all he has to do is configure
the right codes that allows him to push
out the instructions on how to set up
each of the servers quickly effectively
and at scale all right let's go through
the tools and see which ones we can use
the tools that we're going to go through
are chef puppet and support and salt
stacks and we have videos on most of
these software and services that you can
go and view to get an overview or a deep
dive in how those products work so let's
go and get to know our contestants so
our first contestant is chef and chef is
a tool that allows you to configure very
large environments it allows you to
scale very effectively across the entire
ecosystem
and infrastructure chef is by default an
open source code
and one of the things that you find is a
consistent metaphor for the tools that
we recommend on simplylearn is to use
open source code the code itself is
actually written in language of ruby and
erlang and it's really designed for
heterogeneous infrastructures that are
looking for a mature solution the way
that chef works is that you write
recipes that are compiled into cookbooks
and those cookbooks are the definition
of how you would set up a node and a
node is a selection of servers that you
have configured in a specific way so for
instance you may have apache linux
servers running or you may have a my sql
server running or you may have a python
server running and chef is able to
communicate back and forth between the
nodes to understand what nodes are being
impacted and would need to have
instructions sent out to them to correct
that impact you can also send
instructions from the server to the
nodes to make a significant update or a
minor update so there's great
communication going back and forth if we
look at the pros and cons the pros for
chef is that there is a significant
following for chef and that has resulted
in a very large collection of recipes
that allow you to be able to quickly
stand up environments there's no need
for you to have to learn complex recipes
the first thing you should do is go out
and find the recipes that are available
it integrates with git really well and
provides for really good strong version
control some of the consoles are really
around the learning speed it takes to go
from beginner user with chef to being an
expert there is a considerable amount of
learning that has to take place and it's
compounded by having to learn ruby as
the programming language and the main
server itself doesn't really have a
whole lot of control it's really
dependent on the communication
throughout the whole network all right
let's look at our second contender
puppet and puppet is actually in many
ways very similar to chef there are some
differences but again puppet is designed
to be able to support very large
heterogeneous organization it is also
built with ruby and uses dsl for writing
manifests so there are some strong
similarities here to chef as with a chef
there is a master slave infrastructure
with puppet and you have a master server
that has the manifests that you put
together in a single catalog and those
catalogs are then pushed out to the
clients of an ssl connection some of the
pros with puppet is that as with chef
there is a really strong community
around puppies and there's just a great
amount of information and support that
you can get right out of the gate it is
a very well developed reporting
mechanism that makes it easier for you
as an administrator to be able to
understand your infrastructure one of
the cons is that you have to really be
good at learning ruby again as with chef
you know the more advanced tasks really
need to have those ruby skills and as
with chef the server also doesn't have
much control so let's look at our third
contender here ansible and so ansible is
slightly different it is the way the
ansible works is that it actually just
pushes out the instructions to the
server environment there isn't a client
server or master slave environment where
ansible would be communicating backwards
and forwards with its infrastructure it
is merely going to push that
instructions out the good news is that
the instructions are written in yaml and
yowell stands for yaml8 markup language
yaml is actually pretty easy to learn if
you know xml and xml is pretty easy if
you know xml you're going to get yamo
really well ansible does work very well
on environments where the focus is
getting servers up and running really
fast it's very very responsive and can
allow you to move quickly to get your
infrastructure up quick very fast and
we're talking seconds and minutes here
really really quick so again the way
that ansible works is that you put
together a playbook and an inventory or
you have a playbook so the way that
ansible works is that you have a
playbook in the playbook it then goes
against the inventory of servers and
will push out the instructions for that
playbook to those servers so some of the
pros that we have for ansible we don't
need to have an agent installed on the
remote nodes and servers it makes it
easier for the configuration yaml is
really easy to learn you can get up to
speed and get very proficient with yamo
quickly the actual performance once you
actually have your infrastructure up and
running is less than other tools that we
have on our list now i do have to add a
proviso this is a relative less it's
still very fast it's going to be a lot
faster than individuals manually
standing up servers but it's just not as
fast as some of the other tools that we
have on this list and yaml itself as a
language while it's easy to learn it's
not as powerful as ruby ruby will allow
you to do things that at an advanced
level that you can't do easily with the
ammo so let's look at our final
contender here sort stack so source
stack is a cli based tool it means that
you will have to get your command line
tools out or your terminal window out so
you can actually manage the entire
environment via salt sac the
instructions themselves are based on
python but you can actually write them
in yammer or dsl which is really
convenient and as a product it's really
designed for environments that want to
scale quickly and be very resilient
the way that sortstat works is that you
have a master environment that pushes
out the instructions to what they call
grains which is your network and so
let's step through some of the pros and
cons that we have here with saltstag so
sourcetech is very easy to use once it's
up and running it has a really good
reporting mechanism that makes your job
as an operator in your devops
environment much much easier the actual
setup though is a little bit tougher
than some of the other tools and and
it's getting easier with the newer
releases but it's just a little bit
tougher and related to that is that
solstack is fairly late in the game when
it comes to actually having a graphical
user interface for being able to create
and manage your environment other tools
such as ansible have actually had a ui
environment for quite some time all
right so we've gone through all four
tools let's see how they all stack up
next to each other so let the race begin
let's start with the first stage
architecture so the architecture for
most of our environments is a server
client environment so for chef puppet
and salt snack so very similar
architecture there the one exception is
ansible which is a client only solution
so you're pushing out the instructions
from a server and pushing them out into
your network and there isn't a client
environment that there isn't a two-way
communication back to that main client
for what's actually happening in your
network so let's talk about the next
stage ease of setup so we look at the
four tools there is one tool that really
stands out for ease of setup and that is
ansible it is going to be the easiest
tool for you to set up and if you're new
to having these types of tools in your
environment you may want to start with
ansible just to try out and see how easy
it is to create automated configuration
before looking at other tools now and so
with that said chef puppet and sock
aren't that hard to set up either and
you'll find there's actually some great
instructions on how to do that setup in
the online community let's talk about
the languages that you can use in your
configuration so we have two different
types of language with both chef and
ansible being procedural in that they
actually specify at how you actually
supposed to do the task in your
instructions with puppet and sword stack
it's decorative where you specify only
what to do in the instructions let's
talk about scalability which tools scale
the most effectively and as you can
imagine all of these tools are designed
for scalability that is the driver for
these kind of tools you want them to be
able to scale to massive organizations
what do the management tools look like
for our four contenders so again we have
a two-way split with ansible and salt
stack of management tools are really
easy to use you're going to love using
them they're just fantastic to use with
puppet and chef the management tools are
much harder to learn and they do require
that you learn some either the puppet
dsl or the ruby dsl to be able to be a
true master in that environment but what
does interoperability look like again as
you'd imagine with the similar to
scalability interoperability with these
products is very high in all four cases
now let's talk about cloud availability
this is increasingly becoming more
important for organizations as they move
rapidly onto cloud services well both
ansible and sword stack have a big fail
here neither of them are available in
the most popular cloud environments and
puppet and chev are actually available
in both amazon and azure now we've
actually just haven't had a chance to
update our chef link here but chef is
now available on azure as well as amazon
so what does communication look like
with all of our four tools so the
communication is slightly different with
them chef has its own knife tool and
whereas puppet uses ssl to secure
sockets layer and ansible and saltstack
use secure socket hashing and ssh as
their communication tool bottom line all
four tools are very secure in their
communication so who wins well here's
the reality all four tools are very good
and it's really dependent on your
capabilities and the type of environment
that you're looking to manage that will
determine which of these four tools you
should use the tools themselves are open
source so go out and experiment with
them there's a lot of videos our team
has done a ton of videos on these tools
and so feel free to find out other tools
that we have then covered so you can
learn very quickly how to use them but
consider the requirements that you have
and consider the capabilities of your
team if you have ruby developers or you
have someone on your team that knows
ruby your ability to choose a broader
set of tools becomes much more
interesting if however you're new to
coding then you may want to consider
yaml-based tools again the final answer
is going to be up to you and we'll be
really interested on what your decision
is please post in the comments below
which tool you have decided to go with
and what are the challenges that you're
coming up with because we'll help answer
those challenges for you ansible
provides you with one of the easiest
ways to automate your application and i3
infrastructure on that note hi guys
welcome to this complete ansible
tutorial by simply learn in this video
we'll be covering some of the most
important concepts relating to the
devops tool ansible we'll take you
through how you can install ansible and
how you can use the tool to automate
your processes first we have anjali to
tell us how to install ansible on your
system a very warm welcome to all our
viewers i'm anjali from simply learn and
today i'll be showing you how you can
install the configuration management
tool ansible so let's have a brief about
why one would use ansible and what
exactly is ansible so if you consider
the case of an organization it has a
very large infrastructure which means it
has more than probably hundreds of
systems and giving one or even a small
team of people the responsibility to
configure all these systems makes their
work really tough repetitive and as you
know manual work is always prone to
errors so ansible is a tool which can
automate the configuration of all these
systems with ansible a small team of
system administrators can write simple
code in yaml and these codes are
deployed onto the hundreds and thousands
of servers which configures them to the
desired states so ansible automates
configuration management that is
configuring your systems it automates
orchestration which means it brings
together a number of applications and
decides an order in which these are
executed and it also automates
deployment of the applications now that
we know what ansible does let's move on
to the installation of ansible so here
is my oracle vm virtualbox manager i'll
be using two systems there's the node
system which is basically my client
system and there's a server system or
the master system so let's begin at our
server system
so this is my master system guys so the
first thing we do is we download our
ansible tool
so one thing we must remember with
ansible is that unlike
chef or puppet ansible is a push type of
configuration management tool so what
this means is that the entire control
here lies with your master or your
server system this is where you write
your configuration files and these are
also responsible for pushing these
configuration files onto your node or
client system as and when required
creates our ansible tool is installed
now we need to open an ansible host file
and there we'll specify the details of
our node or client machine
so this is an ansible host file as you
can see here the entire file is
commented but there's a certain syntax
that you'd observe for example here we
have a group name web servers under
which we have the ip addresses or
certain host name so this is about how
we'll be adding the details for our
client system first we need to give a
group name
under this group basically we add all
the clients which require a certain type
of configuration since we are using just
one node we'll give only the details for
that particular node first we need to
add the ip address of our client machine
so let's just go back to our client
machine
and this here is the ip address
192.168.2.11.
once you have typed in your ip address
give a space and then we'll specify the
user for our client machine
so all communications between the server
or the master system and the client or
the node system
takes place through ssh ssh basically
provides a secure channel for the
transfer of information
follow this up with your password
in my case it's the root's password
and that's it we are done so now we save
this file and go back to our terminal
so now that our hosts file is written
the next thing we do is we write our
playbook so playbook is the technical
term used for all the configuration
files that we write in ansible now
playbooks are written in yaml yaml is
extremely simple to both write and
understand it's in fact very close to
english
so now we'll write our playbook the
playbook or any code in yaml first
starts with three dashes this indicates
the beginning of your file next thing we
need to give a name to our playbook
so name
and i'm going to name my playbook sample
book
we next need to specify our host systems
which is basically the systems at which
the configuration file or the playbook
in our case will be executed so we'll be
executing this at the client machines
mentioned under the group ansible
servers so we had just one client
machine under it we'll still mention the
group name
we next need to specify the username
with which we'll be logging into our
client machine
which is root in my case
and become true specifies that you need
to become the root to execute this
playbook so becoming the roots called a
privilege escalation
next we need to specify our tasks so
these are basically the actions that the
playbook will be performing so you would
have noticed everything so far is
aligned that is name host remote user
become and task because these are at one
level now whatever comes under task will
be shifted slightly towards the right
although yaml is extremely simple to
understand and read both it's a little
tricky while writing because you need to
be very careful about the indentations
and the spacing
so my first task is install httpd which
is basically a apache server
so now my command yum and this will be
installing the httpd package
and the latest date of it will be
installed so that's our first task
now our second task would be running our
apache service
so name
run httpd
and the action which is service
will be performed on http hence the name
httpd
and state
must be started
now we come to our third task
so here we'll create a very simple web
page that will be hosted
so create content is the name of our
task
and the content that we are creating
here will basically be copied
to our node system at a particular file
location that we'll provide
our content will be congrats
and then we'll provide the destination
at which this file will be copied
so this is the default location for all
our html files
and that's it we are done writing our
playbook
just save this and go back to your
terminal
before we execute the playbook or push
the playbook onto our note system let's
check the syntax of our playbook so the
command for doing so is
and if everything is fine with your
playbook the output would be just your
playbook name so our syntax is perfectly
fine now we can push on the playbook to
our node or the client machine
and that's the syntax for doing so now
as your playbook is being sent over to
the client machine you can see that
first the facts are gathered that is the
current state of your client machine is
first fetched to check what all is to be
changed and what is already present so
the first thing is installing httpd so
our system already had httpd so it says
okay because this does not need to be
changed our next task was running httpd
now although our system had the apache
service it was not running so that is
one thing that was changed the next was
there was no content available so the
content was also added so two tasks were
changed and four things were okay now
everything seems fine and before you
move any forward it is very important
that you check this one line of
documentation provided by ansible you
have all kind of information available
here regarding which all tasks were
executed if your client machine was
reachable or unreachable and so on so
now that everything's fine here we can
move on to our node system
and we'll just go to our browser
so if our playbook has been executed
here what should happen is that the
httpd service must be in the running
state and the web page that we created
should be hosted so let's just type
localhost
and great everything's working fine so
our web page is displayed here so we
come to an end for our installation and
configuration video for the
configuration management tool ansible if
you have any doubts please post them in
the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you as soon as
possible thanks essentially now we have
matthew and anjali to take us through
how to work with ansible ansible today
as one of the key tools that you would
have within your devops environment
so the things that we're going to go
through today is we're going to cover
why you would want to use a product like
ansible what ansible really is and how
it's of value to you in your
organization the differences between
ansible and other products that are
similar to it on the market and what
makes ansible a compelling product and
they want to dig into the architecture
for ansible we're going to look at how
you would create a playbook how you'd
manage your inventory of your server
environments and then what is the actual
workings of ansible as a little extra
we're going to also throw in ansible
tower one of the secret source solutions
that you can use for improving the speed
and performance of how you create your
ansible environments and finally we're
going to go through a use case by
looking at hootsuite social media
management company and how they use
ansible to really improve the efficiency
within their organizations so let's jump
into this so the big question is why
ansible so you have to think of ansible
as another tool that you have within
your devops environment for helping
manage the service and this definitely
falls on the operations side of the dev
ops equation so if we look here we have
a picture of sam and like yourselves sam
is a system administrator and he is
responsible for maintaining the
infrastructure for all the different
servers within his company so some of
the servers that he may have that he has
to maintain could be web servers running
apache they could be database servers
running uh mysql and if you only have a
few servers then that's fairly easy to
maintain i mean if you have three web
servers and two database servers and
let's face it would we all love just to
have one or two servers to manage it
would be really easy to maintain the
trick however is as we start increasing
the number of servers and this is a
reality of the environments that we live
and operate in it becomes increasingly
difficult to create consistent setup of
different infrastructures such as web
servers and databases for the simple
reason that we're all human as if we had
to update and maintain all of those
servers by hand there's a good chance
that we would not set up each server
identically now this is where anspo
really comes to the rescue and helps you
become an efficient operations team
ansible like other system solutions such
as chef and puppet uses code that you
can write and describe the installation
and setup of your servers so you can
actually repeat it and deploy those
servers consistently into multiple areas
so now you don't have to have one person
redoing and re-following setup
procedures you just write one script and
then each script can be executed and
have a consistent environment so we've
gone through why you'd want to use
ansible let's step through what ansible
really is
so you know this is all great but you
know how do we actually use these tools
in our environment so
ansible is a tool that really allows you
to create and control three key areas
that you'd have within your operations
environment first of all there's it
automation so you can actually write
instructions that automate the it setup
that you would typically do manually in
the past the second is the configuration
and having consistent configuration
imagine setting up hundreds of apache
servers and being able to guarantee with
precision that each of those apache
servers is set up identically and then
finally you want to be able to automate
the deployment so that as you scale up
your server environment you can just
push out instructions that can deploy
automatically different servers the
bottom line is you want to be able to
speed up and make your operations team
more efficient so let's talk a little
bit about pull configuration and how it
works with ansible so there are two
different ways of being able to set up
uh different
environments for server farms uh one is
to have a key server that has all the
instructions on and then on each of the
servers that connect to that main master
server you would have a piece of
software known as a client installed on
each of those servers that would
communicate to the main master server
and then would periodically either
update or change the configuration of
the slave server this is known as a pull
configuration an alternative is a push
configuration and the push configuration
is slightly different the main
difference is as with a pull
configuration you have a master server
where you actually put up the
instructions but unlike the pull
configuration where you have a client
installed on each of the services with a
push configuration you actually have no
client installed on the remote servers
you simply are pushing out the
configuration to those servers and
forcing a restructure or a fresh clean
installation in that environment so
ansible is one of those second
environments where it's a push
configuration server and this contrasts
with other popular products like chef
and puppet which have a master slave
architecture with a master server
connecting with a client on a remote
slave environment where you would then
be pushing out the updates with ansible
you're pushing out the service and the
structure of the server to remote
hardware and you are just putting it
onto the hardware irrelevant of the
structure that's out there and there are
some significant advantages that you
have in that in that you're not having
to have the extra overhead weight of a
client installed on those remote servers
having to constantly communicate back to
the master environment so let's step
through the architecture that you would
have for an ansible environment
so when you're setting up an ansible
environment the first thing you want to
do is have a local machine and the local
machine is where you're going to have
all of your instruction and really the
power of the control that you'd be
pushing out to the remote server so the
local machine is where you're going to
be starting and doing all of your work
connected from the local machine are all
the different nodes pushing out the
different configurations that you would
set up on the local machine the
configurations that you would write and
you would write those in code within a
module so you do this on your local
machine for creating these modules and
each of these modules is actually
consistent playbooks the local machine
also has a second job and that job is to
manage the inventory of the nodes that
you have in your environment
the local machine is able to connect to
each of the different nodes that you
would have in your hardware network
through ssh clients so a secure client
let's dig into some of the different
elements within that architecture and
we're going to take a first look at
playbooks that you would write and
create for the ansible environments so
the core of ansible is the playbook this
is where you create the instructions
that you write to define the
architecture of your hardware so the
playbook is really just a set of
instructions that configure the
different nodes that you have and each
of those set of instructions is written
in a language called yammer and this is
a standard language used for
configuration server environments did
you know that yaml actually stands for
yaml8 markup language that's just a
little tidbit to hide behind your ear so
let's have a look on one of these
playbooks it looks like and here we have
a sample uh yaml script that we've
written so you start off your jammer
script with three dashes and that
indicates the start of a script and then
the script itself is actually consistent
of two distinct plays at the top we have
play one and below that we have play two
within each of those plays we define
which nodes are we targeting so here we
have a web server in the top play and in
the second play we have a database
server that we're targeting and then
within each of those server environments
we have the specific tasks that we're
looking to execute so let's step through
some of these tasks we have an install
apache task we have a start apache task
and we have an install my sequel task
and when we do that we can actually
execute a specific set of instructions
and those instructions can include
installing apache and then setting the
state of the apache environment or
starting the apache environment and
setting up and running the mysql
environment
so this really isn't too complicated and
that's the really good thing about
working with the ammo is it's really
designed to make it easy for you as an
operations lead to be able to configure
the environments that you want to
consistently create so let's take a step
back though we have two hosts we have
web server and database server where do
these names come from well this takes us
into our next stage in the second part
of working with ansible which is the
inventory management part of ansible so
the inventory part of ansible is where
we maintain the structure of our network
environment so what we do here is part
of the structure in creating different
nodes is we've had to create two
different nodes here we have a web
server node and a database server net
and under web server node we actually
have the names that were actually
pointing to specific machines within
that environment so now when we actually
write our scripts all we have to do is
refer to either web server or database
server and the different servers will
have the instructions from the yaml
script executed on them this makes it
really easy for you to be able to just
point to new services without having to
write out complex instructions so let's
have a look at how ansible actually
works in real world so the real world
environment with is that you'd have the
ansible software installed on a local
machine and then it connects to
different nodes within your network on
the local machine you'll have your first
your playbook which is the set of
instructions for how to set up the
remote nodes and then to identify how
you're going to connect to those nodes
you'll have an inventory we use secure
ssh connections to each of the servers
so we are encrypting the communication
to those servers we're able to grab some
basic facts on each server so we
understand how we can then push out the
playbook to each server and configure
that server remotely the end goal is to
have an environment that is consistent
so let's ask you a simple question
what are the major opportunities the
ansible has over chef and puppet
really like to hear your answers in the
comments below pop them in there and
we'll get back to you and really want to
hear how you feel that ansible is a
stronger product or maybe you think it's
a weaker product as it compares to other
similar products in the market here's
the bonus we're going to talk a little
bit about ansible tower so ansible tower
is an extra product that red hat created
that really kind of puts the cherry on
the top of the ice cream or is the icing
on your cake ansible by itself is a
command line tool however ansible tower
is a framework that was designed to
access ansible and through the ansible
tower framework we now have an easy to
use gui this really makes it easy for
non-developers to be able to create the
environment that they want to be able to
manage in their devops plan without
having to constantly work with the
command prompt window so instead of
opening up terminal window or command
window and writing out complex
instructions only in text you can now
use drag and drop and mouse click
actions to be able to create your
appropriate playbooks inventories and
pushes for your nerds all right so we
talked a lot about ansible let's take a
look at a specific company that's using
ansible today and in this example we're
going to look at hootsuite now hootsuite
if you not already use their products
and they have a great product hootsuite
is a social media management system they
are able to help with you managing your
pushes of social media content across
all of the popular social media
platforms they're able to provide the
analytics they're able to provide the
tools that marketing and sales teams can
use to be able to assess a sentiment
analysis of the messages that are being
pushed out really grateful and very
popular but part of their popularity
drove a specific problem straight to
hootsuite the challenge they had at
hootsuite is that they had to constantly
go back and rebuild their server
environment and they couldn't do this
continuously and be consistent there was
no standard documentation and they had
to rely on your memory to be able to do
this consistently imagine how complex
this could get as you're scaling up with
a popular product that now has tens of
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
users this is where ansible what came in
and really helped the folks over at
hootsuite today the devops team at
hootsuite write out playbooks that have
specific instructions that define the
architecture and structure of their
hardware nodes and environments and are
able to do that as a standard product
instead of it being a problem in scaling
up their environment they now are able
to rebuild and create new servers in a
matter of
seconds
the bottom line is ansible has been able
to provide hootsuite with it automation
consistent configuration and free up
time from the operations team so that
instead of managing servers they're able
to provide additional new value to the
company a very warm welcome to all our
viewers i'm anjali from simply learn and
today i'll be taking you through a
tutorial on ansible so ansible is
currently the most trending and popular
configuration management tool and it's
used mostly under the devops approach
so what will you be learning today you
learn why you should use ansible what
exactly is ansible the ansible
architecture how ansible works the
various benefits of ansible and finally
we'll have a demo on the installation of
apache or the httpd package on our
client systems we'll also be hosting a
very simple web page and during this
demo i'll also show you how you can
write a very simple playbook in yemen
and your inventory file
so let's begin why should you use
ansible let's consider a scenario of an
organization where sam is a system
administrator
sam is responsible for the company's
infrastructure a company's
infrastructure basically consists of all
its systems this could include your web
servers your database servers the
various repositories and so on so as a
system administrator sam needs to ensure
that all the systems are running the
updated versions of the software now
when you consider a handful of systems
this seems like a pretty simple task sam
can simply go from system to system and
perform the configurations required but
that is not the case with an
organization is it an organization has a
very large infrastructure it could have
hundreds and thousands of systems so
here is where sam's work gets really
difficult not only does it get tougher
sam has to move from system to system
performing the same task over and over
again this makes sam bored not just that
repeating the same task leaves no space
for innovation and without any ideas or
innovation how does the system grow and
the worst of it all is manual labor is
prone to errors so what does sam do well
here is where ansible comes in use with
ansible sam can write simple codes that
are deployed onto all the systems and
configure them to the correct states
so now that we know why we should use
ansible let's look at what exactly is
ansible ansible is an i.t engine that
automates the following tasks so first
we have orchestration orchestration
basically means bringing together of
multiple applications and ensuring an
order in which these are executed so for
example if you consider a web page that
you require to host this webpage stores
all its values that it takes from the
user into a database so the first thing
you must do is ensure that the system
has a database manager and only then do
you host your web page so this kind of
an order is very crucial to ensure that
things work right
next ansible automates configuration
management so configuration management
simply means that all the systems are
maintained at a consistent desired state
other tools that automate configuration
management include puppet and chef
and finally ansible automates deployment
deployment simply means the deploying of
application onto your servers of
different environments so if you have to
deploy an application on 10 systems with
different environments you don't have to
manually do this anymore because ansible
automates it for you in fact ansible can
also ensure that these applications or
the code are deployed at a certain time
or after regular intervals
now that we know what exactly ansible is
let's look at ansible's architecture
ansible has two main components you have
the local machine and you have your node
or the client machine so the local
machine is where the system
administrator sits he or she installs
ansible here and on the other end you
have your node or the client systems so
in case of ansible there's no supporting
software installed here these are just
the systems that require to be
configured and they are completely
controlled by the local machine at your
local machine you also have a module a
module is a collection of your
configuration files and in case of
ansible these configuration files are
called playbooks playbooks are written
in yaml yaml stands for yaml ain't a
markup language and it is honestly the
easiest language to understand and learn
since it's so close to english we also
have the inventory the inventory is a
file where you have all your nodes that
require configuration mentioned and
based on the kind of configuration they
require they are also grouped together
so later in the demo we'll have a look
at how the playbook and the inventory is
written and that will probably make it
clearer so of course a local machine
needs to communicate with the client and
how is this done this is done through
ssh ssh is your secure shell which
basically provides a protected
communication in an unprotected
environment
okay so we saw the various components of
ansible now how does ansible exactly
work you have your local machine on one
end this is where you install ansible if
you have gone through any previous
material on ansible you would have come
across the term agentless often being
associated with the stool so this is
what agentless means you're installing
ansible only on your local machine and
there's no supporting software or plugin
being installed on your clients this
means that you have note agent on the
other end the local machine has complete
control and hence the term agentless
another term that you would come across
with ansible is push configuration so
since the local machine has complete
control here it pushes the playbooks
onto the notes and thus it's called a
push configuration tool now the
playbooks and the inventory are written
at the local machine and the local
machine connects with the nodes through
the ssh client this step here is
optional but it's always recommended to
do so it's where the facts are collected
so facts are basically the current state
of the node now all this is collected
from the node and sent to the local
machine so when the playbook is executed
the task mentioned in the playbook is
compared against the current status of
the note and only the changes that are
required to be made further are made and
once the playbooks are executed your
notes are configured to the desired
states so as i mentioned before ansible
is currently the most trending tool in
the market under the configuration
management umbrella so let's have a look
at the various benefits of ansible which
gives it this position well ansible is
agentless it's efficient it's flexible
simple important and provides automated
reporting how does it do all this let's
have a look at that agentless as i
already mentioned before you require no
supporting software or plugin installed
on your node or the client system so the
master has complete control and
automatically this means that ansible is
more efficient because now we have more
space in our client node systems for
other resources and we can get ansible
up and running real quick ansible is
also flexible so an infrastructure is
prone to change very often and ansible
takes no amount of time to adjust to
these changes ansible cannot get any
simpler with your playbooks written in a
language such as yaml which is as close
to english as you can possibly get
air important basically means that if
you have a playbook which needs to be
run n number of systems it would have
the same effect on all of these systems
without any side effect and finally we
have automated reporting so in case of
ansible your playbook has a number of
tasks and all these stars are named so
whenever you run or execute your
playbook it gives a report on which task
ran successfully which failed which
clients were not reachable and so on all
this information is very crucial when
you're dealing with a very large
infrastructure and finally we reach the
most exciting part of our tutorial the
hands-on before we move on to the actual
hands-on let me just brief you through
what exactly we'll be doing so i'll be
hosting two virtual boxes both centos 7
operating systems one would be my local
machine and other my node or the client
machine so on my local machine first
i'll install ansible we then write the
inventory and the playbook and then
simply deploy this playbook on the
client machine there's just one thing
that we need to do is that we need to
check if the configurations that we
mentioned in our playbook are made right
so we'll now begin our demo this is my
oracle virtualbox here i have my master
system which is the local machine and
this is the client machine so let's have
a look at these two machines this is my
client machine the terminals open right
now so the client machine terminal has a
black background with white text and the
master machine terminal has a white
background with black text just so you
can differentiate between the two so
we'll start at the master machine the
first thing to do is we need to install
our ansible so yum install
ansible hyphen y is the command to do so
so this might take some time
yeah so ansible is installed the next
step we go to our hosts file so host
file here is basically the inventory
it's where you'll specify all your nodes
in our case we just have one node
that's the path to your host file
as you'll see everything here is
commented so just type in the group for
your client notes
so i'm going to name it ansible clients
[Music]
and here we need to type the ip address
of a client machine so my client
machine's ip address is 192.168.2.127
so before you come to this it's advised
that you check the ip address on your
client machine the simple command for
that is ifconfig now once you type the
ip address put a space and here we need
to mention the username and the password
for our client
so i'll be logging in as the root user
so this is the password
and then the user
which is root in my case
that's it now you can save this file
just clear the screen
next we move on to our playbook we need
to write the playbook
so the extension for our playbook is yml
which stands for yaman
and as you can see here i have already
written my playbook but i'll just
explain to you how this is done
so a yaml file always begins with three
dashes this indicates the start of your
yaml file
now the first thing is you need to give
a name to the entire playbook
so i have named it sample book
host is basically where this would be
executed so as we saw earlier in our
inventory i mentioned clients group name
as ansible clients so we use the same
name here
the remote user is the user you'll be
using at your client so in my case
that's root and become true is basically
to indicate that you need to set your
privileges at root so that's called a
privilege escalation
now a playbook consists of tasks
so we have here three tasks the first
task i've named it to install httpd so
what we're doing here is we are
installing our httpd package which is
basically the apache server and we're
installing the most latest version of it
hence the state value is latest the next
task is running httpd so for the service
the name is httpd because that's the
service we need to start running and the
state is started our next task is
creating content so this is the part
where we are creating our web page
so copy because this is the file that
will be created at the client
the content will be welcome
and the destination of the file will be
www html index.html as you know this is
like a default path that we use to store
all our html files
now as you can see here there's quite a
lot of indentation and when it comes to
yaml although it's very simple to write
and very easy to read
the indentation is very crucial
so the first dash here represents the
highest stage that is the name of the
playbook and all the dashes under task
are slightly shifted towards the right
so if you have two dashes at the same
location they basically mean that they
are siblings so the priority would be
the same
so to ensure that all your tasks are
coming under the tasks label make sure
they are not directly under name
so yeah that's pretty much it so when
you write your yaml file the language is
pretty simple very readable indentations
absolutely necessary make sure all your
spaces are correctly placed we can now
save this file
next thing we need to check if the
syntax of our yaml file is absolutely
right because that's very crucial
so the command to check the syntax of
the yaml file is ansible
playbook
the name of your playbook
syntax check
so we have no syntax errors which is why
the only output you receive is
sample.yml which is the name of your
playbook
so our playbook is ready to be executed
the command to execute the playbook is
ansible playbook
and the name of your playbook
so our playbooks executed as you can see
here gathering facts that's where all
the facts of the note that the present
state of the note is collected and sent
to the local machine so it's basically
to check that if the configuration
changes that we are about to make is
already made
so it's not made we do not have the
httpd package installed on our node so
this is the first change that's made
also if it's not installed of course
it's not running that's the second
change that's made so it's put into the
running state
and a final task which is create content
is under the okay state this means that
the contents already present in the
client machine so i made it this way so
that you can actually see the different
states that's present
so over here we have okay four so four
things are all fine the facts are
gathered two things are changed and one
is already present two changes are made
zero clients are unreachable and zero
tasks have failed so this is the
documentation that i was referring to
previously that ansible provides
automatically
and is very useful as you can see
so our next step we need to just check
on our client machine if all the changes
that we desired are made so let's move
to our client
so this is my client machine so to check
this since we are installing the httpd
package and hosting a web page the best
way to do it
is open your browser
and type in
localhost
so there you go your apache server is
installed and your web page is hosted
hey there are you exploring test
automation are you wondering why
everyone is talking about selenium
around you do you want to know what
selenium is all about if yes this is the
video for you simply learn brings to you
a very simple tutorial on selenium what
should you expect from this video before
you start understanding any automation
tool it's good to look back into what
manual testing is all about what are its
challenges and how automation tool
overcomes these challenges challenges
are always overcome by inventing
something new so let's see how selenium
came into existence and how did it
evolve to become one of the most popular
web application automation tool selenium
suite of tools selenium is not a single
tool it has multiple components so we
will look into each of them and as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
looking at what the advantages are and
the limitations of selenium and how do
we work around those limitations all
right so let's get started manual
testing a definition if you can say a
manual testing involves the physical
execution of test cases against various
applications and to do what to detect
bugs and errors in your product it is
one of the primitive methods of testing
a software this was the only method
which we knew of earlier it is execution
of test cases without using any
automation tools it does not require the
knowledge of a testing tool obviously
because everything is done manually also
you can practically test any application
since you are doing a manual testing so
let's take an example so say we have a
use case you are testing say a facebook
application and in facebook application
let's let's open the facebook
application and say create an account
this is your web page which is under
test now now as a tester what would you
do you would write multiple test cases
to test each of the functionalities on
this page you will use multiple data
sets to test each of these fields like
the first name the surname mobile number
or the new password and you will also
test multiple links what are the
different links on this page like say
forgotten account or create a new page
so these are the multiple links
available on the web pages also you look
at each and every element of the web
page like your radio buttons like your
drop down list apart from this you would
do an accessibility testing you would do
a performance testing for this page or
say a response time after you say click
on the login button literally you can do
any type of tests manually once you have
this test cases ready what do you do you
start executing this test cases one by
one you will find bugs your developers
are going to fix them and you will need
to rerun all these test cases one by one
again until all the bugs are fixed and
your application is ready to ship now if
one has to run test cases with hundreds
of transactions or the data sets and
repeat them can you imagine the amount
of effort required in that now that
brings us to the first demerit of the
manual testing manual testing is a very
time consuming process and it is very
boring also it is very highly error
prone why because it is done annually
and human mistakes are bound to happen
since it's a manual executions testers
presence is required all the time one is
to keep doing manual steps step by step
again all the time he also has to create
manual reports
group them format them so that we get
good looking reports also send this
reports manually to all stakeholders
then collection of logs from various
machines where you have run your test
consolidating all of them creating
repositories and maintaining them and
again since it's all as a manual process
there is a high chance of creating
manual errors there scope of manual
testing is limited for example let's say
regression testing ideally you would
want to run all the test cases which you
have written but since it's a manual
process you would not have the luxury of
time to execute all of them and hence
you will pick and choose your test cases
to execute that way you are limiting the
scope of testing also working with large
amount of data manually is impractical
which could be the need of your
application what about performance
testing you want to collect metrics on
various performance measures as a part
of your performance testing you want to
simulate multiple loads on application
under test and hence manually performing
these kind of tests is not feasible and
to top it all up say if you are working
in an agile model where code is being
churned out by developers testers are
building their test and they are
executing them as and when the bills are
available for testing and this happens
iteratively and hence you will need to
run this test multiple times during your
development cycle and doing this
manually definitely becomes very tedious
and burning and is this the effective
way of doing it not at all so what do we
do we automate it so this tells us why
we automate one for faster execution two
to be less error prone and three the
main reason is to help frequent
execution of our test so there are many
tools available in the market today for
automation one such tool is selenium
birth of selenium much before selenium
there were various tools in the market
like say rft and qtp just to name a few
popular ones selenium was introduced by
gentleman called jason huggins way back
in 2004. he was an engineer at
thoughtworks and he was working on a web
application which needed frequent
testing he realized the inefficiency in
manually testing this web application
repeatedly so what he did was he wrote a
javascript program that automatically
controlled the browser actions and he
named it as javascript test runner later
he made this open source and this was
renamed as the selenium core and this is
how selenium came into existence and
since then selenium has become one of
the most powerful tool for testing web
applications so how does selenium help
so we saw all the demerits of manual
testing so we can say by automation of
test cases one selenium helps in speedy
execution of test cases since manual
execution is avoided the results are
more accurate no human errors since your
test cases are automated human resources
required to execute automated test cases
is far less than manual testing because
of that there is a lesser investment in
human resources it saves time and you
know time is money it's cost effective
as selenium is an open source it is
available free of cost early time to
market since you save effort and time on
manual execution your clients will be
merrier as you would be able to ship
your product pretty fast lastly since
your test cases are automated you can
rerun them any point of time and as many
times as required so if this tool offers
so many benefits we definitely want to
know more detail about what selenium is
selenium enables us to test web
applications on all kind of browsers
like internet explorer chrome firefox
safari edge opera and even the headless
browser selenium is an open source and
it is platform independent the biggest
reason why people are preferring this
tool is because it is free of cost and
the qtp and the rft which we talked
about are chargeable selenium is a set
of tools and libraries to facilitate the
automation of web application as i said
it is not a single tool it has multiple
components which we'll be seeing in
detail in some time and all these tools
together help us test the web
application you can run selenium scripts
on any platform it is platform
independent why because it is primarily
developed in javascript it's very common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming knowledge so selenium has
this record and replayback tool called
the selenium id which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
you can replay the script back however
this is mainly used for demo purposes
only because selenium is such a powerful
tool that you should be able to take
full advantage of all its features
selenium provides support for different
programming languages like java python
c-sharp ruby so you can write your test
scripts in any language you like one
need not know in-depth or advanced
knowledge of these languages also
selenium supports different operating
systems it has supports for windows macs
linux even ubuntu as well so you can run
your selenium test on any platform of
your choice and hence selenium is the
most popular and widely used automation
tools for automating your web
applications selenium set of tools so
let's go a little more deeper into
selenium as i said selenium is not a
single tool it is a suite of tools so
let's look at some of the major
components or the tools in selenium and
what they have to offer so selenium has
four major components one selenium id
it's the most simplest tool in the suite
of selenium it is integrated development
environment earlier selenium ide was
available only as a firefox plugin and
it offered a simple record and playback
functionality it is a very simple to use
tool but it's mainly used for
prototyping and not used for creating
automation in the real-time projects
because it has its own limitations like
any other record and replay tool
selenium rc this is nothing but selenium
remote control it is used to write web
application test in different
programming language what it does it it
basically interacts with the browser
with the help of something called as rc
server and how it interacts it's uses a
simple http postgate request for
communication this was also called as
selenium 1.0 version but it got
deprecated in selenium 2.0 version and
was completely removed in 3.0 and it was
replaced by webdriver and we will see in
detail as why this happened selenium
webdriver this is the most important
component in the selenium suite it is a
programming interface to create and
execute text test cases it is obviously
the successor of the selenium rc which
we talked about because of certain
drawbacks which rc had so what webdriver
does is it interacts with the browsers
directly unlike rc where the rc required
a server to interact with the browser
and the last component is the selenium
grid so selenium grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time so it helps
you in achieving parallel execution
since the selenium web driver with you
can only do sequential execution grid is
what comes into picture where you can do
your parallel execution and why is
parallel execution important because in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment and that is what
grid helps you to achieve so all this
together helps us to create robust web
application test automation and we will
go in detail about each of this
components so before that let's look at
the history of selenium version so what
did selenium version comprised of it had
an ide rc and grid and as i said earlier
there were some disadvantages of using
rc so rc was on its path of deprecation
and web driver was taking its path so if
you look at selenium 2 version it had an
earlier version of webdriver and also
the rc so they coexisted from 3. onwards
rc was completely remote and web driver
took its place there is also a 4 dot
version around the corner and it has
more features and enhancement some some
of the features which are talked about
are w3c webdriver standardization
improved id and improved grid now let's
look at each of the components in the
selenium suite selenium ide is the most
simplest tool in the suite of selenium
it is nothing but an integrated
development environment for creating
your automation scripts it has a record
and playback functionality and is a very
simple and easy to use too it is
available as a firefox plugin and a
chrome extension so you can use either
of this browser to record your test
scripts it's a very simple user
interface using which you can create
your scripts that interact with your
browser the commands created in the
scripts are called selenes commands and
they can be exported to the supported
programming language and hence this code
can be reused however this is mainly
used for prototyping and not used for
creating automation for your real-time
projects why because of its own
limitation which any other record and
replay tool has so a bit history of
selenium id so earlier selenium id was
only a firefox extension so we saw that
ide was available since the selenium
version one selenium id died with the
firefox version 55 that was id was
stopped supporting from 55 version
onwards and this was around 2017 time
frame however very recently all new
brand selenium id has been launched by
apply tools and also they have made it a
cross browser so you can install the
extension on chrome as well as as an
add-on on firefox browser so they
completely revamped this ide code and
now they have made it available on the
github under the apache 2.0 license and
for the demos today we'll be looking at
the new id now with this new ide also
comes a good amount of features
reusability of test cases better
debugger and most importantly it
supports parallel test case execution so
they have introduced a utility called
selenium side runner that allows you to
run your test cases on any browser so
you can create your automation using
idec on chrome or firefox but through
command prompt using your site runner
you can execute this test cases on any
browser thus by achieving your cross
browser testing control flow statement
so initially in the previous versions of
idea there were control flow statements
available however one had to install a
plugin to use them but now it is made
available out of box and what are these
control flow statements these are
nothing but your if else conditions the
while loops the switch case and so on it
also has an improved locator
functionality that means it provides a
failover mechanism for locating elements
on your web page so let's look at how
this id looks and how do we install it
and start working on that so for that
let me take you to my browser so say
let's go to the firefox browser so on
this browser i already have the id
installed so when you already have an id
installed you will see an icon here that
says selenium id and how do you install
this you simply need to go to your
firefox add-ons here where it says find
more extension so just type in
selenium id and search for this
extension so in the search results you
see the selenium id just click on that
and now since i've already installed
here it says remove otherwise for you it
is going to give you an add button here
just click on the add button it will
install this extension once it is
installed you should be able to see this
selenium id icon here okay so now let's
go ahead and launch this id so when i
click on that it is going to show me a
welcome page where it's going to give me
few options the first option is it says
record a new test case in a new project
so straight away if you choose this
option you can start recording a test
case in which case it's going to just
create a default project for you which
you can save it later then open an
existing project so you can open if you
already have a saved project create a
new project and close so i already have
an existing project with me for the demo
purpose so i'll go ahead and open that
so i'll say open existing project and i
have created a simple script what the
script does is it logs me into the
facebook using a dummy user mail your
sorry username and password that's all
it's very simple script with few lines
and this is what it's going to do so
what we will simply do is we'll just run
the script and see how it works for that
i am just going to reduce the test
execution speed so that you should be
able to see every step of execution here
all right so what i'll do now here is
i'll just adjust this window and i'll
just simply say run current test all
right so i'll just get this side by side
so that you should be able to see what
exactly the script is doing okay so now
you are able to see both the windows
okay so now it's going to type in your
user email here there you go and now it
will enter the password and it has
clicked on the login button so it's
going to take a while to say login and
since these are the dummy ids it is you
are not able to log in here and you are
going to see this error window fine that
is what is the expected output here now
on the id if you look here after i
execute the test case every statement or
every command which i have used here is
colored coded in green so that means
this particular step was executed
successfully and then here in the log
window it will give you a complete log
of this test case right from the first
step till the end and your end result is
it says fb login which is my test case
name completed successfully let's look
at few components of this id the first
one is the menu bar so let's go to our
id all right so the menu bar is right
here on the top so here is your project
name so either you can add a new project
here or rename your project so since we
already have this project which is named
as facebook and then on the right you
have options to create a new project
open an existing project or save the
current project and then comes on
toolbar so using the options in this
toolbar you can control the execution of
your test cases so first one here is the
recording button so this is what you use
when you start recording your script and
then on the left you have two options
here to run your test cases the first
one is run all tests so in case you have
multiple test cases written here you can
execute them one by one sequentially by
using this run all test else what you
can do is if you just want to run your
current test this is what you would use
then id has this debugger option which
you can use to do a step execution so
say for example now whenever i run the
script it's going to execute each and
every command here sequentially so
instead if i just select the first
command and say do step execution all
right so what it does is the moment it
finishes the first command which is
opening of facebook right i think which
is already done here yeah all right so
once this is done it is going to wait
immediately on the second command and it
says pause debugger so from here you can
do whatever you would like to do in case
you want to change the command here you
can do that you can pause your execution
you can resume your execution here right
you can even completely stop your test
execution or you can just select this to
run the rest of the test case so if we
say run the test case what it is going
to do is just going to simply go ahead
and complete the com complete the test
case now there is another option here
which is you see the timer there which
says test execution speed so to execute
your test cases in the speed you want
say whenever you're developing an
automation script right and say you want
to give a demo so you need to control
the speed sometimes so that the viewer
is able to exactly see all the steps
which is being performed and this gives
you an option to control that complete
execution right so do you see the
grading here so we have somewhere from
fast to completely slow execution so the
previous demo which i showed was i
control the speed and then i executed it
so that we could see every command how
it is being executed all right so what's
the next this is called as an address
bar so whichever whenever whenever you
enter an url here that is where you want
to conduct your test and another thing
what it does is it keeps a history of
all the urls which have used for running
your test then here is where your script
is recorded so each and every
instruction is displayed here in the
order in which you have recorded the
script and then if you look here you
have something called as login reference
so now log is an area where it records
each and every step of your command as
in when they get executed right so if
you see here it says open https
facebook.com and ok so that means this
command was executed successfully and
after the complete test case is done it
gives you whether the test case passed
or failed so in case there is a failure
you will immediately see this test case
is filled in red color also there is
something called as reference here for
example say if i click on any of this
command the reference tab what it is
going to show me is the details of this
command which i have used in the script
it gives you the details of the command
as well as what the arguments have been
used or how how is that you need to be
using this particular command okay so
now what we'll do is let's go ahead and
write a simple script using this id so
with this you'll get an idea how do we
actually record scripts in id so for
that i have a use case here a very very
simple use case so what we will do is we
will open amazon.in then we'll search
simply search for say product iphone and
once we get that search page where all
your iphones are displayed we will just
do an asset on the title of the page
simple all right so let's do that so
first thing what i need is an url okay
so first let me go to my firefox browser
here and say amazon.com so why i'm doing
this just to simply get the right url
absolute url path here and so that i
don't make any mistakes while typing in
the url okay so i got this so let me
close all this windows i don't need any
of this let's minimize this all right so
here what i'll do in the tests tab i'll
say add a new test and name this test as
amazon search done i'll say add now i'll
enter this url which i just copied it
from my browser okay and then i'll just
say start recording so what it
did was since i've entered the url in
this address box it just opened the
amazon dot in url now let's do our test
case so in my test case what i said was
i want to search for iphone once i have
this i'm just going to click on my
search button so now this gives me a
list of all iphones and then i said i
want to add an assertion on the title of
this page so for me to do that what id
gives me an option is i have to just
right click anywhere on this page and
you'll see the selenium id options here
so in this i will select
assert title and then i will close this
browser so that kind of completes my
test case so now take a look at all the
steps which is created for me so it says
open slash because i've already provided
the url here so either you can replace
it with your regular url or you can just
leave it as it is so what i will do
since this is going to be a proper
script and i might be using this to run
it from a command prompt also so i'll
just replace this target with the actual
url and then what it is doing it is
setting a window size then there are
whatever i did on that particular url on
that website it has recorded all the
steps for me so this is where it says
type into this particular text box which
is my search box and what did it type
iphone this was the value which i
entered now there was one more feature
which i told you in this new ide which
had which i said it has a failover
mechanism for your locating techniques
now that is what this is now if you look
here this id is equal to tab search
textbook this is nothing but that search
box where we entered the text iphone and
it has certain identification through
which this ide identifies that web
element and that has multiple options to
select that particular search box so
right now what it has used is id is
equal to two tab search box however if
you know the different locating
techniques you will be able to see here
that it has other techniques also which
it has identified like the name and the
css and the xpath so how does this help
in failovers say tomorrow if amazon.in
website changes the id of this element
right you are not going to come and
rewrite the scripts again instead by
using the same script what it will do is
if this particular id fails if it is
unable to find the element using the
first locator which is the id it simply
moves to the next available ones and it
tries to search for that element until
one of these becomes true that is what
was the failure mechanism which has got
added it's a very brilliant feature
because most of our test cases break
because of element location techniques
well let's come back to this so then we
added an assert title right so what is
us our title here it simply captures the
title of that particular page and it
checks this is all a very simple test
case so what we will do now is we will
stop the recording and then i have also
given a close browser so right now what
i'll do is i'll just comment this out
why because if i just run this test case
it's going to be very fast and you might
not be able to catch the exact command
execution what has happened all right so
right now i'll just disable it so that
it will just do all these test cases and
it just stays there without closing the
browser so now i'll just say run the
current testing so your amazon in is
launched
okay it is typed in the iphone it's also
clicked on the search so it is done so
now if you look here since we are in the
reference tab it is not able to show so
let's go to the log and now let's see
the log so it's going to be a running
log so if you notice here the previous
examples which we have run for facebook
is also in the same lock so we will have
to see the lock from running amazon
search because that's our test case so
if you see here every command line right
was executed successfully assert title
was also done and your test case was
executed successfully so it passed now
what we will do is on this assert title
i'll just modify this
and let's say just add some text i'll
just add double s here now this by
intentionally i'm going to fail this
test case just to show you that whenever
there is a test case failure how does
the id behaves and how do you get to
know the failures all right so i'll just
run the disk test case again so before
that let's close the previous
window all right done and now here i'll
also uncomment the close because anyway
it's a failure which i am going to see
which i should be able to see it in the
logs so i will close the browser after
the execution of test case okay so let's
simply go and run the test case okay
amazon.com is launched it should search
for iphone now yeah there you go all
right
now it should also close the browser yes
it has closed the browser and it has
failed now see here now this is the line
where our command filled why because the
expected title was not there and if you
look in the logs it says your assert
title on amazon.in failed actual result
was something different and it did not
match with what we had asked it for so
this is how simple it is to use your id
to create your automation scripts so we
saw all the components of id we saw the
record button then i showed you the
toolbar i showed you the editor box and
also the test execution lock so now
let's come to what are the limitations
of this id with ide you cannot export
your scripts your test scripts to web
driver scripts this support is not yet
added but it is in the works data driven
testing like using your excel files or
reading data from the csv files and
passing it to the script this capability
is still not available also you cannot
connect to database for reading your
test data or perform any kind of
database testing with selenium webdriver
yes you can also unlike selenium
webdriver you do not have a good
reporting mechanism with the ide like
say for example test ng or repotential
so that brings us to the next component
of the suite which is selenium rc
selenium remote control so selenium rc
was developed by paul hammond he
refactored the code which was developed
by jason and was credited with json as a
co-creator of selenium selenium server
is written in java it is used to write
web application test in different
programming languages as it supports
multiple programming languages like your
java c perl python and ruby it interacts
with the browser with the help of an rc
server so this rfsave server uses a
simple http get and post request for
communication and as i said earlier also
selenium rc was called as selenium 1.0
version but it got deprecated in
selenium 2.0 and was completely removed
in 3.0 and it got replaced by what
webdriver and we'll see why this
happened and what was that issue which
we had with the rc server so this is the
architecture of selenium remote control
at a very high level so when jason
huggins introduced selenium you know the
tool was called as javascript program
and then that was also called as a
selenium core so every html has a
javascript statements which are executed
by web browser and there is a javascript
engine which helps in executing this
command now this rca had one major issue
now what was that issue say for example
you have a test script say
test.javascript here which you are
trying to access elements from anywhere
from the google.com domain so what used
to happen is every element which is
accessible e are the elements which can
belong only to google.com domain like
say for example mail the search or the
drive so any elements from this can be
accessible through your test scripts
however nothing outside the domain of
say google.com in this case was
accessible say for example if your test
scripts wanted to access something from
yahoo.com this was not possible and this
is due to the security reasons obviously
now to overcome that the testers what
they had to do was they had to install
the selenium core and the web server
which contained your web application
which is under test on the same machine
and imagine if you have to do this for
every machine which is under test this
is not going to be feasible or even
effective all the time and this issue is
called as a same origin policy now what
the same origin policy issue says is it
prohibits a javascript from accessing
elements or interacting with scripts
from a domain different from where it is
launched and this is purely for the
security measure so if you have written
a scripts which can access your
google.com or anything related to
google.com these scripts cannot access
any elements outside the domain like as
we said in the example yahoo.com this
was the same origin policy now to
overcome this what this gentleman did
was he created something called as
selenium remote control server to trick
the browser in believing that your core
your selenium core and your web
application under test are from the same
domain and this is what was the selenium
remote control so if you look at again a
high level architecture or how did this
actually work first you write your test
scripts which is here right in any of
the supported language like your php or
your java or python and before we start
testing we need to launch this rc server
which is a separate application so this
selenium server is responsible for
receiving the cellini's commands and
these salinis commands are the ones
which you have written in your script it
interprets them and reports the result
back to your test so all that is done to
your rc server the browser interaction
which happens through rc server right
from here to your browser so this
happens through a simple http
post and get request and that is how
your rc server and your browser
communicate and how exactly this
communication happens this rc server it
acts like a proxy so say your test
scripts ask to launch a browser so what
happens is this commands goes to your
server and then your rc server launches
the browser it injects the javascript
into the browser once this is done all
the subsequent calls from your test
script right from your test scripts to
your browser goes through your rc and
now upon upon receiving these
instruction your selenium core executes
these actual commands as javascript
commands on the browser and then the
test results are displayed back from
your browser to your rc to your test
scripts so the same cycle gets repeated
right until the complete test case
execution is over so for every command
what you write in your javascript here
or your test script here goes through a
complete cycle of going through the rc
server to the browser collecting the
results again from the rc server back to
your test scripts so this cycle gets
repeated for every command until your
complete test execution is done so rc
had definitely lot of shortcomings and
what are those so rc server needs to be
installed before running any test
scripts which we just saw so that was an
additional setup since it acts as a
mediator between your commands which is
your selenius commands and your browser
the architecture of rc is complicated
why because of its intermediate rc
server which is required to communicate
with the browser the execution of
commands takes very long it is slower we
know why because every command in this
takes a full trip from the test script
to your rc server to the core engine to
the browser and then back to the same
route which makes your overall test
execution very slow lastly the apis
supported by rc are very redundant and
confusing so rc does have a good number
of aps however it is less object
oriented so they are redundant and
confusing say for example say if you
want to write into a text box how and
when to use a type key command or just a
type command is always confusing another
example is some of the mouse commands
using a click or a mouse dot both kind
of you know almost providing a similar
functionality so that is the kind of
confusion which developers used to
create hence
selenium rc got deprecated and is no
more available in latest selenium
versions it is obsolete now now to
overcome these shortfalls web driver was
introduced so while rc was introduced in
2004 webdriver was introduced by simon
stewart in 2006. it's a class platform
testing platform so webdriver can run on
any platform like say linux windows mac
or even if you have a ubuntu machine you
can run your selenium scripts on this
machine it is a programming interface to
run test cases it is not an ide and how
does this work actually so test cases
are created and executed using web
elements or objects using the object
locator and the webdriver method so when
i do a demo you will understand what
this webdriver methods are and how do we
locate the web elements on the webpage
it does not require a core engine like
rc so it is pretty fast why because
webdriver interacts directly with the
browser and it does not have that
intermediate server like the rc hat so
each browser in this case what happens
is each browser has its own driver on
which the application runs
and this driver is responsible to make
the browser understand the commands
which you will be passing from the
script like say for example click of a
button or you want to enter some text so
through your script you tell which
browser you want to work with say chrome
and then the chrome driver is
responsible for interpreting your
instructions and to execute it on the
web application launched on the chrome
browser so like rc webdriver also
supports multiple programming languages
in which you can write your test scripts
so another advantage of web driver is it
supports various frameworks like test ng
junit n unit and report n g
so when we talk about the limitations of
webdriver you will appreciate how this
support for various frameworks and tool
help in making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
so let's look at the architecture of web
driver at a high level
what is in web drivers so webdriver
consists of four major components
the first one is we have got client
libraries
right or what we also call it as
language bindings
so since selenium supports multiple
language and you are free to use any of
the supported languages to create your
automation script these libraries are
made available on your selenium website
which you need to download and then
write your scripts accordingly so let's
go and see from where do we download
this so if i go to my browser
so
seleniumhq.org right so if you're
working with selenium this website is
your bible so anything and everything
you need to know about selenium right
you need to come here and use all these
tabs here in this website so right now
what we are going to look at is what are
those language binding so for that i'll
have to go to this download tab here
okay and if you scroll down here you
will see something like selenium client
and web driver language bindings
and for each of the supported language
of selenium you have a download link
right so say for example if you are
working with java here what you need to
do is you need to download your java
language binding so let us go back to
the presentation so this is where your
language bindings are available next so
selenium provides lots of apis for us to
interact with the browser
and when we do the demo i'll be showing
you some of this aps right and these are
nothing but the rest apis
and everything whatever we do through
the script happens through the rest
calls then we have a json wire protocol
what is json javascript object notation
it is nothing but a standard for
exchanging data over the web so for
example you want to say launch a web
application through your script
so what selenium does it it creates a
json payload and posts the request to
the browser driver that is here and then
we have this browser drivers themselves
and as i said there is a specific driver
for each browser
as you know every tool has its own
limitation
so does selenium
so let's look at what these limitations
are and if there are any workarounds for
them
cannot test mobile applications requires
framework like apm
selenium is for automating web
application
it cannot handle mobile applications
mobile applications are little different
and they need its own set of automation
tool
however what selenium provides is a
support for integrating this apm tool
which is nothing but a mobile
application automation tool
and using apm and selenium you can still
achieve mobile application automation
and when do you usually need this when
your application under test is also
supported on mobile devices you would
want a mechanism to run the same test
cases on web browser as well as your
mobile process right so this is how you
achieve it
the next limitation so when we talked
about the components of selenium i said
that with webdriver we can achieve only
sequential execution
however in real time scenario we cannot
just live with this we need to have a
mechanism to run our test cases
parallelly on multiple machines as well
as on multiple browsers so though this
is a limitation of webdriver but what
selenium offers is something called as
grid which helps us achieve this and we
will see in shortly what the selenium
grid is all about
also if you want to know more details as
how do we work with the grid how do you
want to install that grid so do check
out our video
on simply learn website on selenium grid
third limitations so limited reporting
capability so selenium webdriver has a
limited reporting capability it can
create basic reports but what we
definitely need is a more
so it does support some tools like say
test ng report ng and even extent
reports which you can integrate with
selenium and generate beautiful reports
powerful isn't it
also there are other challenges uh with
selenium like selenium is not very good
with image testing
especially for the ones which are
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium like auto it
and seculi so if you look at all this
selenium still provides a complete
solution for your automation need and
that's the beauty of selenium and that
is why it makes the most popular tool of
today for automation
okay let's do a quick comparison between
the selenium rc and the webdriver
so rc has a very complex architecture
you know why because of the additional
rc server whereas due to direct
interaction with the browser webdriver
architecture is pretty simple
execution speed
it is lower in rc and much faster than
webdriver why because in web driver we
have eliminated the complete layer of
selenium server
right that the rc server and we
established a direct communication with
the browser through browser drivers
it requires an rc server to interact
with the browsers we just talked about
it and whereas webdriver can directly
interact with the browser
so rc again we talked about this as one
of the limitations that we have lot of
redundant apis which kept developers
guessing as which api to use for what
functionality
however webdriver offers pretty clean
apis to work with
rc did not offer any support for
headless browser whereas in web driver
you do have a support for using headless
browsers
let's see the web driver in action now
now for the demo we will use this
particular use case and what this use
case says is navigate to the official
simply learn website
then type the selenium in search bar and
click on it and click on the selenium
3.0 training so we are basically
searching for selenium 3.0 training on
the simply learn website first let's do
the steps manually and then we will go
ahead and write the automation script so
let's go to my browser
on my browser what i'll do is i'll let
me first launch the simply learn website
okay and here what my use case step says
is i need to search for
selenium and click on the search button
so once i do that it is going to give me
a complete list of all kind of selenium
trainings which is available with
simplylearn and what i'm interested in
is the selenium 3.0 training here once i
find this on the web page i need to go
and click on that all right so this is
all the steps which we are going to
perform in this use case okay now so for
writing the test cases i'll be using an
id which is eclipse i've already
installed my eclipse and also i have
installed selenium in this instance of
my eclipse all right so if you can see
the reference library folder here you
will see all the jars which are required
for the selenium to work next another
prereq which is required for selenium
and that is your driver files now every
browser which you want to work with has
its own driver file to execute your
selenium scripts and since for this demo
i'll be working with the firefox browser
i will need a driver file for firefox
now driver file for firefox is the
geckodriver which i have already
downloaded and placed in my folder
called drivers
now where did i download this from let's
go ahead and see that so if i go back to
my browser and if you go to your
selenium hq dot website you have to go
to this download tab here in the
download tab when you scroll down you
will see something like third party
drivers bindings and plugins in this you
will see the list of all the browsers
which is supported by selenium and
against each of this browser you will
find a link which has the driver files
now since we'll be using the gecko
driver
this is the link where you need to go to
and depending on which operating system
which you're working on you need to
download that particular file now since
i am working on mac this is the file
which i am using if you are a windows
user you need to download this zip file
and unzip it so once you unzip that you
would
get a file called gecko driver for your
firefox or a chrome driver for your
chrome browser and then what you do is
you just create a directory called
drivers under your project
and just place the driver files here so
these are the two prereqs for your
selenium one is importing your jar files
like this and then having your drivers
downloaded and keep them under a folder
where you can reference to okay so now
we'll go ahead and create a class i
already have a package created in this
project so i'll use this project and
create a new class so i'll say create
new java class and let's call this as
search training i'll be using a public
static void main and i'll click on
finish
so let's remove this auto generated
lines as we do not need them all right
now the first statement which you need
to write before even you start writing
the rest of your coders what you need to
do is you need to define or declare your
driver variable using your class web
driver so what i would do is i'll say
web driver
driver
done all right now you'll see that this
id is going to flash some errors for you
that means it is going to ask you to
import certain libraries which is
required by the web driver so simply
just go ahead and say import web driver
from org dot open sq dot selenium this
is the package which we will need all
right so you have a driver created which
is of the class web driver and now after
this i'm going to create three methods
all right so first method i will have
for
launching the firefox browser okay and
then i will write a simple method for
searching
selenium training
and clicking on it
this is the actual use case what we'll
be doing and then third method i'm going
to write is just to close the browser
which i'm going to be opening right so
these are the different methods which
i'll be creating and from the public
static void main i will just call these
methods one after the other okay so let
us go ahead and write the first method
now my first method is launching the
firefox browser so i'll say public void
since my return type is null or there is
no return type for this let's call it as
launch browser
okay all right now in this for launching
any browser i need to mention two steps
now the first step is where i need to do
a system.set property okay let's do that
first and then i'll explain what this
does i'll just say system dot set
property so this accepts a key and a
value pair so what is my key here my key
here is web driver dot
gecko
dot driver and i need to provide a value
so value is nothing but the path to the
gecko driver and we know that this gecko
driver which i am going to use here is
right here in the same project path
under the drivers folder correct and
that is what the path which i'm going to
provide here so here simply i need to
say
drivers slash
gecko driver gec ko all right done and
let me close this sentence all right now
since i'm a mac user my gecko driver
installable is just the name gecko
driver if you're a windows user and if
you're running your selenium scripts on
the windows machine you need to provide
a complete path to this including dot
exe because driver executable on your
machines is going to be geckodriver.exe
alright so just make sure that your path
which you mentioned here in the
system.set property is the correct path
okay then the next thing what we need to
do is i need to just say driver is equal
to new
firefox driver okay so this command new
firefox driver creates an instance of
the firefox browser now this is also
flagging me error why because again it's
going to ask me to import the packages
where the firefox driver classes present
okay we did that now these two lines are
responsible for launching the firefox
browser phone so this is done so what's
my next step in the use case now i need
to launch the website simply learn so
for that we have a command called
driver.get
driver.get what it does is whatever url
you're going to give it here in this
double quotes as an argument it is going
to launch that particular website and
for us it's a simply learn website so
what i do as a best practices instead of
typing out the url i go to my browser
launch that url which i want to test and
i simply copy it come back to your
eclipse and just simply paste it so this
ensures that i do not make any mistakes
in the url okay so done so our first
method is ready where we are launching
the browser which is our firefox browser
and then launching the simply learn
website now the next method what is my
next method in my next method i need to
give the search string to search
selenium training on this particular
website now for that we need to do few
things what are those few things let's
go to the website again all right so
let me relaunch this let's close this
okay
let me remove all this and let's go to
the home page first okay this is my home
page so as you saw when i did a manual
testing of this i entered the text here
so now since i have to write a script
for this first i need to identify what
this element is for that what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to say right
click here and i'll say inspect element
all right now this element let's see
what attribute it has which i can use
for finding this element so i i see that
there is an id present so what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to simply use
this id and then i'll just copy this id
from here go back to eclipse let's write
a method first so i'll say public void
and what do we give the method name say
search training or just search all right
now in this i need to use a command
called driver dot find element
by id is what i'm going to use as a
locating technique and in double quotes
the id which i copied from the website
is what i'm going to paste here okay and
then what i'm going to do on this
element is i need to send that text the
text which i'm going to search for which
is selenium so i'll just say send keys
and whatever text i want to send i need
to give it in double quotes so for that
selenium so this is done so now i've
entered the text here and after entering
the text i need to click on this button
so for that i need to first know what
that button is so let's inspect that
search button okay now if you look at
the search button other than the tag
which is span and the class name i do
not have anything here all right so what
i can do is i can either use the class
name or i can write an x path since this
is a demo which we have already used id
locating technique i would go ahead and
use the x path here so for me to
construct an x path uh i will copy this
class first okay
and then i already have a crow path
installed on my firefox so i'll use the
crow path and first test my x bar so
i'll just say double slash let's see
what was that element it has a span tag
okay so i'll have to use span and at
class equal to and i'll just copy the
class name here and let's see if it can
identify that element yeah so it is able
to identify so i'll just use this x path
in my code so i'll go back to eclipse
and i'll say driver dot find element by
dot x path and the x path which i just
copied from crow path is what i'm going
to paste here and what is the action i
need to do here i need to say click
done so i have reached a stage where i
have entered this selenium okay and then
i have clicked on the search button once
i do this i know that expected result is
i should be able to find this particular
link here selenium 3.0 training okay and
i should be able to click on that so for
that again i need to inspect this so
let's inspect this selenium 3.2 all
right so now what are the elements this
has now this particular element has
attributes like it has a tag h2 then it
has got some class name and some other
attributes so i would again would like
to use a x path here now this time while
using the x path i'm going to make use
of a text functionality so that i can
search for this particular text so i'll
simply copy this i'll go to my crow path
the tag is h2 so i'll say simply h2
okay and here i'll say text equal to and
this is the text which i copied i missed
out that yes there so i'm just going to
add an s okay so let's first test here
whether it is able to identify that
element yeah so it is able to identify
so can you see a blue dotted line it is
able to show us which element it is
identified so i'll copy this x path now
and let's go to my ide eclipse so now
here what i need to do is i'll have to
again simply say driver dot find element
by dot x path
and paste the x path which we just did
and then again i have to do a click
operation done all right so technically
we have taken all the steps of the use
case and we have written the commands
for that
now let's add an additional thing here
say after coming to this page after
finding this we want to
say print the title of this page now
what is the title of this page if you
just hover your mouse on this it says
online and classroom training for
professional certification courses
simply so what i will do is after doing
all these operations i will just print
out this page title on our console so
for that i have to just do this driver
dot
so let's do a sysop so i'll say sysout
system.out.println okay and here i would
say
let's add a text here the page title is
and then let's append it with
driver dot
get title so this is the command which
will be using to fetch the page title
done now what is the last method i need
to add just to close the browser all
right so let me add a method here i'll
say public void close browser
and it's one single command which i need
to call i'll say driver dot quit okay
and then i need to call all these
methods from my public static void main
so i let me use my class name which is
this so i'm going to create an object
obj is equal to
new class name and then using this
object first is i need to call the
method launch browser and then i'll call
the method search
right and then i'll call the method
close process done so technically our
script is ready with all the
functionality which we wanted to cover
from our use case now there are few
other tweaks which i need to do this and
i'll tell you why i need to do this now
for example
after we click here right after we click
on the search if you observed on your
website it took a little while before it
listed out all the selenium trainings
for us and visually when you're actually
doing it you wait for the selenium 3.0
training to be available and then you
click on that now same thing you also
need to tell your scripts to do that you
need to tell your scripts to wait for a
while until you start seeing the
selenium 3.0 training or it appears on
your web page there are multiple ways to
do that in your script and it is a part
of overall synchronization what we call
where we use kind of implicit and
explicit kind of favorites now since
this is a demo for demo purpose what i
am going to do is i am going to use a
command called thread.sleep and i'm just
going to give an explicit weight of say
three seconds so you can use this mainly
for the demo purposes you can use a
thread.sleep command now this
thread.sleep command needs us to handle
some exceptions
so i am just going to click on add
throws declaration and say interrupted
exception now same thing i'll have to do
it in my main function also okay so
let's do that and complete it all right
so this is done so by doing this what am
i doing i'm ensuring that before i click
on the selenium three dot training we
are giving enough time for the script to
wait until the webpage shows this link
to the selenium 3.0 training that's one
thing i'm doing all right and also now
since you're going to be seeing this
demo through the video recording the
script when it starts running it is
going to be very fast so you might just
miss out saying how it does the send
keys and how did it click on the search
button for us to enable us to see it
properly i'll just add some explicit
weights here just for a demo purpose so
after entering the keys right so what
i'll do is i'll just give a simple
thread dot sleep here
okay so probably a three seconds or two
seconds wait should be good enough okay
three seconds wait should be good enough
here so that we should be able to see
how exactly this works on your browser
when we execute this okay now our
complete script is ready so what i'll do
is i'll just save the script and then we
will simply run the script so to run the
script i just say right click run as
java application okay it says ask me to
select and save i've saved the script
now so let's observe how it runs okay
the
simplylearn.com the website is launched
so the selenium text has been entered in
the search box it has clicked on the
search okay all right so now it did
everything whatever we wanted it to do
all right so since we are closing the
browser you are unable to see whether
the selenium three dot training was
selected or not however what i have
given here is to fetch the title after
all these operations were complete and
if you see here the complete operations
was done and we were able to see the
page title here okay so now what i'll do
since we are unable to see whether it
clicked on the selenium 3.0 training or
not i'll just comment our the close
browser the command okay so we will not
call the close browser so that the
browser remains open and we get to see
whether did it really find the training
link or not okay so let me close this
window we do not need this firefox
window close all tabs and then i'll just
exactly execute the script so i'll say
run as java application so save the file
okay simplylearn.com is launched so
search text is entered now it's going to
click on the search button yes all right
so we've got the search results it
should click on selenium theodore
training and yes it is successfully able
to click on that all right so now it's
not going to close the browser because
we have commented on that line however
it did print us the title here all right
so this is a simple way of using the
selenium scripts
selenium grid so grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with webdriver
you can only do sequential execution but
in real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in
distributed environment and that is
where selenium grid comes into picture
so grid was conceptualized and developed
by patrick the main objective is to
minimize test execution type and how by
running your test parallelly so design
is in such a way that commands are
distributed on multiple machines where
you want to run test and all these are
executed simultaneously what do you
achieve by this methodology of course
the parallel execution on different
browsers and operating system grid is
pretty flexible and can integrate with
many tools like say you want a reporting
tool integrated to pull all the reports
from the multiple machines where you're
running your test cases and you want to
present that report in a good looking
format so you have an option to
integrate such report okay so how does
this grid work so grid has a hub and
node concept which helps in achieving
the parallel execution let's take an
example say your application supports
all browsers and most of the operating
systems like as in this picture you
could say one of them is a windows
machine one of them is a mac machine and
another one is say a linux machine so
your requirement is to run the test on
all supported browsers and operating
system like the one which is depicted in
this picture so what you have to do is
first thing is you configure a master
machine or what you also call it as a
hub by running something called a
selenium standalone server and this
talent standalone server can be
downloaded from the selenium hq website
using the server you create a hub
configuration that is this node and then
you create nodes specific to your
machine requirement and how are these
nodes created you again use the same
server which is your standalone selenium
server to create the node configuration
so i'll show you where the selenium
server can be downloaded so if we go
back to our
selenium hq website so you can see here
right on the top it says selenium
standalone server and this is the latest
version available so you just need to
download once you download this keep a
version of this one on your master
machine that is your hub and this should
also be present on your node machines
and there is a certain command which you
can use to install the server as a node
and as a master depending on your
configuration so once that is done you
have your master and your master of the
hub and the notes created your master
can control on which nodes you want to
execute test now say if this is a mac
machine this is a windows machine
through your master or your hub you
control on which machine you want to
execute what tests then also you could
have a multiple combination of tests
like say for example smoke test to be
run on all these nodes that's the kind
of configuration you can create or a
certain component test to be run on say
only windows 10 with an edge browser or
say regression test on mac machine so
any such things whatever configurations
you have for your node what happens is
the hub picks the right node which
confirms to your requirements or the
configurations which you have set up and
then sends a command to the node to
execute those test cases on the node
everything is controlled through your
master machine only here what happens on
the node so once the node gets the
command from the master the node
actually runs all the test cases which
is it which it intends to run on the
specific browser which you have
mentioned in your configuration file so
this is a very high level architecture
and how a grid works so if you want to
know more details of how the grid works
you can refer to our video on simply
learn all right again limitations so
what limitation does this grid have now
the first one is it has relatively poor
scalability compared to many modern
applications
it is pretty static each server is
configured in advance with a subset of
required browser instances available so
if you want to vary this you will need
to reconfigure so any configuration
tomorrow on any machines you want to
change it cannot be done automatically
you need to completely reconfigure that
node and then add it back to the grid
thirdly although it is available to run
on virtual servers it is actually not
designed as a cloud native application
and because of as a result of this it
isn't optimized to take advantage of
things like say distributed storage or
dynamic scaling or even automatic
failover so these are some of the
limitations of the grid advantages of
selenium speed and accuracy of course
since there is no manual execution your
test can run faster and with grid it
helps in parallel execution and you can
run or execute large volumes of test
within a very short time frame let's
take an example say before just before
the release of your product say during
the last lap of your testing you find a
bug and of course it has to be fixed so
the developer fixes the bug and you want
to run all the test cases pertaining to
that area now can you imagine that if
you have to do this testing manually how
long it's going to take so by automation
you can achieve this in a very short
duration of time and it will also help
you release your product in time with
very minimal or absolutely no human
errors the second advantage it's an open
source so it's available free of cost so
anyone can download it and start using
it it supports wide spectrum of
programming languages we have been
seeing throughout this presentation it
is not restricted to any particular
programming language so whatever
language you are comfortable with you
have an option to use that and write
your selenium scripts selenium has
support for almost all browsers and
operating system we also talked about
headless browser support so this helps
you create test cases once using any of
the browser and run them across all
browsers and all operating system thus
saving you lot of time from manual
execution and helping in achieving a
very broad test coverage and we also saw
that pretty easy to use tool right so
you can check out all our videos and you
can it's just a matter of time that you
can master the skill of writing your
automation scripts reusability of course
like any programming language it
provides you a mechanism to reuse your
code and avoid redundancy well again
let's see an overall what are the
limitations of selenium itself now since
selenium is open source that is one of
the biggest advantage now there is a
little disadvantage which comes with
that and what is it you do not have much
technical support because it's an open
source code however there are loads and
loads of documentations and forums
available which you can definitely refer
to and selenium as we said it is only
for automating web applications it
cannot handle the mobile applications or
even the desktop application however it
does provide support for integrating
tools like apm for mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing especially designed for your web
application tools again we have tools
like auto it and securi which can be
integrated with selenium selenium
webdriver has limited limited reporting
capability but again it does provide us
support for integrating tools like test
ng report ng and extent report it does
not have test management capabilities it
need not right not one tool need not
have each and everything what is
required but there is always a way to
integrate it so selenium does provide a
way to integrate any of the test
management tools now since selenium
supports multiple programming language
the developer of test automation will
require to have some basic knowledge of
any of the programming language it
supports to write effective automation
scripts right so this you could look at
it as an advantage or as a disadvantage
so overall if you look at all this right
selenium still provides a complete
solution for our automation need and
that is why we can still say that
selenium is one of the most popular tool
used in the industry today for your web
application automation how to install
selenium on windows system selenium
installation is a three-step process so
it has certain prereqs the first
prerequisite you need to have java on
your system so we will be installing
java first and then we will be working
with eclipse id so we will be installing
eclipse and then we will install celine
for java we will install the version
java 8 and for eclipse we have a version
4.10 this was the last stable version
which was released in december last year
so i'll be using that version and
selenium we will download the latest
3.14 version okay so let's get started
with our first step which is the java
installation so to install java let's go
to the browser and simply just search
for java 8 download
so now you will see that there is an
oracle site which is listed there and
that is where you would be downloading
all your java package so go ahead and
click on that and for you to download
any jdk package from the oracle site you
need to create an account so if you
already have one you just need to log in
using that account and then you can
download any of the jdks and if you do
not have one please go ahead create a
new account on the oracle login to that
account and then you can just download
the java it so since i already have an
account and i have already downloaded
the package but i'll show you how and
where to download it from so in this
page if you scroll down so you will see
this java development kit 8211 so this
is the version we'll be downloading it
so click on the accept license agreement
and then since we are working on the
windows system today so we will be
downloading this the windows package so
just click on that and it will get
downloaded in your downloaded folder and
as i said i've already downloaded the
packages so here it is what i've done is
i've just created a directory called
installers and i'm going to be keeping
all my installables here so here i have
a folder called java installer and this
is where my installable is so now that
we have this file so we will just go
ahead double click on it and launch this
installer the installer is launched and
just click on run so this will take a
few minutes to install java the
installer is launched now just click on
the next button here so here for the
installation directory you can
change the directory to the choice of
whatever drive and the folder structure
you want to i would like to leave it as
default here and we just go and click on
next and then the java installation is
in progress so let's wait until this is
completed it really shouldn't take too
much time maybe just a few more minutes
here
okay accept the license term just click
on next we leave the destination folder
as it is
so jdk8 is successfully installed on
your system so close the installer now
and let's go ahead and check whether the
installation is done properly so for
that what i'll do is i'll go to my
command prompt and i'll send just say
java minus version so it says java
version 1.8 and this tells us that the
java is installed successfully now after
this installation there are couple of
configurations which we need to do and
what are those configuration one is you
need to set the path variable and then
you we are also going to set a java home
directory so for that first let's go
ahead and check where is the java
installed actually let's figure out the
directory first so if you remember the
directory structure where the java got
installed was in program files java i
have there are certain previous versions
which had installed and then uninstalled
it so that is why you see some residuals
here sitting here let's not worry too
much about that instead let me go to the
latest one what i have installed which
is this okay and there is a bin folder
here and this is the path which we need
to set in our path variable so what i
will do is i'll just copy this path and
then
go to your control panel here go to your
where is my system yeah so click on the
system go to advanced system setting and
here in the environment variables find
the path variable okay and then say edit
now what are we doing here in the path
variable is we are going to add the java
bin directory to the path be very
careful whenever you are editing your
path variable do not overwrite anything
always go into the edit mode go towards
the end here and then just say control v
paste the path which you have just
copied from the explorer window that's
it now just say okay done so your path
setting is done so what's the next one
we need to do we need to add a new
environment variable called the java now
what i'll do for that is i just say new
i just type java home here
and what is the value of this we need to
set we need to set the same path but
without the bin directory so we just
need to set the path till your java
directory that is this so we'll just
copy the path again and paste it here
that is all just say okay click on ok
click on ok here and we are done so
again let's go to our command prompt and
just say java minus version
so everything seems to be fine so now
successfully we have installed java on
the system so what is our next
installation step what we have now we
need to install the eclipse so let's go
back to the browser again so to download
eclipse we will be downloading the
package from the eclipse.org so when you
go here to eclipse.r you can see the
latest version which is available and
the latest version available when this
video was made was 201906
so especially with eclipse since it's an
open source i prefer to work with the
last stable version and so does most of
the developers do and hence that is the
reason why i have picked up the version
which is like last year's version which
is uh 4.10 which was released in last
december so you can always choose to go
with the latest version but then if
there are any issues and if you're like
first time working with the eclipse
you're going to get confused as where
these issues are coming from right so i
would still recommend that you use the
last stable version which is available
with your eclipse so now to get the last
table version what you need to do is go
and click on this download packages and
here if you scroll down this page you
can see here more downloads so there is
a list of all the previous releases of
eclipse which is available and this is
what we need to download so just click
on that 4.10 version and then click on
the os on which you want to install
eclipse for us it is windows so i'll
just click here on the 64-bit windows
and then click on the download and you
will be downloading the complete package
so once you download this is what it
will look like so let's go back to our
directory of installers so this is the
installer for the eclipse which i got
now what's the next step i need to do
just launch this installer and install
eclipse so i'll just say double click on
this i'll say run
so here you will see multiple options
here for eclipse installation so
depending on your requirement you can go
ahead and install any of these packages
so for us we just need an eclipse id for
java developer so i'll select this and
i'll say install so again you'll have a
choice of directory where you want to
install so i have chosen d drive here
this is the default directory name it
takes which is okay we can leave it as
it is and then also you have an option
to create a start menu entry and desktop
shortcut so just leave the default
selection as it is and go ahead and
click on install so this will take a
while to install the eclipse
this is select all you can close this
window this is select all and accept it
okay so the installation has been
completed successfully so let's go and
click on this launch and let's see the
first window what opens
when you launch the eclipse you need to
specify a workspace directory now what
is this workspace directory so this is a
directory or a folder wherein all the
java files or any programs or any
artifacts which you are going to create
through eclipse will be stored in this
particular folder so this could be any
location on your system so this is you
can go ahead browse the location and
change it so for in our case what we
will do is i'll go to the d drive and
i already have a directory so here i'll
create i'll just clear select this
folder and then create a folder called
workspace i'll say my workspace and then
i'll say launch so every time i open the
eclipse right so if this is going to
take as my default workspace and all my
programs all my javascripts or my
automation scripts are getting are going
to be stored in this particular location
so we will say launch
so this is a welcome window which opens
we can just close this and there we go
the eclipse is open with a certain
perspective so there are certain windows
here which we do not need let's just
close them so now the first thing what
you do after launching the eclipse is go
ahead and create a new project so i'll
say file new and since i'm going to be
using java with selenium i'll say create
java project so give a project name
let's say my first project now you have
an option here to select the jre which
you want to use so we just installed
this jdk 1.8 okay so i'm going to click
on use default jre otherwise you also
have an option to use a project specific
gr for example i could have two
different projects where one project i'm
going to be working with gre 1.8 and
there is another project which i want to
work with the latest java maybe java 12
and i can have more than one java
installed on the machine so this give me
an option to select whichever java i
want to work with so if you have another
java installed here it will show up in
this list so and you can just go ahead
and select that now since we have only
one java installed on our machine which
is java 1.8 i will say use default gre
which is 1.8 and i will click on finish
now if you observe this folder structure
the project which is created see all the
reference libraries to this particular
java have been created here now we are
ready to create any kind of java
programs in this project so now we have
successfully done the second step of our
installation which is the eclipse
installation after this we need to
install the selenium so again let's go
back to the browser and see what files
we need to download to install selling
so let me go to my browser and here i
will be going to the seleniumhq.org
so if you are working with selenium this
particular website the seleniumhq.org is
going to be a bible everything and
anything related to selenium is
available in this website whether you
want to download the files whether you
want to refer to the documentation
anything regarding to selenium is
available here so what we want now is
the installables for selenium so here go
to the download tab now for you to
install selenium and start working with
selenium there are three things which
are required for you to download one is
a standalone selenium server so this is
not required immediately when you get
started with selenium however when you
start working with remote selenium
webdriver you would be requiring this
when you have a grid setup you will be
requiring the standalone server so for
that what you can do is you can just
download the latest version available
here so when you click on that it will
download the file into your download
folder so this is one particular file
which you need to keep next selenium
client and web driver language bindings
now in today's demo we will be looking
at selenium with java so that means my
client package of java is what i need to
download so whatever programming
language selenium supports we have
respective downloadables available with
that say if you're working with python
then you need to download your client
library for python and since we are
working with java you need to download
this package so simply what you need to
do click on this link and it will
download the java package for you which
are basically the jar files so we have
client libraries now and then there is
another component what we need now with
selenium you are going to be automating
your web browser applications correct
and you also want your applications to
run on multiple browsers so that means
your scripts the automation scripts
which you create should be able to run
on any browser selenium works with
multiple browsers like edge safari
chrome firefox and other browsers even
it has a support for headless browser
now every browser which it supports
comes with its own driver files now say
for example we want to say work with
firefox driver so that means for us to
start working with firefox browser we
need to download something called as a
gecko driver here and if you want to
work with chrome browser you need to
install the chrome driver so depending
on what browsers you'll be testing with
go ahead click on each of this link and
download the latest driver files now
since we are going to be working with
firefox in this demo what i need to do
is i just need to click here on the
latest link so when i click on the
latest link it is going to take me to
this driver files so driver files are
specific to each of the operating system
so if you go down here you will see
there is a separate driver file
available for linux for mac and for
windows so depending on which operating
system where you'll be running your test
download that particular driver file and
this is the driver file i need because
we are working on windows machine so
these are the three different packages
which we need to download from the
selenium hq dot org for us to install
selling so let me show you the folder
where i've already downloaded all this
so if you see here selenium java
3.141.59 okay this is nothing but our
client library which we saw here let's
go back to the main page here that is
this so once i download this this is a
zip file after i unzip the file this is
the folder structure i see and let's see
what is there in this folder structure
so there are two jar files here and then
in the lips there are multiple jar files
and we will need all this to work with
selling it and then we also downloaded
the driver files so what i did was after
downloading those driver files for the
browser i created a directory here
called drivers and i've kept all my
browser drivers here so i have a driver
file downloaded for chrome i want to
work with firefox so i have a gecko
driver here and then for internet
explorer that's it so this is all we
need so once we have all this what you
need to do is go to your eclipse in the
eclipse right click on the project which
you have created and then go to the
build path and say configure build path
go to the libraries tab here now do you
see this jre libraries here this is what
got installed first and now similarly we
are going to add the selenium jars to
the slide british and how do we add that
on your right you can see this add
external jars click on add external jars
go to your folder where you have
downloaded your selenium which is this
select all the jar files which is
available so i have two jar files here
i'll just say click open again i will
click on add external jar now from the
lips folder i will select all this file
so select all the five jars and click on
open so you should see all the seven jar
files here so once you have this just
say apply and close now if you look into
your project directory here you will see
some a folder called referenced library
and this is where you will see all the
selenium charts here this is a very
simple installation in eclipse when you
want to install selenium you just need
to export all the jars of the selenium
into eclipse and now your system is
ready to start working with selenium
scripts so for us to install java let us
go to our browser
and simply what i'll do is i'll just
google for
java 8 download
okay so we would select the oracle site
for downloading the sd
okay so once you go here you can see
that we have something called as java
software development kit 8 u211 so this
is the version we'll be working with so
in order for you to download you need to
have an oracle account so since i
already have one i have directly been
logged into that so if you do not have
an oracle account please go ahead create
an account for yourself so that you can
download any of the
java installers
now let's go for and download our
package so i'll be downloading this
package for that i need to click on
accept license agreement and then since
we are going to be working on mac this
is the package which i'm going to
download so let's go ahead and click on
that
and now the download is going to start
however we will not wait for the
complete download to happen since i have
already downloaded the package and i
have kept it in one of my folders so let
me show you where that is
so let me go to my finder so what i have
done is i have created a folders called
installers and all the software which we
are going to require today for us to
work with selenium is what i have
downloaded it and kept it here so we
will go step by step so that you
understand what each of these packages
are so as you see here i have the jdk 8
which i have already downloaded so let's
go ahead and install jtk so how do we
install jdk so you have the dmg file
here you just go ahead and double click
on that
okay and then i will double click on
this package
and then we will say continue
and install
so it's going to ask me for my password
okay i've given my password and i'll say
install the software
probably it will just take a couple of
minutes to install java
okay there you go so now the java has
been installed so i let me close this
window let me close this window too and
then now i'll go to my terminal window
so let's open my terminal and here
let's say java minus
version
bingo so there we have java 1.8
installed on our system now there are
couple of other things which you need to
do apart from installation of your jdk
you also need to set some system
variables right so in mac how do you set
the system variables or the environment
variables you do that in your bash
profile so let's see how we do that all
right so what i will do is i'll use an
editor which is my vi
okay and then i'll open my bash profile
so what is bash profile it's a config
file for your bash self this is mainly
used to export variables in your shell
like in windows we are going to do the
system variable setting from the
advanced setting right so similarly we
are going to do that here so i will say
vi dot
dash underscore
profile so this is the file
where
i will be adding java home path
now i have other parts here already
written because i am working with other
multiple software on this machines and
now i'll go to the end of this file and
i'll say
export
java home
equaled
now what is the path we need to give for
java home we need to give the path where
the java has been installed on your
system
okay first let's go and find out that
path so let's go back to our finder
and then i have a folder called library
here so here
there is a java and then there is
something called as java virtual
machines so if you have a single java or
multiple java versions installed so all
those versions you are going to see
under this directory which is java
virtual machines and java one dot is is
what we installed just now so let me go
and open that folder there is something
called as content and then home and in
this you have your jre and bin folder so
that means i need to give my java home
path until here
till this home directory so simply what
i'm going to do is i'll just go here say
get info because i want to just copy the
path and what you can do is you copy
this path
okay and then go back to your shell
and here i'm going to paste this path
plus i want it till the home directory
so i'm just going to type out h-o-m-e-ho
that is it so you have now set your java
home environment variable so simply you
do
save the file escape colon wq and come
out of it and now what you need to do
for this batch profile
to be activated you just exit out of
this terminal
okay close this terminal window and i
will go ahead and open another terminal
so let me close this
info text so here let me again give java
minus version
okay so everything seems to be working
fine so this completes our java
installation now your system is ready
and you have your java up and running
other thing which you also can do is go
to your system preferences
okay here you will see this java control
panel okay this is another way of
finding out that your java has been
installed successfully on the machine so
you can just open this java control
panel and if there is any settings which
you want to do here you can do it
through your control panel also
all right
let's close this
let's minimize this window
and this folder windows
so we have successfully done a step one
so what's our step two we need to go
ahead and install the eclipse now same
thing what i will do i'll go to my
browser
okay and
now i'll open another tab here and i'll
say
eclipse download
and we'll go to this eclipse.org
now here whenever you're going to do
this installation you will see the
latest version appears here my
recommendation to you is instead of if
you're working first time instead of
working on the latest version available
i would suggest that you work with the
last stable version and that's exactly
what you are going to do today so for me
to go to the previous versions i just
need to go here on this download
packages click on it
okay so once you click on that
on this page if you scroll down you will
see something called as more downloads
right in this you will see all the bills
of eclipse which is available all your
previous versions so since today i'll be
working with 4.10 version i will go
ahead and click on this 4.10 this 4.10
was released last year this is 2018
december okay and now when you look at
this installer you have multiple
packages available here so depending on
your need you can choose which package
you want to work with so today for our
demo what i would be using is eclipse id
for java developers
so since we are going to be working on
mac i will go ahead and click on this
downloadable
and then i'll click on this download
which is going to download this
particular file for me i've already
downloaded this file and kept it in my
folder
let's go to my folder
okay it's not opening so let me click
from here
and then let's go to our selenium demo
folder and in that installers okay so
now do you see this eclipse java
12 are
blah blah blah dot dmg so this is the
file which we are going to be using to
install eclipse now as simple as what we
did for jdk i am going to double click
on this and install the eclipse
lets see how the eclipse gets installed
all right so now
i'll just move this folder into
applications
done
so my eclipse is ready now so simply
let's go ahead and launch so what i'll
do i'll just simply search for that on
my system eclipse there you go and i'll
just double click this
is an application downloaded from the
internet are you sure you want to open
it yes please go ahead and open it
okay it is launching it so did you see
how simple the eclipse installation is
it's just downloading the package and
just installing it on your mac machine
all right when you start the eclipse for
the first time you need to set your
workspace so workspace is place where
you're going to keep all your folders
all your
java code or whatever you are going to
do in eclipse all under that particular
directory um so right now it gives me a
default directory rather what i will do
is since i have created a separate
folder for our demos i will go ahead and
select that folder
which is my simply demo
and then in this i will add
a folder called
workspace
okay so that means in this particular
location whatever files i'm going to
create whatever code i'm going to write
in selenium is going to be stored at
this location and then i'll go ahead and
say launch
so it will take a minute to load your
workbench yeah there it goes so when you
launch your eclipse
right so let me just
make this window bigger the first screen
what you are going to see is the welcome
screen
just go ahead and close the welcome
screen and this is the first view of
your eclipse what you're going to get so
let's close out all the windows which we
are not going to be working today
and i just need this main screen here
now what is the first step you're going
to do once you have the eclipse i would
go ahead and create a project first
so i'll simply say open file new java
project let's give a nice name to this
since this is our first project which is
going to be created so i'll say selenium
first project
now if you observe here
so we have a jdk already installed and
eclipse needs a jdk to work with and
what it is done while i create my new
project it has already given me an
option to use the execution jre which
you already have on the system that's
why it has already chosen java one
dotted in case you have multiple javas
installed in in that case what you can
do is you can always go here select this
and select the java of your choice so
say if you have got the latest java
which is java 12 installed on your
system it will give you an option here
along with java software 8 it will give
you java 12 here so you can go ahead and
select that for this particular project
that option is also available now since
we have only one jtk installed here i
will go ahead and create this project
so i'll just click on finish and it's
going to create a project from so there
are few default things which it grades
created one is definitely the gre system
libraries right this is what we told
eclipse when we created project that my
java is 1.8 so what it has done is it
has imported all this jar file which it
requires for our java programs to work
in our eclipse id and then it creates a
src which is your source directory
wherein we will be creating all our java
code or selenium test scripts okay good
so far so this is a simple way of
installing your eclipse and getting your
eclipse ready to work with your selenium
all right so now let's go back
so we have done the installation of java
we have done the installation of eclipse
now what's left just the selenium right
so what is that we need for selenium
let's go back to our browser
okay and this time we will go to
selenium
hq
dot org
so this is going to be a bible for you
if you're going to be working with
selenium so in this website what i do is
i go to downloads
and there are two things which we need
to download for us to work with selena
one is the selenium standalone server
so when you're going to be working with
remote selenium webdriver is when you
would require this however i would
suggest that we download whatever is
required for us even though we might not
use it immediately so what i just need
to do is i need to click on this and
it's going to download this server for
me
so i have already downloaded it and i'll
show you that
and then what we need is the selenium
client and web driver language bindings
okay we need a client so what is the
client which you are going to work in we
are going to working with java client
with the selenium and for that i need to
go ahead and download this if you're
working on say c sharp or ruby or python
then you have the respective packages
which you can go and download now since
we are going to be working with java
here i would go ahead and click on this
and this is going to download the java
client formula now as i said since i've
already downloaded it so let's go ahead
and look at what are those downloadables
what we have so let's close out this
window now if you see here
uh one is the selenium server standalone
which we just downloaded and then when
you download the client libraries what
it does it it creates a zip file it
downloads a zip file and it unzips it
and what is contained in that particular
folder so if you look here selenium java
3. in this folder you have multiple jar
files
with which is what we'll be working with
selenium
so here you have two jar files here and
then under the folder libs you have
other jar files now these are the files
which we will need and now let's see how
do we utilize this file in our eclipse
so for that let's go back to our eclipse
okay so
let me maximize this window so in
eclipse first thing what you need to do
is click on your project
okay right click on that
and then you have something called as
build path
go to the build path and say configure
now here in this configure build path
what you need to do is go to your
libraries
okay go to add external jars
now when you click on that this is where
you need to select all your jar files
from what you have downloaded from the
selenium site so that is present in our
selenium java 3. so what i'll do is
simply select
these two first
okay
then again you click on the external jar
files what we have is an ellipse so
select all the jar files in the list
say open
you have all the jar files what we need
identified here go ahead and click on
apply and close
once you do that how do you know whether
all those jars have been imported
correctly
go to the reference libraries here you
should be able to see all the selenium
jars which we have downloaded to be
listed out here and so it lists here so
that means we have successfully imported
selling hello this is matthew from
simply learn and today we're going to go
through part one of a two-part series on
interview questions that you are likely
to be asked if you are interviewing for
a job that focuses on devops so there
are approximately seven sections that we
cover in devops we go from general
devops questions source code management
with tools such as git continuous
integration and here we'll focus on
jenkins continuous testing with tools
such as selenium and then you also have
the operation side of devops which is
your configuration management with tools
such as chef puppet and ansible
containerization with docker and then
continuous monitoring with tools such as
nagios so let's just get into those
general devops questions so one of the
questions that you're going to be asked
is how is devops different from agile
and the reality is is that devops is a
cultural way of being able to deliver
solutions that's different from agile if
we look at the evolution of delivery
over the last five to ten years we've
gone from waterfall based delivery to
agile delivery which is on uh sprints to
where we are with continuous integration
and continuous delivery around devops
the whole concept of devops is
culturally very very different from
agile and the difference is is that
you're looking at being able to do
continuous releases what does that mean
the difference is is that you want to be
able to send out code continuously to
your production environment that means
the operations team the development team
have to be working together that means
that any code that gets created has to
be able to go to production very quickly
which means you need to be testing your
code continuously and then that
production environment must also be able
to be tested continuously and any
changes or any errors that come up have
to be communicated effectively and
efficiently back to the dev and op team
another area in which i see that devops
is different is really the response that
we have for how we engage with the
customer so the customer is coming to
your website to your mobile app to your
chat bot or any digital solution that
you have and has an expectation when
you're going through and actually doing
a dev ops paradigm the old model would
be that you would capture requirements
from the customer then you do your
development then you do your testing and
there would be these barriers between
each of those as we move faster through
from waterfall to agile what we saw is
that with agile we were able to respond
much faster to customer demands so
instead of it being weeks or months
sometimes in some cases years between
releases of software what we saw it
would was a transition to weeks and
months for releases on software now we
see with devops is that the release
cycle has shrunk even further with the
goal of continuously delighting the
customer how further has that release
cycle shrunk to there are companies that
have gone from having releases of once a
week or once every two weeks or once a
month to now having multiple releases a
day indeed some companies have up to 50
releases a day this isn't something to
also bear in mind is that each of those
releases are tested and verified against
test records so that you can guarantee
that the code that's going to production
is going to be good continuous code so
what are the differences between the
different phases of devops so
effectively there are two main phases of
devops there's the planning and coding
phase and then there's the deploying
phase and you have a tool such as
jenkins that allows you to integrate
between both environments some of the
core benefits that you may have to
devops are going to be some technical
benefits and some business benefits so
when somebody asks you what are the
benefits of devops you can reply that
from a technical point of view you're
able to use continuous software delivery
to constantly push out code that has
been tested and verified against scripts
that have been written and approved you
can be able to push out smaller chunks
of code so that when you have an issue
you're not having to go through massive
blocks of code or massive projects
you're going through just very small
micro services or small sections of code
and you're able to detect and correct
problems faster on the business side the
benefits are absolutely fantastic from a
customer that's coming to your website
and or to your mobile app they're going
to see responses happening continuously
so that the customer is always aware
that you as a company are listening to
their demands and responding
appropriately you're able to provide a
more stable environment and you're able
to scale that environment to the demands
of the number of customers that are
using your services so how you approach
a project that needs to implement devops
so this is really an exciting area for
you to be in so there are effectively
three stages when it comes to actually
working in a dev ops the first stage is
an assessment stage and think of this as
the back of the napkin ideation stage
this is where you are sitting with a
business leader and they're giving you
ideas of what they would like to see
from feedback that they've had from
their customers this is blue sky
opportunity this is thinking of big
ideas that second stage and this often
comes as a fast follow to stage one is
actually proving out that concept so
developing a proof of concept and a
proof of concept can actually be a
multiple different things so it could be
something as simple as a wireframe or it
could be something that is as complex as
a mini version of the final application
depending on the scope of the work that
you're delivering will really depend on
how complicated you want the poc to be
but with that in mind whatever choice
you make you have to be able to deliver
enough in the poc so that when you
present this to a customer they're able
to respond to that creation that you've
developed and able to give you feedback
to be able to validate that you are
going with the right solution and able
to provide the right product to your
customers that third stage is where you
get into your dev ops stage and this is
just the exciting part this is where the
rubber hits the road and you start
releasing code based on a backlog of
features that are being requested for
the solution in contrast to doing agile
delivery where you just continuously
work through a backlog with devops what
you're also looking at is putting in
analytics and sensors to be able to
validate that you are being successful
with the solution that being delivered
so that once you actually start
delivering out code that customers can
interact with you want to be able to see
what are the pieces of the solution that
they are using what do they like what is
complicated where are the failure points
and you want to use that data and feed
that back into your continuous
integration and have that as a means to
be able to back fill the demand or work
that gets completed in the bank log so
what is the difference between
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment so continuous delivery is
based on putting out code that can be
deployed safely to production and
ensures that your businesses and
functions are running as you would
expect them to be so it's going through
and completing the code that you'd
actually see continuous deployment in
contrast is all about ensuring that
you're automating the deployment of a
production environment so you're able to
go through and scale up your environment
to meet the demands of both the solution
and the customer this makes software
development and release processes much
more faster and more robust so if we
look here we can actually see where
continuous integration and continuous
deployment come hand in hand so when you
actually start out with the initial
pushes of your code that's where you're
doing your continuous integration and
your continuous delivery and then at
some point you want to get very
comfortable with deploying the code that
you're creating so it's being pushed out
to your production environment one of
the things that's great about working
with the tools that you use in a devops
continuous integration and continuous
delivery model is that the development
tools that you use the containerization
tools the testing tools should always
reflect the production environment what
this means is that when you actually
come to deploying solutions to
production there are no surprises
because your development team have been
working against that exact same
environment all the way through so a
question that you'll also be asked is
you know what is the role of a
configuration management in devops and
so the role of configuration management
really has three distinct areas and the
first and this is really obvious one and
this is the one where you probably
already have significant experiences is
the ability to manage and handle large
changes to multiple systems in seconds
rather than days hours or weeks as that
may have happened before the second area
is that you want to also demonstrate the
business reasons for having
configuration management and the
business reason here is that it allows
it and infrastructure to standardize on
resource configurations and this has a
benefit in that you're able to do more
with fewer people so instead of having a
large configuration team you can
actually have a smaller more highly
skilled team that's able to actually
manage an even larger operational
environment and thirdly you want to be
able to highlight the ability to scale
so if you have configuration management
tools you're able to manage a
significant number of servers and
domains that may have multiple servers
in it allows you to effectively manage
servers that are deployed on cloud or
private cloud and allow you to do this
with high accuracy so how does
continuous monitoring help and maintain
the entire architecture of the system so
when this question comes up you want to
dig in and show your knowledge on how
configuration and continuous monitoring
is able to control an entire environment
so the number one topic that you want to
bring up when it comes to continuous
monitoring is that with being able to
effectively monitor your entire network
24 7 for any changes as they happen
you're able to identify and report those
faults or threats immediately and
respond immediately for your entire
network instead of having to wait as it
happens sometimes for a customer to
email or call you and say hey your
website's down nobody wants that that's
an embarrassing thing the other three
areas that you want to be able to
highlight are the ability to be able to
ensure that the right software and the
right services are running on the right
resources that's your number one
takeaway that you want to be able to
give of continuous monitoring the second
is to be able to monitor the status of
those servers continuously this is not
requiring manually monitoring but having
a agent that's monitoring those servers
continuously and then the third is that
by scripting out and continuously
monitoring your entire environment
you're creating a self-audit trail that
you can take back and demonstrate the
effectiveness of the operations
environment that you are providing so
one of the cloud companies that is a
strong advocate for devops is amazon's
web services aws and they have really
five distinct areas them that you can
zero in on board services so when the
question comes up what is the role of
aws in devops you want to really hold
out your hand and list of five areas of
focus using your thumb and finger so you
want to have flexible services built for
scale automation secure and a large
partner ecosystem and having those five
areas will really be able to help
demonstrate why you believe that aws and
other cloud providers but aws is
certainly the leader in this space are
great for being able to provide support
for the role of devops so one of the
things that we want to be able to do
effectively when we're releasing any
kind of solution is to be able to
measure that solution and so kpis are
very important so you will be asked for
three important dev of kpis and so three
that really come to mind that are very
effective the first one is mean time to
failure recovery and what this talks
about is what is the average time does
it take to recover from a failure and if
you have experience doing this then look
at the experience you have and use a
specific example where you are able to
demonstrate that mean time to failure
recovery the second is deployment
frequency and with deployment frequency
you want to be able to discuss how often
do you actually deploy solutions and
what actually happens when you're
actually doing those deployments and
what does the impacts to your network
look like when you're doing those
deployments and then the third one is
really tied to that deployment frequency
which is around what is the percentage
of failed deployments and so and how
many times did you deploy to a server
and something happened where the server
itself failed what we're looking for
when you're going through and being
asked for these kpis is experience with
actually doing a devops deployment and
being able to understand what devops
looks like when you're pushing out your
infrastructure and then the second is
being able to validate that
self-auditing ability and one word of
caution is don't go in there and say
that you have a hundred percent success
uh the reality is that servers do
degrade over time and you maybe want to
talk about a time when a server did
degrade in your environment and use that
as a story for how you're able to
successfully get over and solve that
degradation so one of the terms that is
very popular at the moment is
infrastructure as code and so you're
going to be asked to explain
infrastructure as code and really it's
it's something that actually becomes a
byproduct of the work you have to do
when you're actually putting together
your devops environments and
infrastructure's code really refers to
the writing of code to actually manage
your environment and you can go through
many of the other tools that we've
covered in this series but you'll see
that xml or ruby or yaml are used as
languages to describe the configuration
for your environment this allows you to
then create the rules and instructions
that can be read by the machines that
are actually setting up the physical
hardware versus a traditional model
which is having software and installing
that software directly onto the machine
this is really important when it comes
to cloud computing there really is a
strong emphasis of being able to explain
infrastructure as a service and
infrastructure as code is fundamental to
the foundation to infrastructure as
service and then finally allows you to
be able to talk about how you can use
scripted languages such as yammer to be
able to create a consistent experience
for your entire network all right so
let's now get into the next section
which is source code management and
we're going to focus specifically on git
the reason being is that get is really
the most popular source code management
solution right now there are other
technologies out there but for the types
of distributed environments that we have
uh source code management with git is
probably the most effective so the first
question you'll be asked when it comes
to get is to talk about the difference
between centralized and distributed
version control and if we look at the
way that the two are set up older
technologies such as older versions of
team foundation server though the
current version does actually have git
in it but older versions required a
centralized server for you to check in
and check out of code the developer in
the centralized system does not have all
the files for the application and if the
centralized server crashes then you
actually lose all of the history of your
code now in contrast a distributed model
actually we do check in our code to a
server however for you to be effective
and building out your solution you
actually check out all of the code for
the solution directly onto your local
development machine so you can actually
have a copy of the entire solution
running on your local machine this
allows you to be able to work
effectively offline it really allows for
scalability when it comes to building
out your team so if you have a team that
may be in europe you can actually then
scale that team with people from asia
from north america or south america very
easily and not have to worry about
whether or not they have the right code
or the wrong code and in addition to
that if the actual main server where
you're checking in your code does crash
it's not a big deal because you actually
have each person has a copy of the code
so as soon as the server comes back up
you have to check back in and
everybody's running back as if there was
nothing that happened at all so one of
the questions you'll be asked is to give
the answer to some of the commands you
use for working with git so if you were
to be asked the question is what is the
git command that downloads any
repository from github to your computer
on the screen we have four options we
have git push git fork get clone and git
commit the answer in this instance would
be git clone now if you want to be able
to push code from your local system to a
github repository using git then first
of all you want to be able to do is
connect the local repository to a remote
repository and in the example you may
want to talk about using the command get
remote add origin and then the actual
path to a github repository you could if
you wanted to actually at this point
also talk about other repositories such
as get lab that you can also work with
or a private git repository that would
be used just for the development team
once you've actually then added the
local repository into your local
computer then the second action you want
to use is a push which is to actually
push your local files out to the master
environment so you use the command git
push origin master so one question you
may be asked is what is the difference
between a bare repository and a standard
way of initializing a get repository so
let's look through what is the standard
way so the standard way using git init
allows you to create a working directory
using the command git init and then the
folder that creates is the folder that
creates all the revision history related
to the work that you're doing in
contrast using the bear way you have a
different commands for setting that up
so it would be git init dash dash bear
and it does not contain any working or
checked out source files locally on your
machine in addition the revision history
is actually stored in the root folder
versus a subfolder that you would have
with the normal git init initialization
so which of the following cli commands
would you be used to rename a file so we
have git rm git mv git rm-r or none of
the above well in this instance it would
be gate mv a question that you'll be
asked around commit is going to be what
is the process to revert a commit that
has already been pushed and made public
and there are two ways you can address
this the first is to actually
address the bad file in the new commit
and you can use the command git commit
dash m and then put in a comment for why
that file is being removed the second is
to actually create a new commit that
actually undoes all the changes that
were made with the bad commit and then
to do that you would use git revert and
then the commit id and the commit id and
it could be something such as 560e
0938f but you'd have to find that from
the the
commit that you had made but that would
allow you to revert any bad files that
you had submitted so there are two ways
of being able to get files from a get
repository and you're going to be asked
to explain the difference between git
fetch and git pull so get fetch allows
you to fetch and download only new data
from a root new repository it does not
integrate any of the new data into your
working files and it can be undone
anytime if you want to break out the
remote tracking branches in contrast get
pull updates the current head branch
with the latest changes from the remote
server so you get all of the files and
downloaded it downloads new data and
integrates it with the current working
files you have on your system and it
tries to merge remote changes with your
local ones so one of the questions
you'll get asked about git is what is a
gate stash so as a developer you will be
working on the current branch within a
solution but what happens if you come up
with an idea where it's something that
will take a different amount of time for
you to be able to complete but you don't
want to interrupt the mainline branch so
what you can actually do is you can
actually create a branch that allows you
to start working on your own work
outside of the main line branch and this
is called git stash allows you to be
able to modify your files without
interrupting the mainline branch so you
once you start talking about branching
and get be prepared to answer and
explain the concept of branching so
essentially what it allows you to do is
have a mainline master branch that has
all the code that the team is checking
in and checking out against but allows
you to have an indefinite number of
branches that allows for new features to
be built in parallel to the mainline
branch and then at some point be
reintroduced to the main line branch to
allow the team to add in new features
and so if we look through the merge and
get rebase these are the two features
that you'd be using continuously to be
able to talk about how you take a branch
and merge it back into the mainline
branch so on the left hand side we have
git merge which allows you to take the
code that you're creating and merge it
back into the master on the right hand
side what you have is a slightly
different approach this is for projects
where you reach a point in a project
where you go okay we're going to
effectively restart the project at this
point in time and we want to ignore the
complete history that's happened before
that and that's called git rebase and
that would allow you to rewrite the
project history by creating a brand new
mainline branch that ignores all other
previous branches that have happened
before it you can if you want to very
quickly and easily find out all the
files that have been used to make a
particular commit so when somebody asks
you the question how do you find a list
of files has been changed in a
particular commit you can actually say
that all you have to go is find the
command git diff dash tree dash r and
then the hash that you'd use for the
commit and that would actually then give
you a breakdown of all the files that
have been made with that particular
commit a question you'll be asked when
you're talking about merging files is
what is a merge conflict in git and how
can it be resolved so essentially a
merge conflict is when you have uh two
or more branches that are competing with
commits in git and you have to be able
to determine which is the appropriate
files that need to be submitted and this
is where you would go in and to actually
help resolve this issue you'd actually
go in and manually edit the conflicted
files to select the changes you want to
keep in the final merge so let me go
through the steps that you would take to
be able to illustrate this when you're
talking about this particular question
in your interview now there are
essentially four stages the first would
be under the repository name you want to
select a pull request and you want to be
able to show how that pull request would
be demonstrated inside of github so
within the pull request there's going to
be a highlight of conflict markers and
you'll be able to select which conflicts
you want to keep on which you want to
merge and which ones you want to change
so it's a step through how you would
actually resolve a merge conflict and
the first step would be under github you
want to be able to pull the repository
name and then the pull request around
that repository in the pull request list
click the pull request with a merge
conflict and that you'd like to be able
to resolve now we'll pull up a file that
will list out all of the conflicts for
you near the bottom of that file will be
a list of the requests that need to be
resolved and then if you need to make a
decision on which branches you want to
keep or which ones you want to change
that will have to be something you have
to put in instructions inside of the
file you'll actually see that there are
conflict markers within the instructions
which are going to ask you which files
you want to change which ones you want
to keep if you have more than one merge
conflict in your file scroll down to the
next set of conflict markers and repeat
steps four and five until you resolve
all of the conflicts you will want to
mark your file as resolved in github so
that the repository knows that you are
having everything resolved if you have
more than one file with a conflict then
you want to go then onto the next file
and start working on those files and
just keep repeating the steps we've done
up to this point until you have all the
conflicts resolved and then once you
have all of the resolutions created then
you want to select the button which is
commit merge and then merge all your
files back into github and this will
take care and manage the resolution of
the merge conflict within github so you
can also do this through command line
and with the command line you want to
use get bash and so you want to as a
first step open up get bash and then
navigate to the local git repository in
command line by using the cd change
directory and then list out the actual
folder where you actually are putting
all of your code and then you want to be
able to generate a list of the files
that are affected with the merge
conflict and in this instance here you
can actually see the file
styleguy.md has a merged conflict in it
and as before with working with github
you actually go through and use a text
address and use any text editor but as
you go through and edit out what you
want to keep and what you want to
manage in your conflict so you actually
have a resolution that's been created so
that you'll be able to then once you
you're using the conflict markers you
can actually merge your files together
so that the solution itself will allow
you to
incorporate your commits effectively
into the resolution once you've gone
through and applied your changes you're
able to then merge the conflicted
commits into a single commit and able to
push that up to your remote repository
all right let's talk about the next
section which is continuous integration
with jenkins so the first question
you'll be asked about with jenkins is
explain a master slave architecture of
jenkins so the way that jenkins is set
up is that the jenkins master will pull
code from your remote git repository
such as github and will check that
repository every time there is a code
commit it will distribute the workload
of that code and the tests that need to
be applied to that code to all of the
jenkins slaves and then on requests the
jenkins master and the slaves will then
carry out all the builds and tests to be
able to produce test reports the next
question you'll be asked is what is a
jenkins file and simply put a jenkins
file is a text file that has a
definition of the jenkins pipeline and
is checked into a source code repository
and this really allows for three
distinct things to happen one it allows
for a code review and iteration of the
pipeline it permits an audit trail for
that pipeline and also provides a single
source of truth for the pipeline which
can be viewed and edited so which of the
following commands runs jenkins from the
command line is it java jar jenkins dot
war java dash war jenkins.jar
java.jar jenkins.jar java
jenkins.org
and the answer is a java jar jenkins dot
war so when working with jenkins you're
going to be asked what are the key
concepts and aspects of working with the
jenkins pipeline and you want to really
hold out your fingers here and go
through four key areas and that is
pipeline node step and stay so pipeline
refers to the user defined model of a cd
continuous delivery pipeline node are
the machines which is which are part of
that jenkins environment within the
pipeline step is a single task that
tells jenkins what to do at that
particular point in time and then
finally stage defines a conceptually
distinct subset of tasks performed
through the entire pipeline and tasks
could be build test and deploy so which
of the following file is used to define
dependency in maven and do we have a
build.xml
b
palm.xml c
dependency.xml or d
version.xml and the answer is
palm.xml working with jenkins you're
going to be asked to explain the two
types of pipeline used in jenkins along
with the syntax and so a scripted
pipeline is based on groovyscript as
their domain specific language for
jenkins and there are one or more note
blocks that are used throughout the
entire pipeline on the left hand side
you can actually see what the actual
script would look like and the right
hand side shows what the actual
declaration for each section of that
script would be the second type of
jenkins pipeline is a declarative
pipeline and a declarative pipeline
provides a simple and a friendly syntax
to define what the pipeline should look
like and then you can actually at this
point use an example to actually break
out how blocks are used to define the
work completed in a decorative pipeline
so how do you create a copy and backup
of jenkins well to create a backup
periodically back up jenkins to your
jenkins home directory and then create a
copy of that directory it's really as
simple as that a question you'll be
asked as well is how can you copy
jenkins from one server to another well
they're essentially there are three ways
to do that one is you can move a job
from one installation of jenkins to
another by copying the corresponding job
directory the second would be to create
a copy of an existing job directory and
making a clone of that job directory but
with a different name and the third is
to rename an existing job by renaming a
directory so security is fundamental to
all the work that we do within devops
and jenkins provides the center core to
all the work that gets completed within
a devops environment there are three
ways in which you can apply security to
authenticate users effectively and when
you're asked about this question of
security within jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a jenkins has its own internal
database that uses secured user data
from and user credentials b is you can
use a ldap or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate jenkins users or c you can
actually configure jenkins to
authenticate by using such as oauth
which is a more modern method of being
able to authenticate users you're going
to be asked how to deploy a custom build
of a core plug-in within jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through are first of all copying the
dot hpi plugin file into the jenkins
home plugins subdirectory you want to
remove the plugins development directory
if there is one you want to create an
empty file called
dot pinned and once you've completed
these three steps restart jenkins and
your custom build plugin should be
available how can you temporarily turn
off jenkins security if the
administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console this
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's good to know how you can
actually get into jenkins and be able to
resolve the problems of authenticating
effectively into the system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file you should see that it's
set to true which allows for security to
be enabled if you then change the user
security setting to false security will
disabled allow you to make your
administrative changes and will not be
re-enabled until the next time jenkins
is restarted
so what are the ways in which a build
can be scheduled and run in jenkins well
there are four ways in which you can
identify the way a build can be
scheduled on running jenkins the first
is when source code management commits
new code into the repository you can run
jenkins at that point the second can be
the after the completion of other builds
so maybe you have multiple builds in
your project that are dependent to each
other and when so many other builds have
been executed then you can have jenkins
run you can schedule build to run at a
specified time so you may have nightly
builds of your code that illustrates the
changes in the solution you're building
and then finally you also can manually
build a environment on request
occasionally you will want to also
restart jenkins and so it's good that
when a question around how do you
restart jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waiting for
bills to complete by using the jenkins
url that you have for your environment
slash restart or you can allow all
running bills to complete before restart
are required in which case you would use
the command of the url for your jenkins
environment
safe restart so let's go into the fourth
and final section of this first video
which talks about continuous testing
with selenium so the first question you
will be asked most likely around
selenium are what are the four different
selenium components and again you will
want to hold open your fingers because
there are four distinct environments you
have selenium integrated development
environment or selenium ide you have
selenium remote control or selenium rc
you have selenium web driver and then
selenium grid you'll be asked to explain
each of those areas in more detail but
let's start off with by looking at
selenium driver what are the different
exceptions in selenium webdriver so it's
useful to remember that an exception is
an event that occurs during the
execution of a program that disrupts the
normal flow of that program's
instructions and so we have four we have
a timeout exception an element not
visible exception no such element
exception and a session not found
exception and each of those if we step
through them are the four different
types of exceptions that can be thrown
up when using the selenium web driver so
as we evolve in our digital world with
the different types of products that are
available for us to be able to build
solutions onto multiple platforms you're
going to be asked can selenium and other
devops tools run in other environments
and so a good question around this is
cancelium test and application in an
android web browser and the short answer
is absolutely yes it can we have to use
the android driver for it to be able to
work so you want to be able to talk
about the three different types of
supported tests within selenium so when
the question comes up what are the
different test types supported by
selenium you can answer that and there
are three different types of tests first
is a functional test second is a
regression test and third is a load
testing test the functional test is a
kind of black box testing in which test
cases are based on a specific area of
feature within the software a regression
test helps you find any specific areas
that functional tests or non-functional
areas of the code wouldn't be able to
detect the load testing test allows you
to monitor the response of a solution as
you increase the volume of hits and how
you're using the code are put onto it an
additional question you'll be asked is
how can you get a text of a web element
using selenium well the get command is
due to achieve text of a specific web
element and it's important to remember
however that the command does not return
any parameters but just returns a string
value so you want to be able to capture
that stream value and discuss about it a
question you'll be asked around selenium
is can you handle keyboard and mouse
actions using selenium and the answer is
yes you can but you have to make sure
that you're using the advanced user
interaction api and the advanced user
interaction api is something that can be
scripted into your tests and it allows
you for capturing methods such as a
click and hold and drag and drop mass
events and then keyboard down or
keyboard up key release events so that
if you want to to capture say the use of
control shift or a specific function
button off the keyboard you'd be able to
capture those of the following four
elements which of these elements is not
a web element method a get text b
size c
get tag name d
send keys and it's b
size you're going to be asked to explain
what is the difference for when we use
find element or find elements and so if
we look at find element find element
finds the first element in the current
web page that matches the specified
located value in contrast find elements
finds all of the elements on the web
page that matches the specified value
when using webdriver what are the driver
close and driver quit commands and these
are two different methods used to close
a web browser session in selenium so
driver close will close the current web
browser in which your focus is set and
driver quick closes all the browser
windows and ends the web driver session
completely the final question that you
are likely to be asked in using selenium
is how can you submit a form using
selenium well in this instance that's
relatively easy the following lines of
code will let you submit a form in
selenium which would be web element el
equals driver dot find element and then
you put in the id and the element id and
then l submit open close parentheses
semicolon so let's just get into the
first section which is configuration
management so one of the questions that
you'll get asked right away is why do
you have ssl certificates used for chef
really fundamentally your immediate
answer should be security ssl provides
for a very high level of private
security and private and public key
pairing this really is essential to
ensure that you have a secure
environment throughout your entire
network the second part should be that
if you're using ssl and you're using the
private public key model within ssl
you're able to guarantee the systems on
your network that the chef that you'll
be able to validate that the nodes
within your network that chef is
validating against actually are the real
nodes themselves not imposters so you
will also be asked um some questions
such as the following which is the
following commands would you use to stop
or disable the http service when the
system boots and you'll typically get
four responses and they'll be hashtag
systemctl disable
dot httpd.service or is it system
disable http dot service system disable
httpd or the final option which is
system ctl disable httpd.service
your answer should be the first one
which is hashtag system ctl disable http
dot service
so chef comes with a series of tools
that allow it to function effectively
and one of the tools that you're going
to be asked about is what is test
kitchen and test kitchen is essentially
a command line tool that allows you to
be able to test out your cookbook before
you actually deploy it to a real note so
some of the commands that you would use
are for instance if you want to create
an instance of test kitchen you would do
kitchen create if you want to destroy an
instance after you created it you do
kitchen destroy and if you want to be
able to combine multiple instances you
would do kitchen converge so a question
you'll get is around chef is how does
chef apply differ from chef client so
fundamentally the difference between
them is that chef apply will validate
the recipe that you're working on
whereas chef client looks to apply and
validate the entire cookbook that's run
in your server environment so one is
focused on the recipe and the other is
focused on the entire cookbook
so there are some differences when
you're working with different command
lines so for instance when you're
working with puppets and you're working
with one version of puppet and you want
to do what is the command to sign a
requested certificate the top example
here is for public version 2.7 whereas
the lower option here is for puppet
version three now something to bear in
mind when you're going through your
interview process is that the tools that
are used within a continuous integration
continuous delivery devops model do vary
and so you want to be able to talk
knowledgeably about the different
versions of the tools so that when
you're talking to your interviewer
you're able to show the deep knowledge
that you have which open source or
community tools do you use to make
puppet more powerful and essentially
this question is going to be asking you
to look beyond the core foundation of
puppet itself and so the three options
you have is being able to track
configurations with jira which you
should be doing anyway but it's a great
way to be able to clearly communicate
the work that's being done with puppet
our version control can be extended with
get and then the changes should be
passed through jenkins so the three
tools you want to be looking at
integration with jira git and jenkins so
what are the resources in puppet well
fundamentally there are four the
resources are basic units of any
configuration management tool they are
the features of the nodes they are the
written catalog and the execution of the
catalog on a node so as we dig deeper
into puppet one of the things that you
are likely to be asked regarding puppet
is what is a class and puppet and so a
class in puppet is really the name
blocks in your manifest that contain the
various configurations and this can
include services files and packages and
we have on the screen here an example of
what a class would look like when you
write it out and you may want to
memorize just one class don't memorize
just a whole set of classes just
memorize one the person that's
interviewing you is just really looking
for someone who has a working knowledge
they're not looking for you to have
memorized complete massive classes but
having one small class to be able to
illustrate the experience you have is
extremely valuable to the interviewer
particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into ansible one
of the things that you're going to be
asked around ansible is what is ansible
role so a role is an independent block
of tasks and variable files and
templates embedded with inside of the
playbook so example we have here on the
screen actually shows you one role
within a playbook and in this role it is
to install tomcat on a node again as
with previous question within puppet of
a class it's probably good to have
memorized just one or two roles so you
can talk knowledgeably about ansible
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible when
should you be using the curly brackets
and so just as a frame of reference uh
there's often two different ways that
these kind of brackets are referred to
now they're either referred to as french
brackets or curly brackets either way
and what you'll be wanting to answer is
when would you use these specific types
of brackets within and support and
really the answer comes down to two
things one is that it makes it easier to
distinguish strings and undefined
variables and the second is for putting
together conditional statements when you
are actually using variables and the
example we have here is this prints the
value of and we have foo and we have to
then put in the variable conditional
statement of vu is defined as something
so what is the best way to make content
reusable and redistributable
with ansible and there's really
essentially three the first is to
include a sub module or another file in
your playbook the second is to import an
improvement of an include which ensures
that a file is added only once and then
the third is roles to manage the tasks
within the playbook
so a question you will be asked is
provide a differences between ansible
and puppets so if we look at ansible
it's a very easy agentless installation
it's based on python you can configure
it with yaml and there are no support
for windows in contrast puppet is an
agent-based installation it's written in
ruby the configuration files are written
in dsl and it has support on all popular
operating systems so we dig deeper into
the actual architecture ansible it has a
much more simple architecture and it's
definitely a push only architecture in
contrast to puppet it's a more
complicated but more sophisticated
architecture where you're able to have a
complete environment managed by the
puppet architecture so let's get on to
our next section which is
containerization
so let's go through and you're going to
be asked to explain what the
architecture of docker is and docker
really is the most popular
containerization environment so docker
uses a client server architecture and
the docker client is a service which
runs in a command line and and then the
docker daemon which is run as a rest api
within the command line will accept the
requests and interacts with the
operating system in order to build the
docker images and run the docker
containers and then the docker image is
a template of instructions which is used
to create containers the docker
container is an executable package of
applications and its dependencies
together and then finally the docker
registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among other
users so you'll also be asked to provide
what are the advantages of docker over
virtual machine and this is something
that comes up very consistently in fact
um you may want to even extend it as
having what are the differences between
having a dedicated machine a virtual
machine and a docker or docker-like
environment and really the the arguments
for docker are just absolutely fantastic
you know first of all docker does
contain and occupy docket containers
occupy significantly less space than a
virtual machine or a dedicated machine
the boot up time on docker is
significantly faster than a vm
containers have a much better
performance as they are hosted in a
single docker image docker is highly
efficient and very easy to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation docker data volumes can
be shared and reused among multiple
containers the argument against virtual
machines is significant and particularly
if you're going into an older
environment where a company is still
using actual dedicated hardware and
haven't moved to a cloud or cloud-like
environment your arguments for docker
are going to be very very persuasive be
very clear on what the advantages are
for docker over a virtual machine
because you want to be able to
succinctly share them with your team and
this is something that's important when
you're going through the interview
process but also equally important
particularly if you're working with a
company that's transitioning or going
through a digital transformation where
they aren't used to working with the
tools like docker you need to be able to
effectively share with that team what
the benefits are so how do we share
docker containers with different nodes
and in this instance what you want to be
able to do is leverage the power of
docker swarm so docker swarm is a tool
which allows the it administrators and
developers to create and manage clusters
of swarm nodes within the darker
platform and there are two elements to
the node there's the manager node and
then there's the the worker node the
manager node as you'd assume manages the
entire infrastructure and the working
node is actually the work of the agent
as it gets executed
so what are the commands to create a
docker swarm and so here we have an
example of what a manager node would
look like and once you've created a
swarm on your manager node you can now
add worker nodes to that swarm and again
when you're stepping through this
process be very precise in the execution
part that needs to be taken to be able
to effectively create a swarm so start
with the manager node and then you
create a worker node and then finally
when a node is initialized as a manager
node it can immediately create a token
and that token is used for the worker
nodes and associating the ip address
with the worker nodes question 17 how to
run multiple containers using a single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers a single service by using
docker compose and docker compose will
actually run each of the services in
isolation so that they can interact with
each other the language used to write
out the compose files that allow you to
run the service is called yaml and yamos
stands for yet another markup language
so what is the use of a docker file so a
docker file actually is used for
creating docker images using the build
command so let's go through and show on
the screen what that would look like and
this would be an opportunity where if
you're actually in a technical interview
you could potentially even ask hey can i
draw on a whiteboard and show you what
the architecture for using the build
command would look like and what the
process would look like um again when
you're going through an interview
process as someone who interviews a lot
of people one of the things i really
like is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different and
in this instance this is a great example
of where you can stand up to the
whiteboard and actually show what can
actually be done through actually
creating images on the whiteboard very
quickly little square boxes where you
can actually show the flow for creating
a build environment as an architect this
should be something that you're
comfortable doing and by doing it in the
interview and suddenly you want to ask
permission before you actually do it but
doing this in the interview really helps
demonstrate your comfortable feelings of
working with these kind of architecture
drawings so back to the question of
creating a docker file so we go through
and we have a docker file that actually
then goes ahead and creates the docker
image which then in turns creates the
docker container and then we are able to
push that out up to a docker hub and
then share that docker hub with
everybody else as part of the docker
registry with the whole network so what
are the differences between docker image
and docker containers so let's go
through the docker image so the docker
images are templates of a docker
container an image is built using a
docker file and it stores that docker
file in a docker repository or a docker
hub and and you can use docker hub as an
example and the image layer is a read
only file system the docker container is
a collection of the runtime instances of
a docker image and the containers are
created using docker images and they are
stored in the docker daemon and every
container is a layer is a read write
file system so you can't replace the
information you can only append to it
so while you can actually use yaml or
writing your so a question you can be
asked is instead of yammer what can be
an alternate file to build docker
compose so yaml is the one that is the
default but you can also use json so if
you are comfortable working with json
and my that is something that you should
be uh get comfortable with is you want
to be able to use that to name your
files and as a frame of reference json
is a logical way of being able to do
value paired matching using a javascript
like syntax
so you're going to be asked to how to
create a docker container so let's go
through what that would look and we'll
break it down task by task so the task
is going to be create a mysql docker
container so to do that you want to be
able to build a docker image or pull
from an existing docker image from a
docker repository or hub and then you
want to be able to then use docker to
create a new container which has my
sequel from the existing docker image
simultaneously the layer of read write
file system is also created on top of
that image and below at the bottom of
the screen we have what the commands
lines look for that so what is the
difference between a registry and a
repository so let's go through that so
for the docker registry and repository
for the registry we have docker registry
is an open source server-side service
used for hosting and distributing docker
images whereas in contrast for
repository it's a collection of multiple
versions of a docker image in a registry
a user can distinguish between docker
images with their tag names and then
finally on the registry docker also has
its own default retreat called docker
hub for the repository it is a
collection of multiple versions of
docker images it is stored in a docker
registry and it has two types of public
and private registry so you can actually
create your own enterprise registry so
you're going to be asked you know what
are the cloud platforms that support
docker really you know list them all and
we have listed here amazon web services
microsoft azure google cloud rackspace
but you could add in their ibm bluemix
could put in red hat really any of the
cloud service providers out there today
do support docker it's just become an
industry standard so what is the purpose
of expose and publish commands in docker
so if we go through expose is an
instruction used in docker file whereas
publish is used in docker run command
for expose it is used to expose ports
within a docker network whereas with
publishers can be used outside of a
docker environment for expose it is a
documenting instruction used at the time
of building an image and running a
container whereas with publish is used
as to map a host port to a running
container port for expose is the command
used in docker whereas for publish we
use the command-p for when we're doing
our command line used in docker and
examples of these are expose 8080 or
with docker we would put in or for
publish we'd do the example docker run
d dash p and then 0.0.0.80
a colon 80 as our command line so let's
look at continuous monitoring so with
continuous monitoring how does netgio's
help in continuous monitoring of systems
applications and servers and so this is
really just a high level question of
using nagios within your environment and
you should be able to just come back
very quickly and say nagios allows you
to help manage the servers and check if
they've been sufficiently utilized and
if there are any task failures that need
to be addressed and so there are three
areas of utilization and risk that you
want to be able to manage this is being
able to verify the status and services
of the entire network the health of your
infrastructure as a whole and if
applications are working properly
together with web services and apis that
are reachable
so the second question you'll be asked
is how does negatives help in continuous
monitoring of systems applications and
services so it's able to do this by
having the initial negative process and
scheduler and the additional plugins
that you would use for your network
connect with the remote resources and
the negative web interface to be able to
run status checks on a predefined
schedule so what do you mean by nagios
remote plug-in executor or the mpre of
nagios so mpre allows you to execute
plugins on links unix machines that
allow you to do additional monitoring
and machine metrics such as disk usage
cpu load etc
what are the ports used by nagios for
monitoring purposes in this example
there are three and they're easy to
remember so i would memorize these three
but they're essentially ports five six
six six
five six six seven and five six six
eight so there are two types of checks
within that year so you will be asked
for what is an active and passive check
in nagios so an active check and is
initiated by the nagios process and is
run on a regular schedule a passive
check is initiated and formed by an
external application or process so this
may be where a system is failing and
checks our results are submitted to
nagios for processing and to continue
with this for what is an active and
passive check active checks are
initiated by the check logic within the
nagios daemon negatives will execute a
plug-in and pass information about what
needs to be checked plug-in will then
check the operational state of the host
oil service and then process the results
of the host or service check and send
out notifications in contrast with the
passive check it is an external
application that initiates the check it
writes the results of the check to an
external command line file and i guess
reads the external command file and
places the results of all passive checks
in a queue for later processing so you
can go back and revalidate and then
negotiate may send out notifications log
alerts etc depending on the results that
they get from checking the information
so you're going to be asked to explain
the main configuration file and its
location in nagio so the main
configuration file consists of a number
of directives that affect how nagios
operate so consider this as the
configuration file that's read by both
nagios processor and the cgis so this
will allow you to be able to manage the
main configuration file that's placed
into your settings directory so what is
the nagios network analyzer and again
hold out your four fingers because there
are four options here so the nagios
network analyzer are one provides an
in-depth look at all your network
traffic source and security threats two
allows system admins to gather
high-level information on the health of
your network three provides a central
view of your network traffic and
bandwidth data and then four allows you
to proactive in resolving outages
abnormal behavior and threats before
they affect critical business processes
so what are the benefits of http and ssl
certificate monitoring with nagios so
with http certificate monitoring it
allows you to have increased server and
services and application availability
obviously very important fast detection
of network outages and protocol failures
and allows web transaction and web
service performance monitoring the ssl
certificate monitoring allows you for
increased website availability frequent
application availability and provides
increased security so explain
virtualization with nagios so in
responses the first thing you should be
able to talk about is how nagios itself
can run on many different virtualization
platforms including microsoft visual pc
vmware zen amazon ec2 etc etc so just
make sure you get that right off from
the bat is able to provide
capabilities tomorrow an assortment of
metrics on different platforms it allows
for ensure for quick detection of
service and application failures and has
the ability to be able to monitor
against many metrics including cpu usage
memory networking and vm status so name
the three variables that affect
recursion inheritance in nagios and it
is name use and register so name is a
template name that can be referenced in
other object definitions use
specifies the name of the template
object that you want to inherit its
properties and variables from and
register indicates whether or not the
object definition should be registered
to nagios and on the right hand side of
the screen we have an example of what
that script would look like again you
may want to be able to memorize this as
it's something that you can actually
write down and show someone if you're
going through a technical interview so
why is nagios said to be object oriented
and fundamentally comes down to the
object configuration format that you can
use in your object definitions it allows
you to inherit properties from other
object definitions and this is typical
of object oriented development and is
now applied for the nagios environment
so some of the objects that you can
inherit are surfaces hosts commands and
time periods so finally explain what is
state talking in nagios and so there are
really four options here when you're
talking about state stalking so state
stalking is used for logging purposes in
nagios it allows you to enable for a
particular host or service uh that
nagios will watch over very carefully it
will log any changes it sees in the
output of the check results and then
finally helps the analysis of log files
and so with that we come to the end of
this devops tools full course if you
have any doubts or queries let us know
in the comment section below
so watch out for more interesting videos
like these until then keep learning and
stay tuned to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you